THE SENATE COMMITTEE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US FOR THIS MEETING, THE
SENATE WELCOMES THE PUBLIC IN
PERSON, AND WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE Þ
STREET BUILDING. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 2200 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND BEGIN
OUR HEARING. I ENCOURAGE ALL
AUTHORS AND THE PUBLIC, TO BE AS
SHORT AS YOU CAN, TO THE POINT
SO WE CAN GET THROUGH OUR AGENDA
WITHOUT HAVING TO COME BACK, WE
WILL HAVE TO BREAK A LITTLE BIT
BEFORE NOON. AND IF WE HAVEN'T
FINISHED OUR HEARING, WE'LL NEED
TO COME BACK LATER IN THE DAY.
WE HAVE 22 BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. SEVEN BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT. LET ME GO THROUGH THEM
RIGHT NOW. ITEM NUMBER THREE, AB
598 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS.
ITEM SIX AB 1413 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING Ã. ITEM SEVEN AB
2004 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. ITEM EIGHT AB
2001 92 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO. ITEM 11 AB 2533 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO.
ITEM 14 AB 2262 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES AND ITEM 21 AB 3062
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN.
AND A FEW HOUSEKEEPING NOTES. WE
HAVE A SPECIAL ITEM TODAY BEING
CONSIDERED UNDER OUR SENATE RULE
2910 D AND THAT IS SB 739 BY
SENATOR ASHBY. THIS BILL IS
COMING BACK TO US FOR
CONCURRENCE. IS SENATOR ASHBY
HERE? NO, SHE'S NOT OKAY. WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM. WE WILL OPERATE
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE, WE DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM, BUT WE WILL START, SO
WE HAVE SENATOR CORTEZ, IF YOU
WILL COME UP. WELCOME, SENATOR
CORTEZ. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SCR 163, WHICH WOULD
REAFFIRM THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF
LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSIONS FOR OVER HALF A
CENTURY, LAFCOS HAVE PROMOTED
ORDERLY DEVELOPMENT AND BALANCED
IT WITH SOMETIMES COMPETING
STATE INTERESTS OF DISCOURAGING
URBAN SPRAWL, PRESERVING OPEN
SPACE AND PRIME AGRICULTURAL
LANDS, AND EFFICIENTLY EXTENDING
GOVERNMENT SERVICES. EACH COUNTY
IN THE STATE HAS A LAFCO, WHICH
IS COMPOSED OF ELECTED CITY AND
COUNTY MEMBERS, AT LEAST ONE
PUBLIC MEMBER, AND, IN 32
COUNTIES, SPECIAL DISTRICT
MEMBERS. AS WELL. THE LOCAL
LAFCO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
FORMATION OF COUNTY SERVICE
AREAS, WHICH ENABLE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES, INCLUDING WATER AND
SANITATION, TO BE PROVIDED IN A
GIVEN AREA. THESE OFFICIALS ARE
UNIQUELY QUALIFIED TO DETERMINE
WHETHER A PROJECT IS FEASIBLE IN
A GIVEN AREA WITHOUT AN
APPLICATION TO IT. A DECISION
FROM LAFCO GUARANTEES ABOUT
SERVICES FROM THE PROPONENTS OF
URBAN DEVELOPMENTS HAVE NO
WEIGHT BEHIND THEM, I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN SOME GENERAL
CONCERN AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THE
RESOLUTION IS IN SOME WAY. DIS
ACKNOWLEDGING, IF YOU WILL, THE
ACUTE NEED FOR MORE HOUSING. I'M
CERTAINLY A HUGE PROPONENT OF
HOUSING PRODUCTION, BUT I'M ALSO
A HUGE PROPONENT, PROPONENT OF
ORDERLY GROWTH. AND THAT'S, THE
ONLY REAL REASON FOR THE
RESOLUTION IS TO COME FORWARD
AND REMIND FOLKS ON AN ACT THAT
WAS CREATED IN 1963, AMENDED,
OVER A DECADE LATER, AFTER A
FOUR YEAR EFFORT, AND THEN
AMENDED AGAIN BY OUR GOOD FORMER
COLLEAGUE, MADAM CHAIR, SENATOR
HERTZBERG. AFTER ANOTHER FOUR
YEAR EFFORT, THAT IT'S A BODY OF
WORK THAT'S WORKED VERY, VERY
WELL, IN TERMS OF ORDERLY GROWTH.
AND I SUPPOSE THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF MEMBERS EITHER BECAUSE
OF, THE FACT THAT THEY HAVEN'T
HAD A LOT OF EXPERIENCE AT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL. SOME OF
US HAVE, SOME HAVEN'T, THAT THIS
IS REALLY JUST, A RESTATEMENT OF
WHAT ALREADY EXISTS WITH, OF
COURSE, BEING A RESOLUTION. NO,
NO INTENT WHATSOEVER TO CHANGE
THE LAW. WITH THAT, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES? NONE. OKAY. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES? WELL, LET'S JUST
DO IN SUPPORT. SO ALL THOSE IN
SUPPORT, WOULD YOU PLEASE COME
FORWARD? GOOD MORNING, ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT? SEEING NONE. ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. GOOD MORNING. I
COMPLETELY SUPPORT THIS,
AMENDMENT OR A REAFFIRMATION OF
LAFCOS. I'M ADRIANA ROMO. I'M
THE DEPUTY EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
THE LOS ANGELES LAFCO. THANK
YOU, MR. CURTIS. OKAY, I DIDN'T
I HAD ASKED FOR OPPOSITION, BUT
WHICH ARE YOU? I'M IN THE
OPPOSITION. OKAY. GO AHEAD, NICK
CAMERON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, JUST HERE TO POINT
OUT TWO CONCERNS WITH THE
RESOLUTION, AS IT'S CURRENTLY
DRAFTED. I THINK THE FIRST IS
THAT WE ARE WE ARE STATING THAT
LAFCOS HAVE THE SOLE AND
EXCLUSIVE AUTHORITY TO ENGAGE IN
PROCESSING, INITIATING,
CONDUCTING AND COMPLETING
CHANGES OF ORGANIZATION AND
EXTRATERRITORIAL SERVICES OR
REORGANIZATIONS AS WELL. I DON'T
THINK IT'S EVEN BY THE TERMS OF
THE LAFCO LAW. I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT'S AN ACCURATE
STATEMENT, BECAUSE THOSE THAT
PROCESS BEGINS WITH CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND DISTRICTS ADOPTING
A RESOLUTION TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS. AND IN ADDITION TO
THAT, IT LANDOWNERS AND VOTERS
BY PETITION CAN DO THE SAME. AND
WE DON'T WANT TO CREATE THE
IMPRESSION THAT SOMEHOW IN THIS
RESOLUTION, WE'RE BLOCKING THAT
PROCESS. I, I KNOW THAT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS RECOGNIZES
THIS FACT. IT IS ALSO AVAILABLE
FOR LAFCOS THEMSELVES TO
INITIATE PROCEEDINGS AND SO WE
WANT TO HAVE A RESOLUTION THAT
MORE ACCURATELY, I THINK, STATES
WHAT THE LAW IS. I THINK THAT
EVEN IN THE CONDUCTING OF THESE
PROCEEDINGS, THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA HAS A UNIQUE SITUATION
WHERE THEIR CITIES ACTUALLY, IN
SOME CIRCUMSTANCES, CONDUCT THE
ORGANIZATION CHANGE,
ORGANIZATION CHANGE, OR OF
REORGANIZATION. THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS AS WELL. SO IT'S NOT A
UNIVERSAL STATEMENT THAT THEY
HAVE THAT LAFCOS HAVE THE SOLE
AND EXCLUSIVE AUTHORITY. THE
CITIES THEMSELVES, IN THAT CASE,
DO IT. I THINK FINALLY, WHAT WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE IS A REFERENCE
TO ONE PARTICULAR PROJECT,
BECAUSE THE LAW, ASSUMING THAT
THIS BECOMES ACTUALLY, MORE
ACCURATELY STATED IN THE
RESOLUTION THAT IT SHOULD APPLY
TO ALL PROJECTS. AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE ALL AGREE
ON. SO FOR THOSE TWO REASONS,
WE'D LIKE TO SEE, THE BILL, THE
RESOLUTION MODIFIED. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? OKAY. SEEING
NONE, YES. SENATOR WIENER, I
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, SO I'M.
I'LL BE HONEST, SENATOR, I'M A
LITTLE, PERPLEXED BY THE. MAYBE
THAT'S THE WRONG WORD, BUT I'M
TRYING TO GET MY HEAD AROUND
THIS RESOLUTION, FIRST OF ALL,
I'M TRYING TO SAY WHY. WHY? IT'S
NEEDED, THE LAW IS WHAT IT IS.
RIGHT ON LAFCOS AND FOR
CALIFORNIA FOREVER. AND I WANT
TO SAY FOR CALIFORNIA FOREVER OR
ANY OTHER SITUATION. IF LAFCO
HAS THE FINAL SAY, DESPITE OTHER
AGENCIES APPROVING SOMETHING OR
THE VOTERS, THEN THAT IS WHAT IT
IS, SO WHY WHY DOES WHY DO WE
NEED TO HAVE A RESOLUTION?
STATING WHAT THE LAW IS? I MEAN,
PUTTING ASIDE THAT THERE'S A
DISPUTE ABOUT WHETHER THE
RESOLUTION ACCURATELY STATES THE
LAW, BUT WHY DO WHY WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF DOING SO?
WELL, LET ME AND IF I MAY, LET
ME ALSO ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION.
WE'VE ALREADY AGREED THAT THE
LANGUAGE THAT THE OPPOSITION
BROUGHT OUT NEEDS TO BE CHANGED.
THAT'S COMMUNICATION, THAT'S
THAT WE'VE GONE BACK AND FORTH
WITH, WITH CBIA, NO DISPUTE
WHATSOEVER IN TERMS OF THE WAY
IT WAS JUST CHARACTERIZED. AND
THAT'S JUST, SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO GO BACK THROUGH.
ALLEGED COUNCIL WILL NEED TO
AMEND THE DN AND THEN CROSS IT
BEFORE THE FOR IF WE GET OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY, AND IT DOESN'T
IMPACT BACK TO YOUR QUESTION.
YOU KNOW THE WHY, OR YOU KNOW,
ANY OF THE, THE GENERAL INTENT
FOR THE RESOLUTION. IT HAS BEEN,
24 YEARS SINCE THE LEGISLATURE
REALLY TOOK UP AND HAD A
DISCUSSION IN A COMMITTEE OR ON
THE FLOOR, TO THE EXTENT MEMBERS
WANT TO DO THAT, OBVIOUSLY YOU
WERE INTERESTED ENOUGH, YOU
KNOW, TO ENGAGE, ENGAGE ME
TODAY. THAT'S THE PURPOSE. IT'S
I THINK A TREMENDOUS BODY OF
WORK THAT'S BEEN, YOU KNOW,
FIRST CREATED IN 1963. AS I
SAID, WE ALL KNOW THAT, YOU
KNOW, YEARS AND YEARS OF WORK
HAS GONE INTO IT ON TWO SEPARATE
OCCASIONS, TO, TO MAKE SURE
IT'S, IT'S RIGHT. AND IT, AND
IT'S A GOOD COROLLARY, YOU KNOW,
TO THE VALUES OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF, OF HOW
WE WANT GROWTH TO PROCEED. SO
THIS IS JUST ELEVATING THAT.
IT'S JUST CREATING AWARENESS AND
REALLY NOTHING MORE THAN THAT.
THERE'S NOTHING IN IT THAT WOULD
CHANGE THE LAW WHATSOEVER. AND I
THINK THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS,
YOU KNOW, DID A GREAT JOB OF
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT AND REALLY
CLOSING OUT THE ANALYSIS BY
SAYING, YOU KNOW, BY SAYING
THAT. YEAH. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. I, AND I JUST, YOU KNOW, I
WILL SAY IN TERMS OF CALIFORNIA
FOREVER, I HAVE VERY
CONSISTENTLY DECLINED TO TAKE A
POSITION ON THAT PROJECT, BE
INVOLVED, WITH IT. THERE ARE
PLENTY OF PEOPLE WHO ARE,
INVOLVED. SO I, YOU KNOW, IT'S
JUST NOT A PROJECT THAT I AM IN
ANY WAY INVOLVED WITH OR THAT
I'VE TAKEN A POSITION ON, I DO
HAVE CONCERNS THAT THIS
POTENTIALLY, EITHER IS OR COULD
BE PERCEIVED AS THE LEGISLATURE
PUTTING ITS THUMB ON THE SCALE
IN TERMS OF THAT PROJECT. AND SO
THAT'S SORT OF A CONCERN, THAT I
HAVE, BUT I'M GLAD YOU'RE
WORKING WITH, WITH WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO AT LEAST MAKE SURE
THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT THE
RESOLUTION FULLY, ACCURATELY
DESCRIBES THE LAW. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. YEAH. LET ME
JUST SAY THAT THE RESOLUTION
ITSELF IS PROJECT NEUTRAL. YOU
KNOW, IT TALKS ABOUT GENERAL
CONCERNS ABOUT, YOU KNOW, SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT ONE WOULD BE
WORRIED, WORRIED ABOUT IF WE
DIDN'T IF WE HAD NOT DELEGATED
STATE POWERS, YOU KNOW, THROUGH
THE COUNTIES TO LAFCOS. AND, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THUMB
ON THE SCALE. THESE ARE THESE
ARE STATE CONCERNS. LAFCO WOULD
HAVE NO POWER AT ALL, AND THE
COUNTIES WOULD HAVE NO POWER AT
ALL IF NOT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO WE'RE JUST, THE
ACT ITSELF WAS CREATED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WE'RE NOT
AMENDING IT HERE. WE'RE JUST,
AGAIN, CREATING AWARENESS AROUND
IT. THE ANALYSIS DOES REFER TO
THAT PROJECT, AND I DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT. I CERTAINLY
DON'T BLAME THE COMMITTEE, YOU
CAN HOLD OUT PROBABLY ANY NUMBER
OF A HALF DOZEN, CIRCUMSTANCES
AROUND THE STATE WHERE LOCAL
LAFCOS ARE GOING TO BE ENGAGED.
ULTIMATELY, I THINK, IN, YOU
KNOW, ESTABLISHING BOUNDARIES
AND MAKING SURE FIRE SERVICES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE
ADEQUATE FOR, FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE BEING
CONTEMPLATED AND THE
JURISDICTIONAL ISSUES THAT ARE
BEING CONTEMPLATED. SO I DON'T I
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR I'M NOT
FAULTING THE COMMITTEE AT ALL
FOR HOLDING OUT THAT PROJECT.
WE'VE CERTAINLY HAD DISCUSSIONS
ALONG THE WAY ABOUT WHAT ARE
EXAMPLES OF AREAS THAT THIS MAY
BE OF CONCERN. AND, AND SO, YOU
KNOW, I'M COMPLICIT IN THAT. BUT
I TOO HAVE NOT TAKEN ANY
POSITION PUBLICLY OR OTHERWISE
ON, ON THAT PARTICULAR PROJECT,
ALTHOUGH I WILL NOTE THAT I
THINK AT THE END OF THE
RESOLUTION, IT DOES REFER TO,
CORPORATE INTERESTS PURCHASING
THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF FARMLAND.
MAYBE THERE'S ANOTHER PROJECT
AROUND THE STATE WHERE THAT'S
THERE'S A LOT OF THEM HAPPENING
AT THAT. AT THAT SCALE, THERE'S
AN ENTIRE DOCUMENTARY THAT'S
BEEN PREMIERED HERE, OVER ON K
STREET ABOUT, LAND GRABS THAT
ARE GOING ON UP AND DOWN THE
STATE AND, YOU KNOW, I WOULD
RECOMMEND EVERY SINGLE
LEGISLATOR, LEGISLATOR AMONGST
OUR COLLEAGUES, YOU KNOW, WATCH
THAT, IT'S COMPELLING, IT'S
POWERFUL. AND IT'S, IT'S FINALLY
RECEIVED, YOU KNOW, GLOBAL
DISTRIBUTION. SO, WE'RE NOT
OVERREACTING TO THAT. I'M NOT
OVERREACTING TO THAT. BUT I
THINK IT'S, IT IT MAKES ONE
WONDER IF THE LEVEL OF AWARENESS
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE STRUCTURE
THAT WE DO HAVE IN PLACE, THE
GOVERNMENTAL STRUCTURE WE DO
HAVE IN PLACE TO DEAL WITH THOSE
THINGS IS, IS REALLY OUT THERE,
IT WAS JUST OVER A YEAR AGO, IN
PART, IN PART RELATED, I THINK,
TO THE, TO THE SOLANO PROJECT
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO, THAT
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS WERE HELD
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE. JOHN
GARAMENDI, AMONG OTHERS,
CONGRESSMAN, YOU KNOW, TESTIFIED
AS TO GENERAL CONCERNS. AND ONE
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME
OUT OF THAT COMMITTEE, YOU KNOW,
IN THE GIVE AND TAKE WITH THE
PANELIST WAS IT'S PROBABLY TIME
FOR A REAFFIRMATION OF LAFCO,
AND HERE IT IS. SO, OKAY. I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SENATOR, ANY COMMENTS?
OKAY. THANK YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO HAVE CLOSING REMARKS? I THINK
I'VE DONE ENOUGH OF THAT. BUT I
DO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. AND AGAIN, I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
COOPERATION WITH THIS. THANK
YOU. OH, WE DON'T HAVE THE OKAY.
WE'LL DO WE WILL HAVE THE VOTE
LATER, NOW WE WANT TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM ONE. SB 739. SENATOR ASHBY,
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING,
COLLEAGUES. MADAM CHAIR, NICE TO
SEE YOU THIS MORNING. I AM HERE
TO PRESENT SB 739, WHICH ALLOWS
THE CITY OF ELK GROVE TO UTILIZE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER AT RISK
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS FOR A NEW
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL ZOO IN ELK
GROVE UNDER A TYPICAL DELIVERY
PROCESS, A CITY IS REQUIRED TO
COMPLETE ALL CONSTRUCTION
DRAWINGS AND BID THE ENTIRE
PROJECT AS A COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE, WHICH EXTENDS THE
DESIGN TIME AND CONSTRUCTION
DURATION, ULTIMATELY INCREASING
COSTS ON A PROJECT. HOWEVER, A
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER AT RISK,
WHICH IS A CMR MODEL, ALLOWS A
CITY TO HIRE A CONSTRUCTION
MANAGER EARLY IN THE PROCESS.
THIS HELPS STREAMLINE THE
DELIVERY METHODOLOGY. IT
IMPROVES COST ESTIMATING AND
QUICKLY DELIVERS CONSTRUCTION
RELATED RECOMMENDATIONS. SB 739
SEEKS TO ALLOW THE CITY OF ELK
GROVE TO UTILIZE THIS MODEL
DURING THE CONSTRUCTION OF THEIR
NEW AND EXCITING ZOO, UTILIZING
THIS MODEL FOR THE ONSET OF THE
PROJECT CAN HELP FURTHER ALIGN
THE DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION, BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY, CONTROL COSTS.
SB 739 IS A CRUCIAL STEP TOWARDS
BRINGING THIS ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY TO MY DISTRICT. THE
BILLS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SO FAR. I
THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE HERE
PEOPLE HERE TO TESTIFY. ROD
BREWER, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ELK GROVE. HE IS A COUNCIL
MEMBER. AND JASON JACOBS, ON
BEHALF OF THE SACRAMENTO ZOO
BOARD. THERE'S ROD. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
ROD BREWER, IN THIS CAPACITY AS
THE VICE MAYOR OF ELK GROVE, THE
ZOO IS ACTUALLY IN MY DISTRICT,
AND I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
ASHBY FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND
CARRYING THIS BILL AND MOVING
THIS PROJECT FORWARD, BECAUSE
THIS, THIS PROJECT THAT WE'RE
DOING IS GOING TO BE
TRANSFORMATIONAL NOT ONLY FOR
THE CITY OF ELK GROVE, BUT FOR
THE SACRAMENTO REGION ITSELF,
AND THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE NEW
ZOO WILL GENERATE NOT ONLY A
SHORT TERM ECONOMIC IMPACT FROM
ITS CONSTRUCTION, BUT WOULD ALSO
DELIVER ONGOING ECONOMIC
BENEFITS THAT WOULD SUPPORT THE
REGIONAL ECONOMY. THE PROJECT IS
ESTIMATED TO PRODUCE 2400
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND HAVE A
$249 MILLION TOTAL ECONOMIC
IMPACT OVER FIVE YEARS. THE
FIRST FIVE YEARS THE CITY HAS A
COMMUNITY WORKFORCE TRAINING
AGREEMENT WITH LOCAL TRADE
UNIONS. THE NEW ZOO PROJECT
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THAT
AGREEMENT. SENATE BILL 739 WOULD
NOT ONLY CREATE WOULD NOT CREATE
ANY BURDEN FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
3739. WITH YOUR LEADERSHIP, THE
CITY OF ELK GROVE WILL BE ABLE
TO BRING AN ENTIRELY NEW LEVEL
OF EXPERIENCE TO THE SACRAMENTO
REGION THAT WILL FOREVER
REDEFINE ZOOLOGICAL PARKS, NOT
ONLY HERE, BUT NATIONWIDE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS JASON JACOBS AND I SERVE
AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SACRAMENTO ZOO. MANY ANIMALS
THAT WE CARE FOR, SUCH AS LIONS
AND GIRAFFES, ARE FACING
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD. THAT DOESN'T EVEN
COUNT LOCAL SPECIES THAT WE TAKE
CARE OF. LIKE THE WESTERN POND
TURTLES, ACCREDITED ZOOS PROVIDE
A VITAL SERVICE NOT ONLY FOR
WILDLIFE, BUT ALSO FOR PEOPLE.
ZOOS CONTRIBUTE RESOURCES FOR
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION, AS WELL
AS CARING FOR POPULATIONS OF
RARE AND ENDANGERED SPECIES.
ZOOLOGICAL PARKS ALSO SERVE AS
CORNERSTONES FOR OUR COMMUNITY,
WITH INCREDIBLE EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCES. THE NEW REGIONAL
ZOO, LOCATED IN ELK GROVE, WILL
SERVE AS A CONDUIT BETWEEN
PEOPLE AND WILDLIFE. THE CURRENT
ZOO SEES OVER HALF A MILLION
GUESTS PER YEAR ON A LIMITED
FOOTPRINT, WITH NO PARKING AND
NO ROOM FOR EXPANSION, THE NEW
ZOO WILL BE CAPABLE OF HOSTING
WELL OVER HALF. I'M SORRY, WELL
OVER A MILLION VISITORS PER YEAR
WHILE SERVING A CRUCIAL ROLE OF
CONSERVATION AND EDUCATION.
CERTAINLY, THE MAJORITY OF THE
VISITORS FOR THIS NEW PROPOSAL
WILL NEVER GET THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TRAVEL TO AFRICA TO GO ON
SAFARI, AND THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO BUILD IN ELK GROVE.
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE A WINDOW TO
THE WILD AND PROVIDE AN
EXPERIENCE LIKE NONE OTHER. IT'S
A VERY COMPLEX PROJECT AND
THAT'S WHY WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON SB 739. WE CARE FOR
THOUSANDS OF ANIMALS, RANGING
FROM A ONE AND A HALF POUND
MEERKAT TO A 4,500 POUND
RHINOCEROS WHO, BY THE WAY, IS
THE LARGEST RESIDENT OF THE
SACRAMENTO REGION, IT IS AN
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED PROCESS TO
PROVIDE HOMES, INCREDIBLE HOMES
FOR THESE ANIMALS AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. WE THANK SENATOR
ASHBY FOR HER SUPPORT ON THIS
PROJECT, SHE'S BEEN A FAN OF
THIS PROJECT SINCE THE
BEGINNING, AND WE HOPE THAT YOU
WILL HELP US CREATE SOMETHING
INCREDIBLE NOT ONLY FOR ANIMALS,
BUT FOR PEOPLE IN THIS REGION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY WE
HAVE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT?
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I'LL BE
BRIEF. KEITH DUNN, ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL AND SUPPORT, I
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR AND HER
EFFORTS ON THIS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT? SB 739 SEEING NONE ANY,
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? Þ SEEING
NONE. OKAY. BRING IT UP TO DÍAS
AND SENATORS. ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? MOVE THE BILL.
THERE'S NO QUORUM. OH, RIGHT.
OKAY. NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS,
SENATOR, YOU MAY CLOSE. WELL, I
GUESS ON BEHALF OF MY LARGEST
CONSTITUENT AND ALL THE LITTLE
ONES, TOO, WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT, I WOULD APPRECIATE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PUT
THAT, AB. OKAY OKAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS. GOOD MORNING, I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
THE 2243. OKAY ALL RIGHT. WE
WILL MOVE TO ITEM FIVE AB 2243
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS, THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS,
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB 2243, A
BILL THAT CLEAR TO CLARIFY AND
EXPAND AB 2011. FIRST OF ALL,
I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY AND APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE ON
THAT. I WANT TO CALL OUT THAT
THEY RESTORED THE EXISTING
PROVISION IN AB 2011 THAT
REQUIRE PROJECTS TO BE AT LEAST
3200FT FROM OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION AND REFINEMENT. MY
GOAL AS A LEGISLATOR IS TO
FACILITATE ABUNDANT HOUSING THAT
IS BOTH CLIMATE FRIENDLY AND
SAFE. TOWARDS THAT END, WE'VE
BEEN SPENDING THE PAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH
AIR QUALITY EXPERTS, HVAC
EXPERTS AND ARCHITECTS TO FIND A
WAY TO ENSURE THAT THE SAFETY OF
RESIDENTS AND THE BUILDING
WITHIN 3200FT OF OIL AND GAS IS
SUFFICIENT. AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THOUGH, WE CONCLUDED THAT
WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY YET, WHICH IS WHY WE
PROPOSED THIS AMENDMENT. SO FOR
NOW, I'LL CONTINUE TO HELP,
REDUCE OIL EXTRACTION OR
COMMUNITIES, TO HELP EXISTING
RESIDENTS AND TO FREE UP MORE
LAND FOR AB 2011. THE OTHER
ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
GROUPS IS APPLYING AB 2011
WITHIN 500FT OF FREEWAYS, WHILE
IT'S NOT BEING REQUESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE, WE'RE ALSO COMMITTED
TO AMENDING THE BILL AT THE NEXT
OPPORTUNITY TO STEP UP THE AIR
FILTRATION IN THOSE AREAS TO
MERV AND REQUIRE CENTRAL AIR.
AND WHILE WE'RE WORKING WITH,
AND SORRY, AND WE'LL KEEP
WORKING WITH THE EJ GROUPS OVER
THE SUMMER RECESS TO FINE TUNE
THOSE DETAILS. THEY HAVE BEEN
VERY HELPFUL IN THE CONVERSATION
AS FAR AS THE REST OF THE BILL.
AB 2011, ALSO KNOWN AS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HIGH
ROADS JOB ACT OF 2022, WAS A
BILL I AUTHORED IN 2022. IT
ALLOWS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
MULTIFAMILY INFILL HOUSING IN
AREAS ZONED FOR RETAIL, OFFICE
AND PARKING LOTS IN RETURN FOR
MAKING THOSE HOUSES THAT THESE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS BY RIGHT,
DEVELOPERS NEED TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON SITE AND
ENSURE THAT THE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ARE PAID THE PREVAILING
WAGE. SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF AB
2011, THERE HAVE BEEN
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES TO THE
ECONOMY, INCLUDING THE COLLAPSE
OF DEMAND FOR OFFICE SPACE, THE
REDUCED DEMAND FOR BRICK AND
MORTAR RETAIL, AND THE
INCREASING INTEREST RATES. THOSE
CHANGES HAVE CREATED BOTH THE
DEMAND AND OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
OPEN UP. SITES FOR HOUSING MIGHT
BE ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE.
ADDITIONALLY, SINCE AB 2011 IS
ENACTMENT, HOUSING DEVELOPERS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
IDENTIFIED ASPECTS OF THE LAW'S
LANGUAGE THAT ARE SUBJECTIVE AND
OPEN TO INTERPRETATION. THE
SUBJECTIVITY HAS LED TO PROJECT
DELAYS AND DISSUADED UTILIZATION
OF THE LAW. IT IS ALSO LED TO
INCONSISTENT APPLICATION ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS AND CREATED THE
POTENTIAL FOR UNNECESSARY
LAWSUITS. AB 2243 WOULD ADDRESS
BOTH OF THESE ISSUES BY
EXPANDING AB 2011 GEOGRAPHIC
APPLICABILITY AND CLARIFYING
ASPECTS OF THE LAW THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO INTERPRETATION IN
TERMS OF GEOGRAPHIC EXPANSION.
AB 2243 WOULD APPLY AB 2011 TO
THE FOLLOWING TYPES OF PROJECTS.
SITES WITHIN 500FT OF FREEWAYS.
AS I MENTIONED, REGIONAL MALLS
THAT EXCEED 20 ACRES IN SIZE.
THE CONVERSION OF OFFICE TO
HOUSING, EVEN IF THE SITE IS NOT
ALONG A MAJOR COMMERCIAL
CORRIDOR, AND TO A EXISTING HIGH
RISE DISTRICTS, EVEN IF THE SITE
IS NOT ALONG A COMMERCIAL
CORRIDOR. IN TERMS OF REMOVING
SUBJECTIVITY, AB 2243 INCLUDES A
SERIES OF CLARIFICATIONS,
INCLUDING CLARIFYING THAT ALL
ASPECTS OF AB 2011 PROJECTS ARE
MINISTERIAL AND NOT SUBJECT TO
SEQUA. CLARIFYING HOW AB 2011
INTERSECTS WITH DENSITY BONUS
LAW AND SUBJECTING AND SORRY,
AND SPECIFYING THAT ANY SITE
REMEDIATION NEEDS TO OCCUR AFTER
PROJECT APPROVAL, BUT BEFORE THE
SITE CAN BE OCCUPIED.
IMPORTANTLY, AB 2243 DOES NOT
TOUCH AB 2011 LABOR STANDARDS OR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STANDARDS,
WHICH IS WHY IT IS STILL
SUPPORTED. BY 2011, A DIVERSE
COALITION OF CONSTRUCTION,
LABOR, SEIU, CA, AFFORDABLE AND
MARKET RATE DEVELOPERS AND OTHER
PRO-HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS. SO AB
2011 HAS BEEN IN EFFECT FOR
ABOUT A YEAR, ACTUALLY ALMOST A
YEAR TO THE DAY JULY 1ST, DURING
THIS PERIOD, OBVIOUSLY WE'VE
SEEN HIGH INTEREST RATES, YOU
KNOW, WE'VE SEEN PROJECTS THAT
HAVE IN MY DISTRICT, WE'VE HAD
THE NORTH BERKELEY BART, WHICH
HAS BEEN AN ONGOING CONVERSATION
OF HOW WE'RE GOING TO DEVELOP
THAT YEARS AND YEARS IN THE
MAKING. THEY'RE NOW USING AB
2011 TO HELP EXPEDITE THAT
PROCESS FOR THOUGHTFUL HOUSING.
WE'RE SEEING PROJECTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO, PROJECTS ALL OVER THE
STATE TRYING TO UTILIZE AB 2011.
WE'RE ALSO RECOGNIZING SOME OF
THE WEAKNESSES. AND I THINK, YOU
KNOW, AND I SAID THIS IN LAST
COMMITTEE, I'M IN MY SIXTH YEAR
OF 12 YEARS. AND SO I THINK OF
MYSELF NOW AS LIKE LEGISLATIVELY
MIDDLE AGED, YOU KNOW, AND HAVE
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
THIS WORKS. AND HOUSING LAW IS
VERY COMPLICATED, YOU KNOW, WE
WENT THROUGH A LOT TO GET AB
2011 PASSED. IT WAS A BIG LIFT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT WORKS.
AND SO I THINK AS IMPORTANT AS
THE FIRST BILL THAT WE PUT OUT
THERE IS EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT IS
NOW ITS IMPLEMENTATION AND HOW
WE ACTUALLY MAKE IT WORK BETTER.
SO THIS IS REALLY BORN OUT OF A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
BILL CAN THIS LAW CAN BE USED
MOST EFFECTIVELY TO BUILD THE
HOUSING THAT WE NEED TO, WORKING
WITH A DIVERSE COALITION OF
LABOR AND OTHERS TO SUPPORT IT.
SO I'M HONORED TO HAVE BEEN THE
ORIGINAL AUTHOR, THRILLED TO BE
WORKING ON THE CROSSING THE T'S
AND DOTTING THE I'S TO MAKE SURE
IT APPLIES IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY POSSIBLE. AND WHEN THE TIME
IS RIGHT, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. AND WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY, I BELIEVE, IS COREY
SMITH. YEP. FROM THE HOUSING
ACTION COALITION. AND DANNY
CURTIN FROM THE CARPENTERS. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, COREY SMITH, ON BEHALF
OF THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION.
WE'RE A HOME BUILDING, INDUSTRY
FUNDED NONPROFIT THAT ADVOCATES
FOR MORE HOMES FOR ALL RESIDENTS
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS AND PROUD
TO CO-SPONSOR AB 2243, BECAUSE
WE UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
CREATING MORE HOMES FOR
CALIFORNIANS. AND THIS BILL
MOVES THE NEEDLE WITH THE
PASSAGE OF THE LANDMARK BILL, AB
2011, IT'S BEEN CRITICAL IN
EXPANDING PRODUCTION OF HOUSING
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS, AND WE
HAVE MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE
WHO ARE USING AB 2011 TO BUILD
NEW HOMES. BUT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO STRENGTHEN THE
BILL AND DELIVER EVEN MORE
HOUSING. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS. THESE CLARIFICATIONS WILL
IMPROVE THE LAW AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN, TO ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
SITES TO BE DEVELOPED FOR
HOUSING SITES THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY INELIGIBLE FOR
STREAMLINING WILL NOW BE
FEASIBLE, AND IT WILL EXPAND
PRODUCTION THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
INCLUDING INFILL LOCATIONS.
SINCE THE TIME THAT AB 2011 WAS
PROPOSED AND PASSED AND THEN
IMPLEMENTED, WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF MEMBERS WHO ARE TRYING TO USE
THE BILL BUT ARE JUST UNABLE TO
DUE TO THESE CRITERIAS, AND WITH
THESE CLARIFICATIONS, ADDITIONAL
SITES WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
STREAMLINING, CLEARING THE WAY
FOR MUCH NEEDED HOUSING IN
REALLY GOOD LOCATIONS NEAR
AMENITIES, SERVICES, TRANSIT AND
JOBS. THIS BILL IS ULTIMATELY
ALSO GOING TO HELP INCREASE THE
CERTAINTY FOR HOUSING, WHICH
WILL IN TURN DECREASE THE COST
OF CONSTRUCTION FOR HOUSING,
WHICH IS SOMETHING WE
DESPERATELY NEED TO BE DOING
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
DANNY CURTIN WITH THE CARPENTERS
UNION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
POINTED OUT THAT THE LABOR
STANDARDS ARE THE SAME. SO I
WON'T BELABOR IT, BUT I DO WANT
TO MAKE A COUPLE OF POINTS,
ESPECIALLY SENATOR RAZA, YOU AND
I HAVE BEEN AROUND, WORKING ON
LABOR ISSUES FOR A LONG TIME.
NOT I'VE BEEN DOING IT LONGER,
AS YOU HAVE. YOU'RE JUST LIKE,
42 YEARS OLD, AND I KNOW HOW
THAT GOES. BUT THE POINT IS, THE
CONDITIONS OF THE WORKING PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA AND AMERICA ARE
NOT THAT GOOD ANYMORE. IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT TIME. THE LABOR
STANDARDS IN THIS BILL ARE
POTENTIALLY GOING TO CHANGE THE
NATURE OF THE SITUATION IN THE
WORKFORCE, IN THIS INDUSTRY. IT
IS ONE OF THE FOUR INDUSTRIES
THAT ARE RAMPANT WITH WAGE
THEFT. YOU'VE WE'VE GONE OVER
ALL THIS. THERE'S ABOUT $5
BILLION A YEAR BETWEEN STATE AND
FEDERAL AND LOSS OF TAXES THAT
GO INTO SUBSIDIZING THE WORST
ACTORS IN THE INDUSTRY BECAUSE
THEY HAVE WAGE THEFT, BECAUSE
THEY DON'T PAY THEIR TAXES, AND
THEY WORKERS NEED SOCIAL
SUPPORTS, THE ONE ELEMENT THAT'S
CRITICAL TO ACTUALLY POSSIBLY
CHANGING THAT WORKFORCE AROUND
IS THE ABILITY FOR THE JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEES TO
ACTUALLY ENFORCE THE LAW
DIRECTLY, BECAUSE WE CANNOT RELY
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
RELATIONS, NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE
BAD, BECAUSE THEY'RE
OVERWHELMED. SO THIS HAS THE
POTENTIAL FOR ACTUALLY CHANGING
THAT, HALF THE WORKFORCE IN THIS
INDUSTRY IS IN POVERTY. A
QUARTER OF IT WORKS UNDER THE
TABLE. SO WE THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING THAT THE HOUSING
CRISIS IS ALSO A WAGE CRISIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'RE NOW GOING TO DO THE,
SUPPORT ANYONE WISHING TO STEP
UP, GIVE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT. PLEASE
COME FORWARD. HELLO, MY NAME IS
ALEXANDRA HAMPTON, LOCAL 46,
SACRAMENTO, AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, HOLLY, FOR
MANY DAYS WITH LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF SPUR CIVIC
WELL FORMERLY KNOWN AS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION, AS WELL
AS FIELDSTEAD AND COMPANY AND
SUPPORT RAFA SONNENFELD ON
BEHALF OF YIMBY ACTION AND OUR
NEARLY TWO DOZEN CHAPTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
CESAR PLASENCIA, LOCAL 405,
SANTA CLARA COUNTY, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MATT KELLY, LOCAL 46,
SACRAMENTO, CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. MARIA JORDAN, LOCAL 46,
IN SUPPORT. MARCEL MOORE, LOCAL
46, SACRAMENTO. I'M IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ROD FINLEY, LOCAL 46,
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CHRIS
MYERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MARINA
ESPINOSA WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM. AND SUPPORT
DAN BRANTON, DRYWALL LATHERS
LOCAL 9109 RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MATTHEW HARGROVE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
BRIAN SHERMAN, LOCAL 46 AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JOHN
GUILHERME, LOCAL 46. I SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MATTHEW MANJI WITH
INNER-CITY LAWCENTER IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JORDAN PINEDA
CARVAJAL ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
YIMBY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MATTHEW BEESTON
NOR-CAL CARPENTERS UNION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AIDAN HALL,
LOCAL 9109, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MICHAEL WHITLEY, LOCAL
9109. I SUPPORT EMILIO TREVINO,
LOCAL 46. I'M IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
LAUREN DE VALENCIA, REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. OKAY. IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2243? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. GOOD MORNING.
MORNING MORNING. MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME
IS JONATHAN PRUITT. I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE. WE FIRST LIKE TO START
BY THANKING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS FOR REINCORPORATING THE
OIL AND GAS SETBACK INTO THE AB
2243. THIS CONTINUES
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE, AND WE LIKE TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND HER STAFF
AND ALL THE HARD WORK FOR THAT.
HOWEVER, S¼ HAS STILL
RESPECTFULLY REMAINS AND OPPOSED
UNLESS THE MEND POSITION ON AB
2243. WE APPRECIATE THE
DIRECTION OF RECENT
CONVERSATIONS AND THE AUTHOR'S
COMMITMENT TO MEETING WITH US
OVER THE SUMMER, THE SUMMER
BREAK TO CONTINUE TO DISCUSS OUR
REMAINING CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL, OUR ALLIANCE AGREES THAT
DEEPLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS A
KEY NEED FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS, AND APPRECIATES
THE SERIOUSNESS WITH WHICH THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TAKE ON THIS CHALLENGE. AND AT
THE SAME TIME, IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS ARE HEALTHY AND
THEY ARE SAFE. OUR OUTSTANDING
CONCERN DEALS WITH THE REMOVAL
OF THE 500 FOOT BUFFER AROUND
FREEWAYS. THIS BUFFER PROVIDES
RESIDENTS WITH MUCH NEEDED
PROTECTIONS FROM PARTICULATE
MATTER AS WELL AS OTHER
EXPOSURES PRESENTED BY FREEWAYS.
AND SO WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND HER
STAFF TO IDENTIFY THOSE
EQUITABLE SOLUTIONS THAT CAN
THAT CAN BUILD ON THIS
LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT TO
CREATING HEALTHY AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND AGAIN, THANK YOU,
THE AUTHOR, FOR REINSTATING 30
200 FOOT SETBACK AND MAINTAIN A
KEY PROTECTION FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES. AND SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS OVER JULY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR MEMBERS BRADY GARDNER, ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION FOR A COUPLE ISSUES.
FROM A TECHNICAL ASPECT, THE
SHOT CLOCK GOES FROM THE
COMPLETION OF A SUBMITTED
APPLICATION. THAT'S CONCERNING
BECAUSE WE CAN'T CONTROL IF THE
PROPONENT HAS FOLLOWED THE
REGULATIONS THAT'S ESTABLISHED.
SO WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THAT
SHOT CLOCK WITH THE DEEMED
APPROVAL LANGUAGE WOULD BE
CONCERNING FROM ANOTHER ASPECT.
AB 2011 JUST BECAME A LAW LAST
YEAR. OUR CITIES ARE WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH HCD AS WELL AS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO
FIND OUT HOW BEST TO ADDRESS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE WITH THE
BILL. WITH SOME OF THE CHANGES
THAT ARE PROPOSED IN 2011. AND
WE JUST FEEL LIKE WE'RE RUNNING
TOO QUICKLY TO DO AGAIN, MORE BY
RIGHT FOR EXTENDING THE BY RIGHT
TO AREAS THAT WERE NOT ONCE WERE
NOT MEANT FOR RESIDENTIAL
HOUSING IN THE BEGINNING. SO
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT WE'RE
MOVING TOO QUICKLY WITH THIS AND
CITIES NEED MORE TIME TO COMPLY
WITH 2011. THAT SAID, WANTED TO
APPRECIATE SOME MEMBER WICKS
OFFICE. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY. I KNOW WE HAD CONCERNS
ABOUT THE FEE LANGUAGE, WHICH
WAS ADDRESSED, SO WE APPRECIATE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE OVER
RECESS SHOULD IT CONTINUE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. IN OPPOSITION.
ANYONE, PLEASE COME FORWARD IN
OPPOSITION, GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS GINA TEO, AND I'M HERE
WITH CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE. AND, WE ARE
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OH, AND I WAS
ALSO ASKED TO DO A ME TO FOR PSR
LÀ AND FOR APEN. THANK YOU. HI.
MY NAME IS MARISOL TELLO. I'M
FROM BOULDER AND SARAH AND I AND
I OPPOSE AND ALYSSA MENDED TO
PROTECT PEOPLE LIKE ME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME IS
JESSICA HIÂU AND I'M WITH CEQA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED, TO INCLUDE ALL SETBACKS.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
JENNIFER GANADO WITH COMMUNITIES
FOR A BETTER ENVIRONMENT AND
SARAH REGISTERING THE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITIONS OF
ESPERANZA COMMUNITY HOUSING,
HOUSING EQUITY AND ADVOCACY
RESOURCE TEAM, LOS ANGELES AND
EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALICIA
SHARMA ON BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE CENTER
FOR RACE, POVERTY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND WE ARE OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. TIFFANY NG REGISTERING
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED POSITIONS
FOR THREE 350 SOUTHLAND
LEGISLATIVE ALLIANCE 350 SOUTH
BAY, LOS ANGELES. THE VISION
COALITION STAND.EARTH BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT AND FRACTRACKER
ALLIANCE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI. GOOD MORNING, MY NAME IS
MORGAN GONZALEZ. I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA, OR I'M WITH THE SEA,
SARAH. AND ALSO COMMUNITIES FOR
A BETTER ENVIRONMENT. AND WE'RE
IN OPPOSITION UNTIL AMENDED.
ALSO I'M SHOUTING OUT AKJ AS
WELL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, PAUL GONSALVES,
ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF SIMI
VALLEY, SANTA CLARITA AND
THOUSAND OAKS, WE'D LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF THE LEAGUE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
ANGELA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT, WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL. APPRECIATE
THAT THERE ARE AMENDMENTS
FORTHCOMING ONCE WE'VE HAD A
CHANCE TO REVIEW THOSE, WE'LL
REVIEW OUR POSITION AS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. SENATORS MATTHEW BAKER
WITH PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE. WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS BILL,
BUT WITH GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR AND HER WORK IN THIS
ARENA, I DID NEED TO STATE THAT
WE SHARE THE CONCERNS OF OUR S¼
PARTNERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CASEY ELLIOTT. ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF SANTA
ANA, LAFAYETTE, LA HABRA AND
NEWPORT BEACH WITH AN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
MELISSA ROMERO, CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS, WE HAVE AN
OPPOSING AMENDMENT POSITION, BUT
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO REINSTATE THE OIL
SETBACKS LANGUAGE AND PENDING
FURTHER CHANGES TO THE FREEWAY
SETBACKS LANGUAGE AFTER THAT
WILL BE RECONSIDERING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
RACHEL MASON WITH THE WITH
STANDING TOGETHER AGAINST
NEIGHBORHOOD DRILLING LOS
ANGELES AND RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSING LESSMAN BUT
APPRECIATIVE OF THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER OPPOSITION?
OKAY. SEEING NONE MEMBERS.
SENATOR WIENER, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. I FULLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL, AND I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR ALL OF HER
INCREDIBLE WORK ON A LOT OF
HOUSING ISSUES, INCLUDING AB
2011. THAT WAS THE INITIAL BILL
THAT HELPED BREAK THE LOGJAM
THAT THE PARALYSIS WE HAD SEEN
IN THIS BUILDING AROUND SOME
LABOR STANDARDS. AND I THINK IT
OPENED UP A LOT OF DOORS FOR
WORK WE DID LAST YEAR ON SB 433
AND SB FOUR AND SO ON AND SO
FORTH. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. I DO JUST WANT
TO, COMMENT ON SOME OF THESE,
NEVER ENDING PUSHES TO EXCLUDE
MORE AND MORE CALIFORNIA
GEOGRAPHY FROM HAVING HOUSING.
AND I'M NOT CRITICIZING IN ANY
WAY, OR I JUST WANT TO BECAUSE
WE DEALT WITH THIS LAST YEAR AS
WELL, WHAT WE SEE, AND THIS IS
VERY TYPICAL OF WHY WE HAVE A
DEEP HOUSING CRISIS IN SAN
FRANCISCO, BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS
A LAUNDRY LIST OF WHY YOU CAN'T
BUILD HOUSING WHERE YOU CAN'T
BUILD HOUSING, NEVER ENDING
GEOGRAPHY THAT SHOULD BE
EXCLUDED FROM HOUSING. AND IT
GROWS AND IT GROWS AND IT GROWS
WITHOUT ACTUALLY ADVOCATING FOR
MORE HOUSING. AND I HAVE SAID
THIS BEFORE, AND I WILL SAY IT
AGAIN, AND I KNOW I IRRITATE
PEOPLE WHEN I DO IT, BUT I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
MOVEMENT TALK MORE ABOUT A PRO
HOUSING AGENDA, NOT JUST WE
SHOULDN'T BUILD HOUSING HERE,
BUT HERE ARE THE PLACES WHERE WE
SHOULD MAKE IT SUPER, SUPER,
SUPER EASY TO DO. SO AND THERE
ARE SOME VOICES IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT WHO DO
THAT. AND SO THAT I APPLAUD
THAT. THERE ARE OTHER VOICES IN
THE ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT, THAT
IT'S JUST ABOUT WHERE YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO BUILD HOUSING AND
NEVER SUPPORTING, MAKING IT
EASIER TO BUILD HOUSING AND THE
OTHER AREAS. AND IS IT ANY
WONDER THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE LIVING ON OUR STREETS
THAT WE HAVE SO MANY LOW INCOME
RENTERS WHO, IF THEY LOSE THEIR
APARTMENT, THEY WILL BE ON THE
STREETS OR OUT OF CALIFORNIA? IS
IT ANY WONDER THAT WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES ARE GETTING PUSHED OUT
OF MANY PARTS OF CALIFORNIA? AND
IS IT ANY WONDER THAT KIDS CAN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY GREW UP?
BECAUSE IT'S ALL ABOUT NO, NO,
NO, NO HERE. THIS IS BAD. THIS
IS BAD. HERE'S A REASON HERE.
HERE'S A REASON. THERE AND
NEVER. YES, YOU KNOW, IN TERMS
OF THE OIL SETBACK ISSUE, I WANT
TO BE CLEAR. THIS IS NOT AN OIL
SETBACK PROVISION OR OIL SETBACK
MEANS WHAT WE DID WHEN WE PASSED
THE OIL SETBACKS. AND I AUTHORED
ONE OF THE VARIOUS VERSIONS OF
THOSE LAWS, OIL SETBACK LAWS,
BEFORE IT WAS ADOPTED. AND I
SUPPORT, AN OIL SETBACK OIL
SETBACKS IS ABOUT TELLING OIL
COMPANIES YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
DRILL IN CERTAIN AREAS. IT WAS
NEVER ABOUT THAT. THE OIL
COMPANIES NOW GET TO DECIDE
WHERE WE PUT HOUSING. THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS. IT'S JUST
COMPLETELY FLIPPED. AND WHEN AND
WITH THIS VERY SIGNIFICANT
BUFFER, WHICH I WAS FORCED TO
TAKE IN SB FOUR LAST YEAR, WE
ARE NOW IT CARVED OUT BIG SWATHS
OF LOS ANGELES AND PARTS OF
ORANGE COUNTY. SOME WEALTHY
COMMUNITIES, SWATHS OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND BEVERLY
HILLS NOW GET CARVED OUT.
WEALTHY AREAS BECAUSE THEY THEY
HAVE TECHNICALLY A DRILLING SITE
THERE. AND SO THAT'S WHEN WE
WHEN WE START CARVING, DOING
THESE BIG CARVE OUTS. THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENS. AND THEN ON THE
FREEWAY ISSUE, THAT 500 FOOT
BUFFER, WHICH I HAVE NEVER
ACCEPTED IN ANY BILL. AND I
THANK YOU FOR NOT ACCEPTING THAT
I, LIKE YOU, AGREED TO THE AIR
FILTRATION, WHICH MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE TO START SAYING WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BUILD WITHIN 500FT ON
EITHER SIDE OF A FREEWAY. TALK
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF GEOGRAPHY
THAT THAT WOULD WIPE OUT OF A
BILL. SO THANK YOU FOR NOT
AGREEING TO THAT. SO, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO BUILD. WE
HAVE TO EXCLUDE THE COASTAL
ZONE. WE HAVE TO EXCLUDE
ANYWHERE NEAR FREEWAY, HAVE TO
EXCLUDE ANYWHERE NEAR WHERE AN
OIL COMPANY DECIDES TO HAVE A
DRILLING SITE. WE HAVE TO
EXCLUDE IN, YOU KNOW, IN CERTAIN
WILDFIRE ZONES, EXCLUDE,
EXCLUDE, EXCLUDE, EXCLUDE,
EXCLUDE. AND IT GETS TO THE
POINT WHERE WHERE ARE YOU
ALLOWED TO BUILD. SO, YOU KNOW,
I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
STATEMENT, I WILL MOVE THE BILL
ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM. BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO REALLY ZOOM OUT
AND LOOK AT THE BIG PICTURE
HERE. AND AGAIN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
SENATOR SERRATO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND WHAT HE SAID, A LOT OF
THE STUFF I HAVE THE SAME
CONCERNS ABOUT OUR APPROACH TO
TRYING TO GET MORE HOUSING. BUT
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
INTERRELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
HOUSING, TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDORS, JOBS, ROADS, ALL OF
IT IS INTERRELATED. AND, THIS
APPROACH, I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT,
AND ONE OF THE REASONS I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT IS I TAKE LIKE A
REGIONAL MALL. LET'S TALK ABOUT
HAWTHORNE MALL, IF AT THE END OF
THE DAY, IT'S EASIER TO TEAR ALL
OF THAT STUFF DOWN, JUST DON'T
WORRY ABOUT THE ZONING AND JUST
REBUILD THE HOUSING THAT YOU
WANT TO BUILD IN THESE
COMMERCIAL AREAS, YOU KNOW, THE,
THE TYPE OF BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION AND ALL OF THOSE
THINGS. EVENTUALLY THOSE THINGS
HAVE, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE SAFETY
CONCERNS ABOUT YOU KNOW, YOU
KNOW, BUILDING AND SAFETY. THOSE
ALL THESE TYPE OF BUILDING OR
ALL THESE TYPE OF HOUSING AND,
BUILDING REQUIREMENTS ARE
DIFFERENT FOR THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF YOUR COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS. YOU'VE GOT AND
THEY'RE BUILT WITH MATERIALS
THAT ARE NOT NECESSARILY
ADEQUATE FOR A HOUSING TYPE OF
BUILDING. AND SO YOU SPEND MORE
MONEY AND TIME TRYING TO CONVERT,
TYPE ONE AND TWO BUILDINGS INTO
TYPE FIVE BUILDINGS FOR TYPE
FIVE USE. AND, AND WHEN YOU DO
THAT, YOU LOSE OPPORTUNITIES
ELSEWHERE TO ACTUALLY JUST BUILD
WHAT YOU NEED WITH THE MATERIALS
THAT ARE ENVIRONMENTALLY WHAT WE
WANT THEM TO BE. AND SO WE'RE
NOT, YOU KNOW, I FEEL LIKE WE'RE
WE'RE GOING DOWN A PATH WHERE
WE'RE SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY
TRYING TO FIX A CAR. WHEN YOU
SHOULD JUST GO AHEAD AND REPLACE
IT BECAUSE IT COSTS MORE TO, YOU
KNOW, MORE, MORE TO BUY ALL THE
PARTS AND FIX ALL THE PARTS THAN
IT DOES. JUST BUY ANOTHER CAR.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
THESE BUILDINGS. A LOT OF THESE
BUILDINGS ARE OUTDATED AS FAR AS
THEIR CONSTRUCTION USE FOR
TODAY'S ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS,
INCLUDING WINDOWS, THE TYPE OF
CEMENT THAT'S BEING USED.
REMEMBER, WE'RE WE WANT TO GET
RID OF THE OLD TYPE OF CEMENT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY. AND YET WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO USE THESE THINGS. SO
WHEN SOMETHING HAS OUTLIVED ITS
PURPOSE, IT'S TIME TO TEAR IT
DOWN. AND AS FAR AS PUTTING
RESIDENTIAL INTO THESE AREAS
THAT USED TO BE ZONED FOR
COMMERCIAL, THAT'S SOMETHING FOR
THE CITY. AND THE PLANNING TO
MAKE WORK, BECAUSE THE
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDORS,
EVERYTHING ABOUT THOSE AREAS
WERE ALL PLANNED AND BUILT FOR,
FOR THAT. AND WHEN YOU CONVERT
IT, THERE'S A LOT MORE TO
CONVERTING THAN JUST PUTTING UP
PARTITIONS INSIDE, MAYBE TRYING
TO MODIFY AN HVAC SYSTEM THAT'S
ANOTHER WHOLE BIG ISSUE, AND
THEN MAKING IT SO THAT IT'S SAFE
FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE IN, IF
THERE'S A FIRE OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, SO, YOU KNOW, TO ME, THIS,
THIS IS BUILDING UPON SOMETHING
THAT I THINK THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
SOME CONVERSIONS OF 12,000 UNITS
OR SOMETHING, BUT WE HAVE YET TO
SEE THE LONGER TERM RESULT OF
THOSE AND WHETHER THOSE ARE MORE
COSTLY THAN THEY WERE. IF WE
JUST, LIKE I SAID, TEAR IT DOWN,
BUILD WHAT YOU WANT IN THE RIGHT
WAY, IN THE RIGHT PLACE, BECAUSE
THEN YOU CAN ALSO FOCUS YOUR
ENERGIES ON BUILDING AWAY FROM
THE FREEWAY. SOME AREAS YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A TOUGH TIME DOING
THAT. YOU KNOW, AND BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THE MORE DENSE AREAS
AND WHAT, SENATOR WIENER WAS
TALKING ABOUT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE THAT OUR PROBLEM ISN'T
NECESSARILY ENOUGH ROOM. IT'S
THE PROCESS THAT PEOPLE HAVE TO
GO TO, TO, YOU KNOW, CITIES USED
TO SPRING UP AND, YOU KNOW, AND
BUILD HOUSES AND MEET THE
DEMAND. AND THEY JUST CAN'T DO
THAT ANYMORE. AND SO IT'S THOSE
PROCESSES THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT. IF WE WANT TO FIX THIS
HOUSING PROBLEM SO THAT WE CAN
IDENTIFY, YOU KNOW, THE, THE
REAL ISSUES ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO OFFSET
SOME OF THE, THE IMPACTS FROM
BUILDING AND THINGS VERSUS THIS.
IT'S A BARRIER OF REGULATIONS
AND ALL OF THESE OTHER THINGS
THAT WE MAKE. WE THIS IS A
SELF-MADE PROBLEM. WE'VE CREATED
IT AND YET WE WON'T GET RID OF
THE THINGS THAT WE CREATED THAT
ARE MAKING HOUSING COSTS SO DANG
MUCH. AND NOW, YOU KNOW, WE ARE
CAUGHT IN OUR OWN WEB. AND
THAT'S WHAT I FEEL LIKE. IT'S
LIKE ALL OF THESE THINGS THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN HERE,
AND LONG BEFORE I WAS HERE,
WE'RE NOW CAUGHT IN THAT WEB AND
WE CAN'T GET OUT, AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO TRY TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT THIS IS IT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, I JUST A COMMENT TO THE
AUTHOR. THERE WAS ONE THAT YOU
DIDN'T SPECIFY AMENDMENT THAT
YOU DIDN'T SPECIFICALLY MENTION.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S
RESTORING THE EXISTING LAW
REGARDING INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
ORDINANCES. YEAH. YES, WE'RE
ACCEPTING THAT. I'M SORRY. YES.
OKAY. I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
WITH THAT. I DO JUST WANT TO
MAKE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS BASED
ON WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID.
I, I UNDERSTAND WE ALL HAVE THE
FRUSTRATION OF NOT BUILDING
ENOUGH HOUSING FAST ENOUGH.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT. BUT
IT ALSO COMES AT A TIME WHEN
THERE ARE COMMUNITIES POOR
COMMUNITIES, COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR, WHO OVER THE DECADES,
WERE IGNORED WHEN IT CAME TO
DECIDING WHERE TO BUILD. AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT AS WE
MOVE TOWARDS A MORE DELIBERATE
OKAY, PLANNING FOR WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO, YOU KNOW, THAT WE NEED
THIS MUCH HOUSING, THAT ISSUES
THAT AFFECT THOSE POOR
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR ALSO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. SO THE
FRUSTRATION OF YOU KNOW, MY
COLLEAGUES SAID, DON'T BUILD
HERE. NO, NO, NO, NO, NO. THERE
ARE MANY GOOD REASONS WHY THAT'S
DONE. WE JUST HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
WHEN THOSE AND HOW TO INTEGRATE
THOSE CONCERNS THAT ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES THAT COME
UP. I HAVE FIVE FREEWAYS IN MY
DISTRICT. I DON'T KNOW OF ANY
OTHER, DISTRICT IN THE IN THE
STATE THAT HAS THAT MANY. SO
THESE MAY BE UNIQUE TO CERTAIN
AREAS, BUT THEY'RE VERY
IMPORTANT TO, TO CERTAIN AREAS.
SO I THINK IT'S OUR JOB TO TRY
AND FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE
INTEGRATE AND GIVE IT THE RIGHT
BALANCE. SO WITH THAT, I THINK
THERE'S NO MORE COMMENTS. NO.
OKAY. I THINK Þ FIVE RIVAS. I'M
SORRY. OH, I'M SORRY. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THE DO A ROLL CALL
FOR THE QUORUM. SENATORS DURAZZO
I DURAZZO, PRESENT SEYARTO SATO
PRESENT. DOLLY DOLLY. PRESENT.
GLAZER. SKINNER SKINNER.
PRESENT. WAHAB WIENER. WIENER.
PRESENT. YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU. SO WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR WIENER. Dð PASSES Þ
CLOSING REMARKS. WELL, I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS. I
APPRECIATE BOTH THE SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION, I, TOO HAVE A LOT OF
FREEWAYS IN MY DISTRICT. IT IS
CALIFORNIA. I THINK MANY OF US
DO. OH OH, OH, MY GOLF SWINGS.
GOOD. TO, YOU KNOW, AND I, I
GENUINELY WELCOME, YOU KNOW,
OPPOSITION, THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY TO THE CONVERSATION
AROUND DEVELOPING A PRO HOUSING
AGENDA BECAUSE I THINK THAT
BENEFITS ALL OF US, AND, YOU
KNOW, WE'VE HAD ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS. I'VE COMMITTED TO
HAVING CONTINUED ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS. I WANT TO LAND
THIS IN A PLACE THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE, AND I'M DEAD SET, DEAD
SET. COMMITTED. DEAD SET,
COMMITTED ON ENSURING THAT WE
ARE BUILDING THE HOUSING THAT WE
NEED FOR ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
SO WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS DURAZZO I, DURAZZO I
CIERTO. CIERTO. NO. DOLLY. DOLLY
I. GLASER. SKINNER. SKINNER I
WAHAB. WIENER. WIENER I 4 TO 1.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ARE WE
GOING TO HOLD THAT OPEN? YES.
YES WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN FOR
MORE VOTES. OKAY. NOW WE HAVE.
OKAY. NOW, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
WERE, GOING TO HEAR ON AB 1893.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
1893, A BILL TO MODERNIZE
BUILDER'S REMEDY. THE BUILDER'S
REMEDY IS PART OF HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW THAT SAYS THAT IF A
CITY OR COUNTY DOES NOT HAVE A
COMPLIANT HOUSING ELEMENT, THEN
LOCAL ZONING DOES NOT DOES NOT
APPLY, AND A DEVELOPER CAN
PROPOSE A PROJECT THAT CAN BE
ANY SIZE ANYWHERE IN THE
JURISDICTION. THE GOAL. THE GOAL
OF BUILDER'S REMEDY IS TO COMPEL
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO COMPLETE
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT. WHY IS
THIS THE GOAL? BECAUSE WE HAVE A
MASSIVE HOUSING CRISIS, AND THE
ONLY WAY WE'RE CLIMBING OUT OF
IT IS IF EVERY CITY AND COUNTY
DOES THEIR PART BY ADOPTING AND
IMPLEMENTING THE HOUSING ELEMENT
IS HOW WE DO THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY, 1 IN 3
JURISDICTIONS ARE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH HOUSING ELEMENT
LAW. THOSE JURISDICTIONS ARE
ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT SOLVING
THE HOUSING CRISIS IS NOT THEIR
PROBLEM. THEORETICALLY, THIS
WOULDN'T BE A PROBLEM BECAUSE IN
NON-COMPLIANT CITIES AND
COUNTIES, WE'D BE SEEING LOTS OF
BUILDER'S REMEDY PROJECTS THAT
RESULT IN LOTS OF HOUSING, SO
THAT IGNORING STATE LAW DID NOT
MEAN AN END TO HOUSING
PRODUCTION. UNFORTUNATELY, THE
BUILDER'S REMEDY HAS NOT
FUNCTIONED IN THAT WAY. ONE OF
THE REASONS IS THAT THE EXISTING
LAW IS LEGALLY MURKY, ADDING A
LEVEL OF RISK THAT TURNS OFF
RISK ADVERSE DEVELOPERS AND
THOSE THAT CAN'T AFFORD TO
LITIGATE THE LAW ALSO INCLUDES
AN AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT OF
20, WHICH SOUNDS NOBLE AND
LOFTY, BUT ACTUALLY MAKES MOST
HOUSING PROJECTS ECONOMICALLY
INFEASIBLE, EVEN IF THE
OCCASIONAL PROJECT IS ABLE TO
PENCIL. AND ALSO CITIES STILL
HAVE AT THEIR DISPOSAL A MYRIAD
OF TOOLS TO THWART PROJECTS THEY
DISLIKE, EVEN IF THEY ARE CODE
COMPLIANT. THAT'S WHY, WHILE
THERE ARE NOW AT LEAST 100
BUILDER'S REMEDIES PROJECTS
PROPOSED IN THE STATE, WE DON'T
HAVE A SINGLE UNIT BUILT FROM A
BUILDER'S REMEDY PROJECT. WE
HAVE A LOT OF DISCUSSION ABOUT
BUILDER'S REMEDY PROJECTS.
THERE'S OFTEN TALK OF THIS ON
THE TWITTER VERSE, BUT BUILDER'S
REMEDY PROJECTS HAVE NOT
ACTUALLY RESULTED, TO MY
KNOWLEDGE, IN A SINGLE FAMILY
HAVING A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD.
THE RESULT IS THAT THERE ARE
EFFECTIVELY NO CONSEQUENCES FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT IGNORE
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW, WHICH IS
WHY WE NEED TO MODERNIZE THIS
LAW. WORKING WITH OUR SPONSOR,
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA, WE
HAVE CRAFTED A BILL THAT REMOVES
ANY AMBIGUITY AMBIGUITY ABOUT
WHERE THE BUILDER'S REMEDY WOULD
APPLY, HOW MUCH DENSITY WOULD BE
ALLOWED, AND WHAT OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS WOULD APPLY. IT ALSO
ENHANCES FEASIBILITY BY REDUCING
THE AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT TO
SOMETHING THAT DOES NOT RENDER
PROJECTS INFEASIBLE. THE AIM IS
TO CREATE A SELF-ENFORCING
MECHANISM THAT FACILITATES A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF HOUSING IN
THOSE CITIES THAT HAVE NOT
COMPLIED WITH STATE HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
STRIKING A BALANCE IN THE FACE
OF EXISTING LAW THAT IS QUITE
MURKY, AND DOING SO PROACTIVELY,
INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR THE
COURTS TO MAKE THE CASE, WHICH
COULD NOT ONLY TAKE 5 TO 10
YEARS, BUT WHOSE OUTCOME IS
COMPLETELY UNPREDICTABLE, TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE, WE'VE HAD
TO TAKE ACTIONS THAT THIS THAT
THE CITIES LIKE BUT UPSET SOME
OF OUR PRO HOUSING FRIENDS, LIKE
PUTTING A DENSITY MAXIMUM ON
BUILDER. SO MANY PROJECTS. WE'VE
ALSO HAD TO DO SOME THINGS THAT
CITIES DON'T LIKE THAT ARE PRO
HOUSING. FRIENDS DO LIKE, WHICH
IS TO REMOVE THE ABILITY FOR
JURISDICTIONS TO EFFECTIVELY
DENY PROJECTS BY SITTING ON THEM
IN PERPETUITY. THE RESULT IS A
BILL THAT HAS A BROAD AND
UNUSUAL COALITION THAT SPANS
FROM THE INNER CITY LAW CENTER,
WHICH REPRESENTS PRO BONO, THE
HOMELESS ON SKID ROW, CBIA
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY, AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS, CALIFORNIA
YIMBY AND OTHERS. EVERYONE IN
THAT GROUP HAS GIVEN UP
SOMETHING FOR WHAT THEY SEE AS A
GREATER GOOD, WHICH IS MORE
ADOPTION OF LOCAL HOUSING
ELEMENT AND MORE APPROVAL OF
HOUSING. WHEN CITIES AND
COUNTIES FAIL TO ADOPT THEM. AND
THE DELICATE BALANCE IS THE
REASON THAT I AM UNABLE TO.
UNFORTUNATELY ACCEPT THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TODAY. UNFORTUNATELY, THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT AMENDMENTS
TIP THE BALANCE FAR IN THE FAVOR
OF THE JURISDICTIONS DO NOT HAVE
EXISTING HOUSING ELEMENT, GIVING
THEM A RANGE OF TOOLS TO
NEUTRALIZE BUILDERS REMEDY
PROJECTS. AND WHILE WE'VE HAD
VERY FRUITFUL AND LONG AND
DELIBERATE CONVERSATIONS, BOTH
WITH THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF,
ONE THAT I'M EAGER TO CONTINUE,
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE OUT OF
COMMITTEE, I FELT THAT THE
AMENDMENTS UNDERMINE THE BILL
TOO SUBSTANTIALLY,
UNFORTUNATELY, AND I DON'T TAKE
THIS LIGHTLY. AS YOU KNOW, MADAM
CHAIR, I HAVE THE UTMOST RESPECT
FOR YOU AND YOUR TEAM, AND I
KNOW YOU'VE WORKED, DECADES ON A
LOT OF THESE ISSUES, BUT, WE
WENT BACK AND FORTH ON THIS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF WE CAN
LAND THIS. I IF THIS BILL GETS
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY, I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU. I'D LIKE
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT WE CAN
DO THAT. BUT THE AMENDMENTS
CURRENTLY IS WRITTEN.
UNFORTUNATELY, I CAN'T TAKE
THEM. MY BELIEF IS THAT THE BEST
WAY FOR CITIES TO COMPEL WITH
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT, THE BEST
WAY FOR CITIES TO COMPLETE THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT IS TO DO IT OR
FACE THE CONSEQUENCE, WHICH IS
MORE HOUSING, I HAVE MY
WITNESSES HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I'LL LET THEM SELF
INTRODUCE. AND WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT, WE'D RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. OKAY. AND SO WE'LL
HAVE TWO AT TWO MINUTES EACH OR.
YEAH, TWO MINUTES EACH, WE HAVE
ALEX FISH FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE WHO WILL BE
HERE FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
OKAY, OKAY. THANK YOU. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS JANICE STANFORD. I'M A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA ON
BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
I WANT TO START BY THANKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND FOR AUTHORING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL, THE
BUILDER'S REMEDY IN THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT HAS BEEN ON
THE BOOKS SINCE 1990. IT SAYS
THAT IF A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DOESN'T HAVE A COMPLIANT HOUSING
ELEMENT, THEN IT CANNOT
DISAPPROVE A MODERATE OR MIXED
INCOME PROJECT, EVEN IF IT'S
INCONSISTENT WITH ZONING OR THE
LOCAL LAND USE DESIGNATION. IT'S
A CONSEQUENCE WHEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REFUSE TO PLAN FOR
THE NEEDS OF THEIR RESIDENTS.
THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT IN
EXISTING LAW IS CLEAR. THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
SHOULD BE INTERPRETED AND
IMPLEMENTED IN A MANNER TO
AFFORD THE FULLEST POSSIBLE
WEIGHT TO THE INTEREST OF, AND
THE APPROVAL AND PROVISION OF
HOUSING. SO THE PURPOSE OF THE
BUILDER'S REMEDY IS TWOFOLD. IT
WAS INTENDED TO SERVE AS A
COMPLIANCE TOOL TO ENCOURAGE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO IT
PROVIDES A PATH FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT EVEN REMOTELY. RIGHT
NOW, THE BUILDER'S REMEDY ISN'T
WORKING AS INTENDED. 175
JURISDICTIONS STILL DON'T HAVE A
COMPLIANT HOUSING ELEMENT 1 TO 3
YEARS PAST THE DEADLINE. AND
SINCE 1990, THE BUILDER'S REMEDY
HAS NOT RESULTED IN ONE PROJECT
BEING BUILT. DESPITE REPORTS
THAT OVER 150 BUILDER'S REMEDY
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN HAD
APPLICATIONS SUBMITTED, NOT ONE
OF THOSE PROJECTS HAS BEEN
ENTITLED OR BUILT TO DATE.
INSTEAD, THE LACK OF CLARITY IN
THE EXISTING BUILDER'S REMEDY
STATUTE HAS LED TO LOCAL
DISPUTES AND LITIGATION. OUR
INVESTIGATION REVEALED THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE EMPLOYING
A VARIETY OF TACTICS TO DELAY OR
BLOCK BUILDER'S REMEDY PROJECTS,
FROM MOVING FORWARD. THESE
DELAYS AND EFFECTIVE DENIALS OF
PROJECT APPLICATIONS HAVE
LARGELY AVOIDED CONSEQUENCE BY
STOPPING SHORT OF A VOTE, THIS
IS DELAYED OR EVEN PREVENTED.
HOUSING PROJECTS FROM BEING
BUILT SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
COST TO DEVELOP NEW HOUSING, AND
LIKELY DETERRED SOME BUILDERS
FROM SUBMITTING APPLICATIONS AT
ALL, ESPECIALLY SMALLER BUILDERS
THAT CAN'T AFFORD TO LITIGATE.
AB 1893 WOULD RESPOND TO THESE
ISSUES. CLOSE LOOPHOLES PROVIDE
CLARITY FOR DEVELOPERS, CITY
PLANNERS, AND COURTS, AND UNLOCK
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
BUILD HOUSING TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE.
GOOD MORNING, HONORABLE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS MATTHEW
MUNGAI AND I'M WITH INNER CITY
LAW CENTER. WE'RE THE ONLY
PRO-BONO LEGAL SERVICES PROVIDER
BASED IN SKID ROW IN LOS
ANGELES, AND WE SERVE FOLKS WHO
ARE HOMELESS AND AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS THROUGHOUT LA
COUNTY. THE RENO PROCESS WAS
CREATED TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
JURISDICTION BUILDS HOUSING FOR
RESIDENTS AT ALL INCOME LEVELS
IN EVERY CITY, NEIGHBORHOOD, AND
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA, WORKING
PEOPLE DRIVE THE LOCAL ECONOMY,
ENSURING THE STORES ARE
OPERATED, MAIL IS DELIVERED, AND
THE FOOD AND FOOD IS GROWN,
COOKED AND SERVED. WORKING
PEOPLE ARE THE HEART AND SOUL OF
OUR ECONOMY AND OUR COMMUNITIES,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, MANY
COMMUNITIES HAVE IGNORED THEIR
OBLIGATIONS TO BUILD HOUSING FOR
THEIR COMMUNITY MEMBERS,
ESPECIALLY HOUSING FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES. AB 1893 ENSURED
THAT NO COMMUNITY CAN SAY NO TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND TO MIXED
INCOME HOUSING IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY, SOME OF THE WEALTHIEST
CITIES, INCLUDING SOUTH PASADENA,
SAN MARINO, LA HABRA HEIGHTS AND
PALOS VERDES ESTATES HAVE
REFUSED TO DO THE BARE MINIMUM
NOT TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING,
BUT TO PLAN FOR IT. CALIFORNIA
HAS MADE IT OUR TOP PRIORITY TO
REQUIRE EVERY CITY TO BUILD ITS
FAIR SHARE OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, AND THE BUILDERS REMEDY
PROCESS ALLOWS DEVELOPERS TO
PROPOSE AFFORDABLE AND MIXED
INCOME PROJECTS. IF CITIES DO
NOT COME INTO COMPLIANCE. BUT SO
FAR, EVERY PROJECT HAS FACED
LAWSUITS AND RISING BUILDING
COSTS HAVE MADE PROJECTS
INFEASIBLE. IF THE BUILDER'S
REMEDY IS NOT A REAL OPTION,
THERE IS NO CONSEQUENCE FOR
CITIES TO BREAK THE LAW AND
REFUSE TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE.
WHEN SOUTH PASADENA AND ALHAMBRA
BOTH BOTH IN NONCOMPLIANT,
REFUSED TO ALLOW AFFORDABLE AND
MIXED INCOME HOUSING. THIS DRIVE
DISPLACEMENT AND GENTRIFICATION
IN EAST LOS ANGELES AND HIGHLAND
PARK. WE CANNOT ALLOW THE STATUS
QUO TO CONTINUE. AB 1893
PROPOSES AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS AT FEASIBLE LEVELS,
WHILE CREATING RULES AND
STANDARDS FOR BUILDERS. REMEDY
PROJECT AB 1893 ENSURES THE HIGH
INCOME COMMUNITIES CAN NO LONGER
SAY NO TO HOUSING, PLACING THE
BURDEN SOLELY ON LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. IF HOUSING LAW
ELEMENT LAW IS TO BE ENFORCED,
THE BUILDER'S REMEDY MUST BE
CLEAR AND MIXED INCOME PROJECTS
MUST MAKE ECONOMIC SENSE. FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN THIS DECADE,
HOMELESSNESS FELL IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. THIS YEAR, THIS WAS ONLY
POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE BUILT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE CITY
OF LA EVERY CITY, EVERY
NEIGHBORING CITY MUST DO THEIR
FAIR SHARE AND AB 1893 WILL
ENSURE THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND THANK THE ASSEMBLY FOR
HER LEADERSHIP AND THANK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY, WE'RE MOVING ON
NOW TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
1893, MARINA ESPINOSA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
AND SUPPORT. HOLLY FOR MANY DAYS
WITH LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
ON BEHALF OF CIVIC WELL SPUR
BUILD CASA FIELDSTEAD AND
COMPANY, SAND HILL PROPERTIES
AND HABITAT FOR HUMANITY,
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, DARLENE DUPREE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, JORDAN
CARVAJAL, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DANITA STROMGREN, VOLUNTEER WITH
CALIFORNIA AARP ON BEHALF OF OUR
3.2 MILLION MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. CÁC GILSON WITH
AXIOM ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, LESLIE RODRIGUEZ, ON BEHALF
OF HOUSING TRUST SILICON VALLEY,
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, COREY
SMITH, HOUSING ACTION COALITION
AND SUPPORT MATTHEW HARGROVE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT? OKAY. SEEING NONE,
FOR OPPOSITION, I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES WHO REQUESTED
TO TESTIFY, ARTHUR WILLING,
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA,
AND MIKE RAWSON, PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT. HOLD ON TO SIT DOWN.
OKAY. GO AHEAD. SO I'LL JUST.
I'LL JUST GO AHEAD. OH, THERE WE
GO. THANK YOU. I'LL JUST GO
AHEAD AND GO AHEAD AND JUMP IN.
SO ARTHUR WILSON, GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR RURAL COUNTIES AND
FORMERLY THE COUNTY COUNSEL FOR
TEHAMA COUNTY IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM, I WILL SAY WE DO
CONCEPTUALLY VERY MUCH AGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS
THAT THE BUILDERS REMEDY
REQUIRES REFORM AND
CLARIFICATION. IN ITS CURRENT
FORM, THE BUILDERS REMEDY IS
BASICALLY A NEGATIVE IMPLICATION
IN THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT. AND WHEN IT DOES APPLY,
WHICH IS UNCLEAR, THERE THE
SCOPE OF OBJECTIVE STANDARDS
THAT CAN APPLY UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND WITH SUCH WITH
WHAT LIMITATIONS ARE ALSO
UNCLEAR. THERE DEFINITELY NEEDS
TO BE SOME REFORM IN THIS AREA.
THE BUILDERS REMEDY TO BE
EFFECTIVE FOR ITS INTENDED
PURPOSES NEEDS TO BE CLEAR. IT
NEEDS TO BE ADMINISTRABLE, AND
IT NEEDS TO STRIKE THE RIGHT
BALANCE WITH THE STATE'S OTHER
VERY IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICIES,
SOME OF WHICH HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED EARLIER HERE TODAY.
ENSURING ADEQUACY OF PUBLIC
SERVICES, AFFORDABILITY AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
UNFORTUNATELY, WITH GREAT
RESPECT TO THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS, AB 1893, IN ITS
CURRENT FORM DOES NOT DO THIS.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE POINTS IN THE
BILL OF UNCLARITY THAT WILL MAKE
IT VERY DIFFICULT TO ADMINISTER.
TO GIVE JUST ONE EXAMPLE, I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF THEM THAT
ARE MENTIONED. I THINK VERY WELL
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS,
ALTHOUGH SUCH PROJECTS ARE
OSTENSIBLY REQUIRED TO COMPLY
WITH OBJECTIVE STANDARDS, NO
COMBINATION OF THOSE STANDARDS
CAN PRECLUDE THE PROJECT FROM
BEING CONSTRUCTED AS PROPOSED BY
THE DEVELOPER, MOST STANDARDS
THAT I'VE WORKED WITH IMPLY SOME
LIMITATION ON THE WHIMS OF THE
APPLICANT. HOW DO WE MAKE THAT
WORK? THAT'S A KIND OF SORT OF
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SORT OF OUR
MAJOR CONCERN WITH. THE BILL.
ALSO, THIS BILL DOES AND I THINK
IS INTENDED TO AND THIS IS
REALLY THE POLICY ISSUE DOES
REDUCE SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
OTHER PUBLIC POLICIES. IT
CERTAINLY REDUCES LOCAL
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS, BUT ALSO VERY MUCH
REDUCES THE INCENTIVES TO USE
SOME OF STATE LAWS. OTHER TOOLS,
INCLUDING THE DENSITY BONUS LAW.
MOREOVER, THE BILL HAS A NEW
STANDARD FOR DENIAL OF A PROJECT
THAT I THINK IF YOU JUST READ
IT, UNJUSTIFIED DELAY FROM WHICH
A REASONABLE PERSON COULD
CONCLUDE THAT THE PROJECT WAS
EFFECTIVELY DENIED, CLEARLY
SHOWS A LEVEL OF SUBJECTIVITY
THAT IS CERTAINLY GOING TO
GENERATE LITIGATION, BUT I'M NOT
SURE IT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO
GENERATE HOUSING. WE HAD A VERY
SIMILAR ISSUE THAT WE WORKED ON
LAST YEAR WITH ASSEMBLY BILL
1633 THAT DEALT WITH THE VERY
SIMILAR ISSUE OF UNJUSTIFIED
CEQA DELAY THERE AS HERE WE AS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RECOGNIZE THAT
BAD FAITH, UNJUSTIFIED DELAY,
WHICH I'M SURE DOES HAPPEN IN
THE STATE. THAT'S NOT A GOOD
THING. THAT SHOULD NOT BE
ENCOURAGED, THAT SHOULD BE
DISCOURAGED AND PROHIBITED.
PROHIBITED YES, MA'AM, SO BUT WE
SPENT CLOSE uTWO YEARS WORKING
WITH A LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS,
WORKING VERY HARD IN SUPPORT OF
THAT EFFORT, AND CAME UP WITH A
VERY NUANCED AND BALANCED
COMPROMISE. WE DID SAY YES TO
HOUSING. WE DID SAY YES TO THAT
BILL, AND WE WOULD VERY MUCH
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS OVER THE INTERIM TO
COME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT
REALLY WILL ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL.
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IN PRINT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. ROSSEN. YES,
I'M MICHAEL ROSSEN, I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION AND
ADVOCACY AT THE PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT. IT'S A STATE
SUPPORT CENTER FOR LOCAL LEGAL
SERVICES AND OTHER PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'VE BEEN WORKING
FOR HOUSING ELEMENT COMPLIANCE
AND ENFORCEMENT FOR 25 YEARS,
AND THERE'S BEEN SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN COMPLIANCE OVER THE
YEARS. I NOTE THAT TWO THIRDS OF
THE CITIES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ALREADY IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
SIXTH CYCLE, SO WE'RE NOT IN A
IN A IN A CASE WHERE EVERYBODY
IS THUMBING THEIR NOSE AT THE AT
THE HOUSING ELEMENT LAW,
CURRENTLY I'M CO-COUNSELING WITH
THE AG'S OFFICE ON THE KNOCK
DOWN AND DRAG OUT SUIT AGAINST
THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH,
WHO STEADFASTLY REFUSES TO ADOPT
A HOUSING ELEMENT. SO WE'VE
WORKED TOGETHER WITH THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL AND THE
OPPONENTS TO THE BILL, I'M HERE
PARTLY BECAUSE I C  DRAFTED IN
1990 THE ORIGINAL HHR AMENDMENTS
THAT CREATED THE BUILDER'S
REMEDY AND AT THAT TIME, AND
THAT WAS LEROY GREEN'S, SB 2011,
AT THAT TIME, THE PURPOSE OF
THAT, PURPOSE OF THAT BILL WAS
TO OPEN THE DOOR FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO, IN NIMBY
COMMUNITIES THAT HAD ERECTED
BARRIERS AGAINST PRODUCING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THAT'S WHY
THE 20% AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENT WAS IN THERE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT PATH WAS OPEN FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
THERE WAS, AS, AS YOU KNOW, THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
HAVE FEWER RESOURCES THAN THE
MARKET DEVELOPERS, AND THERE
NEEDED TO BE A WAY FOR THEM TO
OVERCOME THE EXTREME RESISTANCE
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT, AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS SOMETHING THAT'S
MUCH HARDER TO GET APPROVED IN
COMMUNITIES THAN MARKET RATE
DEVELOPMENT. ALTHOUGH I AGREE,
THERE'S A LOT OF RESISTANCE TO
MARKET RATE DEVELOPMENT THESE
DAYS, SECOND POINT, I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE IS THAT, AND I CONCUR
WITH THE, THE OPPOSITION POINTS
THAT WERE, THAT WERE JUST MADE.
IS THAT WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
OKAY. IT THIS BILL UPENDS THE
INCLUSIONARY ZONING LAWS OF OVER
170 COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE WHAT IT SAYS IS THAT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO DO A BUILDER'S
REMEDY PROJECT, YOU CAN'T APPLY
YOUR INCLUSIONARY ZONING LAW TO
THAT PROJECT UNLESS YOU SHOW
THAT THAT THAT THE PROJECT WOULD
BE INFEASIBLE, UNLESS YOU SHOW
THAT IT WOULD BE FEASIBLE, YOU
CAN'T APPLY YOUR INCLUSIONARY
ZONING. THAT WOULD REQUIRE EVERY
COMMUNITY THAT GETS A BUILDER'S
REMEDY PROGRAM TO HIRE AN EXPERT
AND DO THAT ANALYSIS. SO I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AND IF,
UNLESS AMENDED AND HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR TO AMEND GOING
FORWARD, WE WANT TO OPEN THIS UP
NOW TO OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. ETHAN
NAGLER, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
RANCHO PALOS, VERDI'S AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. RALPH
SONNENFELD WITH THE MBA ACTION
AND MBA LAW. WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION,
APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
RECENTLY AND WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
TO, TO GET TO NEUTRAL OR SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN, CHAIR AND
SENATORS MATTHEW BAKER WITH
PLANNING CONSERVATION LEAGUE.
AGAIN, WITH GREAT RESPECT TO THE
AUTHOR, FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THESE ISSUES. WE REMAIN OPPOSED
ON THIS AMENDED. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
BRIAN AUGUSTA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION, THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR RURAL
HOUSING, NATIONAL HOUSING LAW
PROJECT, PUBLIC ADVOCATES, AND
THE 40 OTHER ORGANIZATIONS WHO
HAVE SUPPORTED OUR LETTER
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION, UNLESS
AMENDED TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BRADY GERHARD, ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES, IN
A RESPECTFUL OPPOSING THIS
AMENDED POSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. KIARA
ROSS, ON BEHALF OF THE MARIN
COUNTY COUNCIL OF MAYORS AND
COUNCIL, COUNCIL MEMBERS IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL, THANK YOU. PHOEBE. SENIOR
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL ACTION IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. THANKS SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. USHA SHARMA, ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTER FOR RACE, POVERTY AND
THE ENVIRONMENT WITH AN OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. JENNIFER GANADO
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT REGISTERING A
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. SYLVIA SOLIS HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD, WE ARE UNFORTUNATELY
IN AN OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION, I'M ALSO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS, ALSO WITH AN OPPOSED
POSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY, BRING IT UP. ANY MORE IN
OPPOSITION? OKAY SEEING NONE, WE
HAVE OUR MEMBERS AT THE DAIS.
ANYBODY? SENATOR WIENER, THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. YOU, SOME OF US ARE LIKE
MOTHS TO THE FLAME, AND YOU ARE
DEFINITELY THE MOTH TO THE FLAME
ON THIS ONE. AND I REALLY
COMMEND YOU FOR TAKING THIS, FOR
TAKING THIS ON BUILDER'S REMEDY.
OF COURSE, WAS SORT OF A DEAD
LETTER FOR A LONG TIME. THIS
THING THAT HAD BEEN IN IN
CALIFORNIA LAW FOR DECADES AND,
AND JUST MOST PEOPLE DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW ABOUT IT. AND THE REASON
PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT IT NOW AND
WHY, YOU KNOW, IT'S BECOME THIS
CONTENTIOUS DEBATE AND WHY, YOU
KNOW, LEADING TO THIS BILL IS
BECAUSE WE FINALLY OVER THE LAST
YOU KNOW, SIX, EIGHT YEARS, PUT
TEETH INTO OUR STATE HOUSING
PLANNING REQUIREMENTS. WE
ACTUALLY CREATED RINA NUMBERS
THAT WERE NOT A JOKE, AND RINA
WAS JUST A JOKE FOR A LONG TIME
IN TERMS OF THE LOW NUMBERS THAT
CITIES WERE RECEIVING, AND WE
CHANGED THAT AND WE ACTUALLY.
AND THEN WE SAID, YOU KNOW,
HOUSING ELEMENT HAS MEANING. YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO A HOUSING
ELEMENT. IT'S NOT JUST A PIECE
OF PAPER THAT COLLECTS DUST ON
THE SHELF, AND WE PUT TEETH INTO
IT. AND THAT'S A POWERFUL THING.
AND IT'S CREATED TENSION. BUT
IT'S HEALTHY, LONG OVERDUE,
TENSION DURING THIS TRANSITION
PERIOD. AND SO NOW BUILDER'S
REMEDY HAS MEANING BECAUSE OF
THE CHANGES IN THE LAW THAT
WE'VE THAT WE'VE THAT THAT WE'VE
MADE, AND I KNOW, YOU KNOW, THIS
HAS BEEN A TOUGH ONE FOR A LOT
OF US BECAUSE I HAVE IN TERMS OF
THE COALITIONS THAT I WORK WITH
IN THE PRO HOUSING WORLD, THE
PEOPLE WHO ALL AGREE THAT WE
NEED A LOT MORE HOUSING, THERE'S
DISAGREEMENT WITHIN THAT
COALITION. AND SO IT'S A TOUGH
ONE. AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN
CHALLENGING FOR YOU AS WELL. AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY TO MY FRIENDS
ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS ISSUE,
WE'LL FIGURE IT OUT. IT'S ALL
GOING TO BE IT'S ALL GOING TO BE
GOOD, AND I DO THINK THAT THERE
IS, YOU KNOW, THE CURRENT
BUILDER'S REMEDY IS A VERY
CHAOTIC THING. IT'S NOT IT WAS
NOT A WELL CONSTRUCTED LAW. IT
CREATES A LOT OF CHAOS AND
UNCERTAINTY. THERE ARE SOME WHO
BELIEVE THAT THAT CHAOS AND
UNCERTAINTY IS A GOOD THING
BECAUSE IT CREATES A STRONGER
INCENTIVE FOR CITIES TO ACTUALLY
GET IT TOGETHER AND FOLLOW THE
RULES. ON THE OTHER HAND, AS
YOU'VE NOTED, IT'S NOT LEADING
TO SOME EXPLOSION OF NEW HOUSING
OR REALLY MUCH HOUSING OR ANY
HOUSING AT ALL. AND SO I THINK
THERE IS A REALLY GOOD ARGUMENT
TO, TO REALLY STRENGTHEN THE
LAW. WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE.
AND, AND SO I REALLY DO, COMMEND
YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU, SO THIS
ONE, I'M REALLY KIND OF TORN ON,
ON ONE HAND, PROBABLY THE WORST
WAY TO GET ME TO AGREE WITH OR
DISAGREE WITH THE BILL IS TO
START ATTACKING CITIES AND
MAKING IT SOUND LIKE IT IS ALL
THEIR FAULT. IT'S ALL THE FAULT
OF THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE
THAT DON'T WANT THESE THINGS
GOING ON, I HAVE WATCHED CITIES
EVOLVE, NEW CITIES THAT HAVE
GONE THROUGH, BUILDING PHASES
AND TRYING TO DO THEIR UPDATE,
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENTS AND THEIR
GENERAL PLANS AND ALL OF THOSE
THINGS. AND WHEN THEY FINALLY
GET DONE WITH ONE, A YEAR LATER,
A NEW LAW COMES INTO PLACE AND
THEY HAVE TO GO OUT, FIND $2
MILLION TO GO REDO ALL OF THEIR
GENERAL PLAN, THEIR HOUSING AND
ALL THAT. SO THERE'S A PROCESS
THAT HAS CREATED A LOT OF ANGST
WITH CITIES. AND YES, THERE ON
THE OTHER HAND, THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT ABSOLUTELY, YOU KNOW, THEY
WANT TO KEEP THEIR COMMUNITY AT
A CERTAIN BUILDING LEVEL OF
INCOME AND ON ALL OF THAT. AND
THAT IS EQUALLY AS WRONG, YOU
KNOW, SO I'M, I'M LOOKING AT
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF SOME OF
THE CITIES I REPRESENT,
INCLUDING THE CITY I LIVE IN AND
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN
HEARING ANTI THIS AND ANTI THAT
ON CITIES. SOMEBODY BETTER GET
DOWN TO MY AREA AND LOOK AND SEE
WHAT'S GETTING BUILT THERE,
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF
GETTING BUILT. THE REASON IT'S
GETTING BUILT NOW AND NOT EIGHT
YEARS AGO IS NOT THE CITY'S
FAULT. I WAS THERE WHEN WE HAD
AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT IN
2016, AND IT WAS A GOOD PROJECT,
AND IT THE BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN HCD AND ALL THE OTHER
DIFFERENT HOUSING AGENCIES AND
THE FUNDING AGENCIES AND ALL OF
THAT, THEY ARE FINALLY GRADING
EIGHT YEARS LATER. THEY'RE
GRADING. OKAY. SO THERE'S A
PROCESS IN THERE WHERE CITIES
ARE TRYING LIKE HELL TO BUILD
AND GET WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE DOING. BUT THERE'S ALSO THE
OTHER PART WHICH WE'VE CREATED
THAT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO GET
THROUGH. WE CITIES DON'T HAVE
CONTROL OVER BUILDER FINANCING,
CITIES DON'T HAVE CONTROL OVER
HCD FIGHTING WITH CITIES OVER
DEFINITIONS AND WHETHER THERE
AND GOING THIS GOING BACK AND
FORTH TRYING TO GET A HOUSING
ELEMENT THAT THEY JUST GOT DONE
DONE AGAIN. SO IT'S LIKE
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO WORK
TOGETHER. STOP BLAMING EACH
OTHER. I MEAN, WE OUR, OUR LIKE
HCD AND OTHER AGENCIES THAT WORK
WITH CITIES, THEY THEY HAVE TO
REMEMBER CUSTOMER SERVICE CITIES
ARE THEIR CUSTOMERS TOO. THEY'RE
NOT THERE TO JUST TO COME OUT
AND WIELD A HAMMER AND BEAT THEM
OVER THE HEAD, BECAUSE THAT'S
NOT GOING TO ACCOMPLISH
ANYTHING. AND IN FACT, SOME OF
THIS STUFF IS GOING TO HAVE A
BACKLASH TO IT, BECAUSE SOME OF
THE STUFF THAT IS GETTING BUILT
RIGHT NOW, PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT
THOSE AND THINKING, OH MY GOD.
AND IF I WERE, I WOULDN'T WANT
TO RENT ONE OF THOSE BECAUSE
THEY LOOK HORRIBLE. WHO WANTS TO
GO AND LIVE IN SOMETHING THAT
LOOKS TERRIBLE? SO THAT'S WHY
CITIES NEED THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE SOME SAY IN HOW
SOMETHING LOOKS. BUT A LOT OF
THE LAWS WE WANT, THE BUILDER'S
REMEDY AND ALL THESE, THESE ARE
JUST CRAMMING THOSE THINGS IN
AND THEY'RE AND SOME OF THEM ARE
HIDEOUS LOOKING AND THEY'RE IN
HIDEOUS LOCATIONS RIGHT NEXT TO
A FREEWAY, RIGHT NEXT TO A BUSY
STREET. NO PARKING. ALL OF THOSE
THINGS ARE COMING TO PASS NOW,
AND YOU'RE GOING TO GET A BIGGER
BACKLASH FROM COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THERE'S NO WAY FOR THEM
TO MITIGATE THOSE THINGS. SO,
YOU KNOW, I YOU KNOW, THIS IS
LAW, THIS YOU KNOW, THE
BUILDER'S REMEDY IS LAW. AND IT
DOES NEED FIXED. AND, SO I'M
KIND OF WILLING TO TRY AND KEEP
THIS MOVING SO YOU CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT. BUT FOR PETE'S
SAKE, YOU GOT TO GET OFF THIS
ANTI CITY NONSENSE BECAUSE I WAS
THERE AND I'M NOT I WASN'T THERE
AS A CITY MEMBER. I WAS I WAS ON
THE CITY COUNCIL FOR SURE. I
WASN'T THERE AS AN ADVOCATE FOR
THE CITY, BUT I GOT TO WATCH THE
PROCESS AND HOW FRUSTRATING IT
IS. AND NOW WE'RE LISTENING TO
THIS, THIS NONSENSE ABOUT THE
CITIES, THIS AND THE CITIES
THAT, AND THEY'RE JUST TRYING TO
HELP COMMUNITIES BE GREAT
COMMUNITIES FOR EVERYONE TO LIVE
IN. AND IF EVERYBODY WOULD
COOPERATE, WE COULD GET THERE.
AND THIS IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
HASHED OUT SOMEWHERE SOMEHOW, SO
THAT WE CAN FIND THAT SWEET SPOT
WHERE THEY HAVE ENOUGH INCENTIVE
TO DO IT, BUT ALSO THE ABILITY
TO DO IT. AND IN THE LAST THING
I'M GOING TO SAY ON THIS SUBJECT
MATTER IN CALIFORNIA, THERE IS
NO SUCH THING AS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO BE BUILT. THERE IS NO
WAY TO BUILD AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSE. THE ONLY THING WE CAN DO
IS SUBSIDIZE WHATEVER IT COSTS
TO BUILD TO BRING THE PRICE
DOWN. SOMEHOW, FOR A WHILE. SO
THAT'S, YOU KNOW, FOR ME, THAT'S
THE FRUSTRATION OF THIS. AND I
THINK YOU CAN TELL THAT IN MY
VOICE, FOR ALL OF THESE YEARS,
I'VE BEEN LISTENING TO THIS AND
WATCHING THIS AND, AND WORKING
WITH CITIES AND, AND TRYING TO
FIND WHAT, YOU KNOW, WHERE IS
THE SWEET SPOT AND WE CAN'T FIND
IT. SO. SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS. IT SEEMS A LITTLE BIT
OF HEAVY HANDEDNESS, BUT I THINK
IT NEEDS TO BE WORKED ON A
LITTLE MORE, AND I'M WILLING TO
LET IT GO, IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON IT SO THAT WE CAN GET
SOMETHING THAT REALLY DOES WORK.
THANK YOU. CAN I CAN I WOULD YOU
MIND IF I RESPOND, MADAM CHAIR,
TO THAT OR I CAN ALSO TAKE OTHER
QUESTIONS. SURE YES. YES THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AS IS NOTED ON
OUR MATERIALS, THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE, WHICH I CHAIR,
SUPPORTED THIS BILL AND I VOTED
YES. AND OUR IF I TAKE THE ISSUE
OF THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING, WHICH
OF COURSE, WAS A CONCERN FOR OUR
COMMITTEE AS TO WHETHER WE WOULD
ALLOW FOR A MODIFICATION ON THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ISSUE. BUT
WHEN WE LOOKED AT ALL THE DATA
AND THE FACT THAT EVEN WITH OUR
STRENGTHENED HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AND THERE
HAVE, MANY LAWS THAT HAVE
STRENGTHENED IT, INCLUDING MY SB
330 AND, I'M GOING TO FORGET THE
OTHER ONE, I THINK IT WAS SB
167, BUT I CAN'T REMEMBER. SO
DON'T HOLD ME ON ON BILL
NUMBERS. BUT AND THEN THE
COMBINATION OF HCD'S WILLINGNESS
TO ENFORCE THE RENA, IT HAS, OF
COURSE, RAISED THE SPECTER OF
BUILDER'S REMEDY. HOWEVER, EVEN
WITH THE STRENGTHENING OF THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AND
THE NUMBER OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT ARE NOT IN COMPLIANCE,
WE'VE NOT YET SEEN A PROJECT
BUILT UNDER BUILDING BUILDER'S
REMEDY. SO NOW LOOK, ON THE ONE
HAND, IT WOULD BE GREAT IF THERE
WAS NEVER A PROJECT BUILT UNDER
BUILDER'S REMEDY. IT WOULD BE
GREAT IF OUR CITIES WOULD JUST
COME INTO COMPLIANCE. I'M NOT
TRYING TO ATTACK CITIES, SENATOR
SATO. I'M JUST BEING CLEAR THAT
WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO HAVE THESE
ENFORCEMENTS IF THEY WOULD COME
INTO COMPLIANCE, HOWEVER, IF
THEY DON'T, THEN THE BUILDER'S
REMEDY IS A REMEDY, AND IT WAS
IN LAW WELL BEFORE IT WAS PUT
INTO LAW. I CAN'T EVEN REMEMBER
THE EXACT YEAR IT WAS THE LATE
60S, I BELIEVE. IN A MINUTE.
ANYWAY, IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME,
DECADES, AND YET WE'VE NOT SEEN.
SO IF I'M NOW SPEAKING JUST FROM
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING POINT OF
VIEW, IF OUR COMMITMENT IS TO
ENSURE THAT WE ACHIEVE SOME
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, IF A
BUILDER'S REMEDY PROJECT IS
BUILT, THEN WHAT THE CONCLUSION
OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE WAS IS
THAT WE WERE OPEN TO THE CHANGE
IN THE REQUIREMENT BECAUSE WE'D
NOT YET OUR GOAL IS TO GET
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND WE'VE NOT
ACHIEVED IT. AND BY BY OUR IF WE
INSIST ON A CERTAIN NUMBER, IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET THAT WHICH WE
WANT. SO THE, THE, OUR
CONCLUSION IN THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE WAS THAT THE CHANGES
WHILE YES, ON THE FACE OF IT,
LOOK SOMEHOW LIKE WE ARE HURTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN FACT MIGHT
RESULT IN OUR ACHIEVING IT. IF
ANY BUILDER'S REMEDIES PROJECTS
GO THROUGH AND THE OTHER CHANGES
IN THE BILL WE FELT WOULD MAKE
IT MORE LIKELY THAT A BUILDER'S
PROJECT REMEDY PROJECT GOT
BUILT. AND I CAN CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE SOME PEOPLE AND SOME
OF THE OPPOSITION JUST DOESN'T
LIKE BUILDER'S REMEDY, PERIOD.
BUT IT IS NOT BEFORE US TO
ELIMINATE THAT ASPECT OF THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY LAW.
WHAT'S BEFORE US IS WHETHER WE
MODIFY IT OR NOT. AND IT WAS THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE'S CONCLUSION
THAT THE MODIFICATIONS THAT WERE
IN THE BILL WERE APPROPRIATE IN
ORDER TO HAVE THE REMEDY ON OUR
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY LAW, BE
FUNCTIONAL AND WORK. I, THERE
WAS AN ASSERTION THAT THIS
OVERRIDE OVERRODE, WHAT'S THE
WORD? INCLUSIONARY HOUSING, BUT
I ANYWAY, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS THAT AUTHOR, I
WOULD ACTUALLY ASK MR. FISH, IF
YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO THAT.
SURE. I THANK YOU, SENATOR. I
THAT IS EXACTLY THE LOGIC OF THE
BILL THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACTUALLY GET THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OR SUBSIDIZED HOUSING IF
YOU WILL, AND THE LOCAL
INCLUSIONARY IS AN INTERESTING
ISSUE BECAUSE JUST IN THE
OPPOSITION LETTERS, YOU CAN SEE
THE DIVERGENCE OF OPINIONS ALL
THE WAY FROM ONE GROUP SUBMITTED
A LETTER SAYING THAT WE WERE
FOOLISHLY INTRODUCING LOCAL
INCLUSIONARY INTO THE BUILDER'S
REMEDY, AND IT DOESN'T EXIST
UNDER CURRENT LAW TO WE WERE
DESTROYING LOCAL INCLUSIONARY,
WHICH OF COURSE IS PRESERVED
UNDER EXISTING LAW. SO THOSE ARE
OBVIOUSLY DIAMETRICALLY OPPOSITE
OPINIONS. THAT'S THE SORT OF
THING THAT WOULD GET RESOLVED IN
COURT OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS,
AND WE WOULDN'T KNOW UNTIL A
COURT OF APPEAL DECISION AND
EVERYBODY CAN. THIS IS THE TYPE
OF LEGAL AMBIGUITY OF THESE
STEAKS. EVERYBODY CAN PUT THEIR
DREAMS ONTO WHAT THAT WHAT THE
MEANING IS OF THE LAW, COURTS
ARE GOING TO DO WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO. SO WE TRIED TO
STRIKE A BALANCE IN IN MANY
AREAS OF THIS TEXT. YOU'LL SEE
THAT IN LOCAL INCLUSIONARY IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE WHERE WE SAID WE
WILL ALLOW LOCAL LOCAL ENTITIES
TO USE THEIR LOCAL INCLUSIONARY
PROGRAMS IF THEY'RE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE PROJECT IS
FEASIBLE, JUST SINCE WE'RE ON
THAT SUBJECT, MR. ROSSEN, CAN
YOU YOU YOU WERE AROUND WHEN
THIS. YEAH. FIRST GOT STARTED. I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
MISUNDERSTOOD PEOPLE HAVE SAID
SOME SOME OF THE WITNESSES SAID
THERE HAVEN'T BEEN ANY BUILDERS
REMEDY PROJECTS APPROVED. THAT'S
NOT TRUE. BUT YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT A BUILDER'S
REMEDY PROJECT IS, ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT WAS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS THAT WERE OR
DEVELOPERS THAT WERE WILLING TO
PROVIDE 20% THE NONPROFIT
DEVELOPER GOES IN, MAKES A
PROPOSAL FOR AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECT, AND THE NIMBYS
COME OUT AND THEY TURN IT DOWN
AND THEY DON'T HAVE A HOUSING
ELEMENT THAT'S IN COMPLIANCE.
THEY ALSO DON'T HAVE A GOOD
HEALTH AND SAFETY REASON AS TO
WHY TO TURN IT DOWN. AND WE CALL
THEM UP ON THE PHONE AND WE
TALKED TO THE CITY ATTORNEY AND
WE SAY, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE GOING
TO GET SUED IF YOU DON'T DO
THIS. AND THAT'S GOING TO COST
YOU EVEN MORE MONEY. SO YOU
SHOULD FOLLOW THE LAW. AND MOST
OF THE TIME, THE CITY ATTORNEYS,
THEY DIDN'T KNOW FROM THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT, THEY
READ IT. AND THEN THE PROJECT
WAS APPROVED. THAT'S A BUILDER'S
REMEDY PROJECT. AND THERE HAVE
BEEN MANY, MANY OF THOSE
APPROVED BY NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS
OVER THE COURSE OF ALMOST 30
YEARS OF THIS LAW. SO I THINK
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT TOO,
THAT THIS IS THIS IS FOR, THIS
IS OPENED THE DOOR FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO
GET OVER THE NIMBY OPPOSITION
THAT OCCURS IN IN SOME
COMMUNITIES, NOT ALL
COMMUNITIES, BUT IN SOME
COMMUNITIES IT OCCURS. IT WASN'T
THAT THE CASE IN THE SANTA
MONICA, THERE WAS A 16. ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT THE RECENT
BUILDERS, BUILDERS REMEDY
PROJECT? YEAH, THERE WAS THERE
WERE 16 PROPOSED AND THEY
RESISTED. AND THEY WENT INTO BUT
THEY LOOKED AT THE LAW AND THEY
SAID, WELL, WE'LL PROBABLY GOING
TO HAVE TO APPROVE THESE. SO
THEY SAT DOWN AND NEGOTIATED
AND, AND CAME TO VARIOUS
DECISIONS ABOUT EACH ONE. I'M
NOT SURE WHAT THOSE WERE, BUT
THEY WERE SETTLED. YEAH, YEAH.
YES. THE AUTHOR WANTED TO
RESPOND, YEAH. I WAS JUST GOING
TO THERE WAS SORT OF A LOT OF
COMMENT HERE. I DON'T KNOW IF
I'M ALSO HAPPY TO. I DON'T KNOW
IF ANYONE ELSE WANTS TO SPEAK. I
CAN KIND OF WRAP UP. OH, I'M
SORRY, I'M SORRY I WENT TO YOU.
YES, SENATOR DARLING. WELL, I
JUST, FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING A DIFFICULT BILL, I
BELIEVE. AND, BUT I WANT I JUST
WANT TO SHED SOME LIGHT ON MAYBE
JUST THE PROCESS AND, YEARS OF
BEING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL, DOING
GENERAL PLANS AND TRYING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING. AND I'VE SAID
I'M KIND OF ALONG THE SAME LINES
AS SENATOR SUHARTO THAT, FIRST
OF ALL, CITIES DON'T BUILD
HOUSES, DEVELOPERS BUILD HOUSES.
AND WE'VE SEEN THE EVOLUTION OF,
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE THAT PROFIT,
THAT BUILD HOUSES ARE TRYING TO
MAKE A PROFIT. AND WE'VE SEEN
NOW NON-PROFITS, A LOT OF
NONPROFITS, FOLKS IN THE
MARKETPLACE, BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING TO MANIPULATE WHAT KIND
OF HOUSING WE GET OUT THERE. AND
I AGREE WITH THE STATEMENT THAT
THERE ARE NO AFFORDABLE HOUSES
IN CALIFORNIA, PERIOD. I DON'T
CARE IF YOU CALL IT AFFORDABLE.
IT'S NOT AFFORDABLE. AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR THOSE FOLKS WHO
ARE IN THAT CATEGORY. AND THOSE
ARE MY CHILDREN. AND IT'S THEY
HAVE A NO DREAM OF EVER OWNING A
HOME IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT IS
VERY HARD TO ATTAIN THAT NOW,
NOW, IN MY DISTRICT, WE ARE THE
LARGEST DISTRICT IN THE STATE
GEOGRAPHICALLY, AND THE REASON
WE'RE THERE, WE LIKE OPEN
SPACES, BUT THE FOLKS. SO THIS
IS A BATTLE MORE IN AREAS THAT
YOU ALL REPRESENT, AND I CAN'T
IMAGINE DEALING WITH THE
FRUSTRATIONS THAT YOU ALL DEAL
WITH. AND, YOU KNOW, BUT I AM
ALSO A SENATOR THAT REPRESENTS
MY DISTRICT AND ALSO REPRESENTS
THE WHOLE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE GET TO WEIGH IN ON THESE
ISSUES AND WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
OTHER AREAS WILL EVENTUALLY COME
TO MY AREAS AND PARTS OF MY
AREA. SO, I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY, AND
I THINK I THINK IT DOES MAYBE
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE WORK. BUT
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT SOMEHOW
WE HAVE TO GET TO THE POINT
WHERE, WE'RE NOT HAVING
ATTORNEYS DUEL BACK AND FORTH
ABOUT WHAT LAWS DO, WHAT,
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WE STILL NEED TO DRIVE THE COST
OF HOUSING DOWN, TRULY DRIVE IT
DOWN. AND THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN
DO THAT IS FOCUS ON SOME OF THE
OTHER POLICIES, NOT WHAT A CITY
OR COUNTY IS DOING FOR THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT, BUT OUR GREEN
BUILDING STANDARDS ARE OUR COST
OF ENERGY, OUR COST OF PRODUCING
MATERIALS THAT BUILD HOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA. I MEAN, WE TALK
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, IT TAKES
CONCRETE AND OUR CONCRETE IS SO
MUCH HIGHER THAN EVERYWHERE
ELSE. OUR LABOR IS SO MUCH
HIGHER. EVERYTHING IS HIGHER IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF
REGULATIONS AND MANY FACTORS
PLAY INTO IT. AND WE WORK AROUND
THE EDGES ON BILLS LIKE THIS TO
TRY TO GET SOMEBODY TO A PLACE
WHERE THEY CAN ACTUALLY BUILD A
HOUSE. AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT,
WE HAVE FOLKS WHO DON'T WANT TO
HAVE ANYTHING HAPPEN IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THEY VOTE THEY'LL
TELL THEIR REPRESENTATIVE, YEAH,
GO PASS ALL THESE POLICIES. BUT
WHEN YOU COME, WHEN IT COMES
DOWN TO THEIR COMMUNITY, THEY
PUSH BACK. THEY DON'T WANT ANY
NEIGHBORS AND OR THEY DON'T.
THEY DON'T WANT TO CHANGE THEIR
COMMUNITY FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY WORK IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND I HAVE TRUCKEE, I REPRESENT
THE CITY OF TRUCKEE AND TAHOE,
WHERE THE BILLIONAIRES ARE
KICKING OUT THE MILLIONAIRES,
LITERALLY. YEAH, IT'S BIZARRE
AND THEY DON'T CARE. THE
BILLIONAIRES DON'T CARE. THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE THEIR SPACE. BUT
THE PEOPLE THAT SERVE THEM LIVE
IN RENO, NEVADA AND HAVE TO
COMMUTE EVERY DAY UP TO TRUCKEE
TO TRY TO SERVE THEIR NEEDS. AND
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THOSE
ISSUES TO TRY TO GET THOSE FOLKS
TO BE ABLE TO LIVE IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. ACTUALLY, TRUCKEE
USED TO BE A LITTLE LOGGING
TOWN, AND THAT'S WHERE ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT WORKED IN THE SKI
RESORTS LIVED, AND NOW IT'S
TURNED INTO A PLACE WHERE YOU
CAN'T AFFORD EITHER. SO I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
BECAUSE I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS WHERE WE
ACTUALLY MAKE IT AVAILABLE FOR
THOSE FOLKS THAT SERVE THOSE
WEALTHY FOLKS HAVE A PLACE TO BE
IN PART OF THAT COMMUNITY AS
WELL, AND NOT HAVE TO LIVE
SOMEPLACE A LONG WAYS. AND AWAY
TO SERVE THEM. AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, I'LL BE SUPPORTING
BILL. I HOPE THAT WE CAN GET TO
A PLACE WHERE AND I KNOW THAT
ALL CITIES AREN'T HERE. SOME OF
THEM HAVE HAVE DONE THEIR JOB
VERY WELL. AND THIS HAS BEEN AN
OPPORTUNITY, I THINK, FOR SOME
TO PUSH BACK. AND SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY,
HOPEFULLY FOR THE FACT THAT WE
CAN GET THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY WORK AND ARE ON THOSE
WORKING WAGES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND I THINK THIS
BILL WILL ACTUALLY HELP US GET
THERE. SO THANK YOU. DID YOU
WANT TO. YEAH, I JUST WANTED TO
ON THE SANTA MONICA EXAMPLE. AND
OF COURSE, THERE WERE A COUPLE,
BUT OUR HOUSING COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL CITED THE
SANTA MONICA EXAMPLE. I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S EXACTLY THE SAME
ONE, BUT IN THAT NEGOTIATION,
SANTA MONICA REDUCED THE
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT. SO
THAT WAS THE RESULT OF AND
OKAYING THE PROJECT TO REDUCE
THE AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT.
OKAY, OKAY. I HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION FOR MR. ROSSEN, THE
ISSUE OF INCLUSION, INCLUSIONARY.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN THAT A LITTLE
BIT MORE? SURE, SO, RIGHT NOW
THE BILL SAYS THAT IF YOU
PROPOSE A BUILDER'S REMEDY
PROJECT BY ONE OF THE
PERCENTAGES THAT'S IN THE
CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL, IT
CAN. YEAH. JUST TURNED OFF MY
MIC. IT THE YOU YOU HAVE TO
APPLY THE INCLUSIONARY
PERCENTAGE IF IT'S A GREATER
PERCENTAGE, BUT YOU CAN ONLY
APPLY THAT INCLUSIONARY
PERCENTAGE IF IT'S A GREATER
PERCENTAGE. IS IF YOU DO A
STUDY, IF YOU CAN MAKE A FINDING
THAT BY PUTTING THAT GREATER
PERCENTAGE ON THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, ON THE BUILDER'S REMEDY
PROJECT, THAT PUTTING THAT
PERCENTAGE ON THE BUILDERS
PROJECT IS FEASIBLE, OR PUTTING
THAT PUTTING THAT PERCENTAGE ON
THE BUILDERS PROJECT WILL NOT
RENDER IT INFEASIBLE. YOU HAVE
TO DO THAT. AND SO EVERY
COMMUNITY IN WHICH A BUILDER'S
REMEDY PROJECT IS PROPOSED WOULD
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS
IN ORDER TO PROPOSE THEIR,
THEIR, THEIR INCLUSIONARY ZONING
REQUIREMENT. AND IN SANTA
MONICA, WITH 16 BUILDERS
REMEDIES PROJECT, THEY WOULD
HAVE HAD TO LOOK AT EACH PROJECT
INDIVIDUALLY AND COME UP WITH AN
ANALYSIS THAT SAID WHETHER OR
NOT THE INCLUSIONARY IN SANTA
MONICA WAS FEASIBLE OR NOT
FEASIBLE, IT'S JUST NOT WORKABLE.
AND THE STATE? THE STATE, WHAT
DO YOU MEAN IT'S NOT WORKABLE?
WELL, ESPECIALLY WITH REGARDS TO
THE RIGHT. RIGHT NOW, THE
STATE'S FIRST OF ALL, THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA REQUIRES THAT WHEN
YOU DO YOUR HOUSING ALERT, IF
YOU HAVE AN INCLUSIONARY ZONING
ORDINANCE AND OVER 170
COMMUNITIES DO, IF YOU HAVE
THAT, YOU HAVE TO PUT IN YOUR
HOUSING ELEMENT AN ANALYSIS THAT
SHOWS THAT YOUR INCLUSIONARY
ZONING ORDINANCE, INCLUDING THE
PERCENTAGE, DOES NOT CREATE A
CONSTRAINT TO DEVELOPMENT. YOU
ALREADY HAVE TO DO THAT IN YOUR
HOUSING ELEMENT. I KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CITIES THAT
HAVEN'T DONE THEIR HOUSING, BUT
THERE ARE OTHER REMEDIES THAT
THE STATE HAS AS WELL. THE STATE
CAN REQUIRE THAT ANY COMMUNITY
THAT HAS A 15% REQUIREMENT OR
HIGHER INCLUSIONARY REQUIREMENT,
THE STATE CAN REQUIRE THAT THEY
DO A STUDY OVER THE WHOLE CITY
TO SEE WHETHER THERE ARE 15%
INCLUSIONARY REQUIREMENT IS, IS
FEASIBLE. THE LAST THING ALL
INCLUSIONARY ORDINANCES HAVE A
PROVISION IN THEM THAT SAYS, IF
A DEVELOPER DOESN'T BELIEVE OR
THINKS THAT THEY CAN'T MAKE A
FAIR RETURN ON THEIR INVESTMENT
BY PROVIDING THAT PERCENTAGE OF
INCLUSIONARY THE THEY CAN GO TO
THE CITY AND SAY, YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWING ME TO GET A FAIR RETURN
ON INVESTMENT, CAN I GET MY
INCLUSIONARY REDUCED AND ALL
ORDINANCES, ALL THE, ALL THE
INCLUSIONARY ORDINANCES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT I'VE SEEN HAVE
THAT PROVISION IN THEM. AND THE
CITY CAN SAY IF THE DEVELOPER
MAKES THE CASE, THEY CAN REDUCE
THE PERCENTAGE THAT'S ALREADY
THERE. SO WE DON'T NEED THIS
NOW, ESPECIALLY IF IT HAS TO BE
A ON EVERY SINGLE BUILDER'S
REMEDY PROJECT. IT'S GOING TO,
REALLY, CITIES CAN'T AFFORD THAT.
AND SO THEY WILL NOT APPLY THEIR
INCLUSIONARY LAW, WHICH THEY'VE
ALREADY LOOKED AT. AND DECIDED
THAT'S WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN IN
THEIR COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO GO
FORWARD AND GROW, WE NEED TO
INCLUDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE'RE NOT DOING WHAT WE NEED TO
DO FOR COMMUNITIES OF MINORITY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO AFFORD TO STAY
IN OUR CITIES. THANK YOU, MR.
WHITING. CERTAINLY. THANK YOU.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT ON
THE ISSUE OF FEASIBILITY, ONE OF
THE PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
ESSENTIALLY PUTS THE BURDEN ON
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO PROVE
THAT IT'S OBJECTIVE STANDARDS,
AGAIN, NOT SUBJECTIVE STANDARDS,
OBJECTIVE STANDARDS APPLICABLE
TO AN APPROPRIATE ZONE AS
DEFINED IN THE BILL ARE
FEASIBLE. I THINK ONE, EVEN WITH
AN EXPERT, THAT WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT TO
AFFIRMATIVELY PROVE THAT
FEASIBILITY HAS AN ECONOMIC
ELEMENT, AND WITHOUT ACCESS TO
THE DEVELOPER'S FINANCES,
WITHOUT ACCESS TO A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT WE OFTEN DON'T
HAVE, EVEN WITH AN EXPERT, THAT
WOULD BE EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO
DO TO THE POINT MADE, ALLOWING
THE DEVELOPER TO DEMONSTRATE
INFEASIBILITY MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE. THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION, AND WITHIN THE
POLICY THAT THE BUILDER'S REMEDY
THAT IS IN EXISTING LAW THAT WE
DON'T CHALLENGE WITHIN THE
POLICY, THERE IS SOME THERE IS
SOMETHING TO BE SAID FOR
OFFERING THEM THAT OPPORTUNITY.
FLIPPING THE BURDEN AROUND
FUNCTIONALLY IS GOING TO MAKE IT
VERY, VERY DIFFICULT TO ENFORCE
ANY OBJECTIVE STANDARDS, EVEN
THE ONES THAT THAT THIS BILL,
ONE ALLOWS AND THAT TWO DON'T
PHYSICALLY PRECLUDE DOING
WHATEVER IT WAS THE BUILDER
PROPOSED. SO I THINK THAT THAT'S,
AGAIN, ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE SORT
OF AMBIGUITIES. HOW'S IT GOING
TO WORK IN PRACTICE? HOW IS IT
GOING TO BE ADMINISTRABLE? THAT
CERTAINLY AFFECTS INCLUSIONARY
ISSUES, BUT ALSO AFFECTS THE
BASIC IMPOSITION OF ANY FORM OF
STANDARDS. THANK YOU. OKAY, OKAY.
I, WOULD LIKE TO HEAR JUST A
QUICKLY FROM MR. SMITH, IF YOU
COULD ADD ANYTHING ON LABOR. I
KNOW YOU CAME IN LATE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
JEREMY SMITH HERE AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA. I THINK OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL AS WE DISCUSSED,
WITH MR. FISCH FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE, WE APPRECIATE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS IS AROUND
THIS IDEA OF DISAPPROVALS UNDER
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT,
WE READ THE BILL NOW AS ALLOWING
DEVELOPERS TO CHALLENGE ANY
PERMITTING ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION OR PUBLIC HEALTH
ANALYSIS WHICH THEY CONSIDER,
QUOTE, BURDENSOME AS AN ILLEGAL
DISAPPROVAL, EVEN WHEN THOSE
AGENCY ACTIONS MAY BE NECESSARY
TO ADDRESS ENVIRONMENTAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS, WE FEAR
THIS COULD UNDERMINE THE ENTIRE
SEQUA, AND LAND USE PROCESS. I
DON'T THINK THAT'S THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT, BUT THAT'S HOW WE READ
THE BILL, IN ITS CURRENT FORM,
IN PRINT, AND WE THINK THIS IS
GOING TO UNDERMINE THOSE
PROCESSES BY ENCOURAGING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO APPROVE HOUSING
PROJECTS JUST TO AVOID
LITIGATION WITH POTENTIAL
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT, ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS. SO
OUR CONCERNS ARE AROUND THAT
KIND OF DEFINITION OF
DISAPPROVAL AND HOW THAT WOULD
BE DEALT WITH IN THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. GREAT. THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME, I THINK WE GO
BACK TO GO BACK TO THE AUTHOR.
YOU WANT TO. SURE. WRAP IT UP,
THANK YOU FOR THE CONVERSATION.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT, MY HOPE IS
THAT WE NEVER HAVE TO USE
BUILDER'S REMEDY THAT THIS THIS
LAW WILL NOT APPLY TO ANYONE.
BECAUSE, AS MR. SENATE-TV SAID,
WE'VE WORKED WITH OUR CITIES TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THEM TO WORK
WITH HCD TO HAVE A MORE SEAMLESS
PROCESS. I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT,
BECAUSE I DO HEAR THAT FROM SOME
OF MY CITIES AS WELL. I DO THINK
WE HAVE A LOT OF CITIES OUT
THERE WHO ARE DOING WHO ARE
DOING THE RIGHT THING, WHO ARE,
YOU KNOW, COMPLIANT WITH HOUSING
ELEMENT, WHO WANT TO BUILD, WHO
ARE ZONING THE RIGHT WAY, WHO
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN,
AND I'M SORRY. JUST. OH, YES.
SORRY TO INTERRUPT YOU FOR JUST
A SECOND. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE I WASN'T I NEED TO MAKE MY
COMMENTS. SURE. AND THEN YOU
WRAP UP OR. SURE. YES. I JUST
WANTED TO RESPOND TO MR.
SERRATO. FINISH THAT AND THEN
I'LL SAY SOME COMMENTS. THANK
YOU. SO, SO MY HOPE IS THAT WE
CAN YOU KNOW, THIS BILL IS ABOUT
CREATING CLARITY AROUND THE LAW.
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF LEGAL
AMBIGUITY. I DO THINK THERE'S
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE WITH
REGARD TO HCD AND HOW OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACCESS AND HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR STATE
AGENCIES. SO I CERTAINLY WOULD
WOULD CONTINUE TO, TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT, IT'S DEFINITELY A
COMPLICATED BILL. AND TO SENATOR
SKINNER'S POINT, THERE'S BEEN
AND THE CONVERSATION AROUND
INCLUSIONARY, THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF CONVERSATION AROUND THAT. AND
YOU'VE SEEN EVEN CITIES REDUCING
THEIR INCLUSIONARY RATE, BECAUSE
IN THE END OF THE DAY, WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE PROJECTS
PENCIL OUT OR ELSE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE FEASIBLE, SO AGAIN,
THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE I'M HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR AND OTHERS ON AROUND THE
INCLUSIONARY RATE, BUT I'M HAPPY
TO ALSO HEAR OUT YOUR QUESTIONS
AND THEN PROVIDE A CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELL, EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT YOU'RE A FIGHTER FOR
HOUSING ASSEMBLY MEMBER, SO I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT, AND WE
ALL WANT TO DO MUCH MORE.
EVERYBODY HERE TALKED ABOUT
EITHER THEIR OWN SITUATION,
THEIR OWN DISTRICT, ABOUT HOW WE
NEED MORE, MORE HOUSING, WE NEED
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING, IN MY
OPINION, BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT'S
KEEPING PEOPLE OUT OF FINDING A
HOME, OR BUYING A HOME OR JUST
PAYING THE RENT. SO WE NEED MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, AND IT'S,
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE BEEN WORKING.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING THE LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS, I CAN'T SUPPORT
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
IT'S A IT'S A HUGE LIFT. IT'S,
MAJOR CHANGES, MANY MOVING
PIECES. AND TO ASSESS, WE'VE HAD
A DIFFICULT TIME TO TRY TO
ASSESS THE IMPACTS OF THE ENTIRE
BILL. THERE ARE PARTS OF IT,
SOME OF THEM WERE MENTIONED BY
OUR PRO AND CON, WITNESSES. BUT
THIS DISAPPROVAL PROCESS, WILL
REALLY EXPOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO LITIGATION. THE OBJECTIVE
STANDARDS, YOU KNOW, KEEPS
BLOCKS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
IMPOSING ALL KINDS OF THINGS
THAT WE IN THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
ASKED THE LOCALS TO DEVELOP
POLICIES ON. WE'VE ASKED LOCALS
TO DEVELOP POLICIES ON CLIMATE
ADAPTATION, FIRE HAZARDS,
FLOODING, ELECTRIFICATION, OPEN
SPACE, LABOR REQUIREMENTS. WE'VE
DONE THAT. AND SO THIS BLOCKS
GOVERNMENTS FROM BEING ABLE TO
DO THAT. AFFORDABILITY LOWERS
AFFORDABILITY. SO THERE ARE SOME
VERY KEY THINGS HERE, THAT ARE
BEING DISRUPTED. THE LEGISLATURE
WORKED HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN QUICKLY APPROVE CEQA,
DOCUMENTS AND EXEMPTIONS FOR
HOUSING PROJECTS, I'M ALSO NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH THE WAY AGAIN,
THE OBJECTIVE STANDARDS. SO IN
MANY CASES IN THIS BUILDING,
WE'VE TOLD GOVERNMENT, AGAIN,
WORK HARD, ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
AND THIS BILL WOULD PREVENT
LOCAL AGENCIES FROM, IMPOSING
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT WE EXPECT
OF THIS, SO OUR GREATEST NEED IN
THIS STATE IS HOUSING FOR, IN MY
OPINION, IS HOUSING FOR THE
LOWEST INCOME INDIVIDUALS, AND
THIS BILL SHIFTS FROM THAT FOCUS
IN MY OPINION, WE TRIED WE'VE
HAD SOME COMMUNICATIONS, WE'VE
HAD SOME. AND I THOUGHT
YESTERDAY WE WERE READY TO GO.
YOU FELT THE AMENDMENTS WERE
UNWORKABLE. BUT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING HARD ON THIS. WE'VE MADE
SUGGESTIONS SINCE FOR A WEEK NOW,
AND, YOU KNOW, TO ME, THE
MESSAGE IS THAT, YOU KNOW,
UNLESS YOU HAVE THE WHOLE THING
AS IS THAT YOU'RE UNWILLING TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS. AND WE TRIED
REALLY HARD AND YOU WORKED WITH
YOUR STAFF NOT TO GET ANY
AMENDMENTS FROM THIS. AND TO BE
LEFT WITH ONLY THE BILL, I
THINK, IS NOT A GOOD IDEA. I
THINK IT REALLY, AGAIN, FOR ALL
THESE ISSUES THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT. SO, I WOULD BE,
VOTING NO ON IT. Ó. YES. THANK
YOU. BEFORE BEFORE HER CLOSE
CLOSURE? NOPE NO. OH, OKAY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I
APPRECIATE YOUR. YOUR POSITION,
AND AS I MENTIONED, HAVE,
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF RESPECT FOR
THE WORK YOU DO. AND I ALSO
AGREE WITH YOU ON THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OUR
LOWEST INCOME COMMUNITIES. I
ALSO THINK WE NEED HOUSING FOR
FOLKS AT ALL INCOME LEVELS. THIS
HAS BEEN A REALLY TOUGH BILL, AS
I MENTIONED, WITH A PRETTY
COMPLICATED COALITION, WHICH HAS
BEEN MENTIONED BY OTHER
COLLEAGUES AS WELL. I WANT TO
KEEP WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS
AND TRY TO EARN YOUR VOTE ON THE
FLOOR. IF THE BILL GETS OUT
TODAY, AND I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON SOME OF THE
STUFF THAT'S BEEN RAISED TODAY
AROUND, YOU KNOW, THE, THE
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES AND SOME OF
THE OBJECTIVE STANDARDS. I THINK
OUR STAFFS AND US CONTINUE, YOU
KNOW, HAD A LOT OF FRUITFUL
CONVERSATIONS. I DO THINK
THERE'S SOME PLACES WHERE SOME
OF THAT STUFF CAN LAND, AND WANT
TO KEEP WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT.
I'D LIKE TO SEE THE BILL MOVE
FORWARD SO WE CAN GET IT THROUGH
INTO THE NEXT HURDLE. OBVIOUSLY,
IT'LL GO TO IF IT GETS OUT
TODAY, IT'LL GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS, AND, AND
GENUINELY HAVE A COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH. WE'VE TAKEN A TON OF
AMENDMENTS ON THIS BILL
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE PROCESS,
THIS IS, I THINK IT'S GONE
THROUGH, I DON'T KNOW, MULTIPLE
COMMITTEES IN THE ASSEMBLY. WENT
THROUGH HOUSING HERE. SO MAYBE
IT'S FIFTH OR SIXTH COMMITTEE.
SO WE'VE TAKEN A LOT OF
AMENDMENTS ALONG THE WAY, AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO DO SO. AND I
EXPECT WE'LL CONTINUE TO TAKE
MORE AMENDMENTS AS WE MOVE INTO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
WILL WANT TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT, AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD, I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE SO THAT WE
CAN KEEP THAT CONVERSATION
GOING. I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH
ANY OF THE MEMBERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE WITH CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED TO SEE IF WE CAN
REFINE THE APPROACH. BUT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS TO
CREATE SOME CERTAINTY FOR FOLKS
AROUND A PRETTY AMBIGUOUS LAW
THAT DOES NEED TO BE FIXED
AGAIN, WITH THE GOAL THAT IT
NEVER ACTUALLY APPLIES, BECAUSE
CITIES ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING, AND WE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH HCD TO ENSURE THAT CITIES
CAN DO THE RIGHT THING. SO WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. OKAY, MOVE WITH THEIR
OUR VOTE. YOU ARE CUTTING OFF.
WE'RE CUTTING OFF DISCUSSION ON
THE BILL. I ASKED FOR HER TO
WRITE, BUT I HAD RAISED MY HAND.
WELL, YOU HAD ALREADY SPOKEN. I
SPOKE ONCE. IT'S TRUE. THAT'S
WHY I STOPPED HER EARLIER. TO
ASK HER. I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT
DISCUSSION WAS GOING TO BE CUT
OFF. I TOLD HER, ANSWER THE
QUESTION, AND SHE WAS GOING TO.
I WAS GOING TO MAKE MY REMARKS.
AND THEN SHE WAS GOING TO MAKE
HER CLOSING REMARKS. RIGHT. AND
I RAISED MY HAND. SO BECAUSE,
LOOK, IT'S OKAY. IT'S ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. I DON'T WITH ALL WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT, MADAM CHAIR, WE ARE
SENATORS. WE I THINK WE SHOULD
GIVE THE SENATOR AN OPPORTUNITY.
JUST JUST MY THING. WE ALLOWED A
LOT OF TESTIMONY TODAY AND THIS
IS A VERY BIG BILL AND A LOT OF
CONTROVERSY. I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU GIVE HER THE GRACE.
IF YOU WANT ME TO WITHDRAW MY
MOTION, I WILL. UNTIL AFTER THE
SENATOR SPEAKS. I WILL OKAY. GO
AHEAD. IT IS NEVER MY PREFERENCE
TO VOTE AGAINST A CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION. AND WHEN IN
LISTENING TO THE AUTHOR'S
OPENING COMMENTS, I HEARD THE
AUTHOR INDICATE SOME WILLINGNESS
TO MOVE TOWARDS WHAT THE
COMMITTEE WAS ASKING, BUT NOT IN
THE FORM THAT IS LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. NOW, I APPRECIATE
THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS. HOWEVER, I AM NOT
COMFORTABLE KILLING THE BILL. MY
COMMITTEE ALREADY SUPPORTED THE
BILL, AND I GAVE MY REASONS FOR
WHY, BUT I'M ALSO ALWAYS
RELUCTANT TO NOT SUPPORT A
CHAIR. AND UNLESS I HEARD WRONG,
I HEARD THE AUTHOR INDICATE THAT
THERE WAS WILLINGNESS TO MOVE,
NOT TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AS
WRITTEN, BUT TO MOVE TOWARDS.
NOW, WHETHER THAT HAPPENS IN A
PROCESS OR. BUT I JUST WANTED TO
PUT THAT ON THE RECORD BECAUSE,
AGAIN, WHILE I'M NOT WILLING TO
HAVE THE BILL DIE, IT IS ALSO
NOT MY PREFERENCE TO OVERRIDE
THE CHAIR. OKAY, YOU KNOW, EVERY
BILL THAT HAS COME THROUGH HERE,
WE HAVE WORKED REALLY, REALLY
HARD UP UNTIL THE LAST SECOND
BEFORE A VOTE IS TAKEN, WORKED
REALLY, REALLY HARD SOMETIMES
HERE TO REACH SOME AMENDMENTS TO
SHOW GOOD FAITH THAT WE'RE
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
EVERY TIME WE GOT CLOSER TO THE
TO THAT, THE NEGOTIATIONS WERE
STOPPED AND THE IDEAS WERE
REJECTED EVERY SINGLE TIME, ALL
THE WAY, EVEN UP UNTIL THIS
MORNING. SO I DON'T TAKE LIGHTLY
VOTING NO ON THIS BILL. I DON'T
TAKE LIGHTLY. BUT I ALSO NEED TO
KNOW AS CHAIR, I NEED TO KNOW
THAT THERE WAS A SERIOUSNESS
BEHIND THE COMMITMENT, THAT IT
WAS NOT JUST GOING TO BE. DON'T
WORRY ABOUT IT. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE CARE OF IT DOWN THE LINE.
IF I DON'T SEE THAT AND I SEE
JUST THE CURRENT BILL, TAKE IT
OR LEAVE IT, I'LL THINK ABOUT IT.
THAT'S JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE TO ME
AS A CHAIR. AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUES,
WHICH IS LOCAL GOVERNMENT. WE
NEED TO SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO PUSH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. I'M ALL FOR THAT.
BUT THE PROCESS HERE HAS BEEN
THAT THERE'S NO ACCEPTANCE OF
SOME SERIOUS AMENDMENTS. NONE.
SO I REALLY, YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I
WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND THAT I
TAKE THIS VERY, VERY SERIOUS.
BUT IT'S MY RESPONSIBILITY ALSO
TO, TO IF SOMEBODY'S GOING TO
MAKE IF AN AUTHOR IS GOING TO
MAKE A COMMITMENT, WHERE IS THE
PROOF? THE PROOF IS IN WHAT WE
HAVE. UP UNTIL TODAY, A WHOLE
WEEK HAS GONE BY SINCE WE MADE
THE ORIGINAL SUGGESTIONS FOR
AMENDMENTS. IT'S NOT LIKE WE
DIDN'T CARE OR WE IGNORED OR WE
DIDN'T DISCUSS. SO THAT'S MY
EXPLANATION TO YOU, SENATOR
SKINNER, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
YES. IF I MAY. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT, AND I, I'M I'M
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING THE
MOTION, SUPPORTING THE BILL, FOR
ALL THE REASONS THAT I SAID
EARLIER IN THE HEARING, AND I,
AS A COMMITTEE MEMBER, I VERY,
VERY RARELY VOTE AGAINST THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE CHAIR, BUT
SOME SOMETIMES WE ALL DO FROM,
FROM TIME TO TIME. AND I JUST
WANT TO SORT OF ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
ON THIS COMMITTEE, WE HAVE
MULTIPLE STRONG HOUSING LEADERS.
WE HAVE A CHAIR OF OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. WE HAVE
THE CURRENT CHAIR OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE, THE IMMEDIATE PAST
CHAIR OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE,
MULTIPLE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE CARRIED HUGE
WATER IN TERMS OF HOUSING POLICY
FOR MANY, MANY YEARS. AND WE ALL
HAVE, YOU KNOW, SOME VERY WELL
DEVELOPED, VIEWS ON ON THE
DIRECTION OF HOUSING POLICY, THE
I THINK IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO TRY
TO RESOLVE THINGS. AND I'VE
RESOLVED, YOU KNOW, ON A, ON A
HOUSING BILL THAT I HAD WE
DISPUTE I HAD WITH THE CHAIR AND
WE AND WE RESOLVED THAT. BUT
SOMETIMES THE RESOLUTION
DOESN'T, DOESN'T HAPPEN. AND SO
I'LL BE VOTING FOR IT TODAY,
WHICH IS AGAINST NOT SOMETHING I
TYPICALLY DO, BUT I THINK UNDER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES, THAT'S WHERE
I AM WITH THE GREATEST OF
RESPECT TO THE CHAIR AND RESPECT
FOR HER NOT SUPPORTING THE BILL.
MADAM CHAIR, THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING THEM TO SPEAK. I
APPRECIATE THAT, AND I WILL MAKE
A MOTION NOW ON AB 19, 1893. WE
HAVE A MOTION. MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
DURAZZO. I MEAN, NO. DURAZZO.
NO. SATO HI. SATO. I DOLLY.
DOLLY, I GLASER. SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB. WIENER WIENER.
AYE. 4 TO 1. OKAY. THANK YOU.
YEAH. IF YOU WANT TO HAND IT
OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR. OKAY. I
THINK IT WAS HERE. ALL RIGHT,
MR. CARRILLO, ARE YOU READY?
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING, 21, 92 FIRST. I CAN
DO THAT. 2371, HOW ABOUT I START
WITH THAT? 2371? WOULD THAT BE
OKAY? THAT'S PERFECT. THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU, MR. VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS
BILL. AB 2371. I WOULD LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AND THANK
YOUR COMMITTEE TEAM FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL
AND FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
ACCOMMODATION DURING THIS VERY
DIFFICULT WEEK FOR ME AND MY
TEAM. I BELIEVE THE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDE LANGUAGE NEGOTIATED WITH
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE LAST
WEEK, WHICH REMOVED THE
REMAINING OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL, AS WELL AS AMENDMENTS
NEGOTIATED WITH THE COMMITTEE
THAT ADD CHILD CARE FACILITIES,
RECREATION CENTERS AND COMMUNITY
CENTERS TO THE LIST OF SENSITIVE
FACILITIES. SENATORS ELECTRIFIED
SECURITY FENCES HAVE PROVEN TO
PROVIDE AN EFFECTIVE AND SAFE
DETERRENT FOR BUSINESSES SEEKING
TO PROTECT LARGE AND HEAVY
PRODUCTS THAT MUST BE STORED
OUTDOORS. PREVIOUS LEGISLATION,
AS WELL AS INTERNATIONAL
STANDARDS, HAVE ENSURED THAT
THESE FENCES ARE SAFE. IN FACT,
DESPITE THE THOUSANDS OF FENCES
INSTALLED THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY, THERE HAS NEVER BEEN AN
INJURY, MUCH LESS A FATALITY,
CAUSED BY ONE OF THESE FENCES.
THESE FENCES DO, HOWEVER, SERVE
AS A DETERRENT AND AN EFFECTIVE
ALARM SYSTEM, PARTICULARLY FOR
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE EQUIPMENT
OR INVENTORY THAT MUST BE STORED
OUTDOORS. UNDER EXISTING LAW, AN
ELECTRIFIED SECURITY FENCE MAY
ONLY BE INSTALLED AND OPERATED
INSIDE THE EXTERIOR, EXTERIOR
FENCE, OR WALL ON A COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY, A PERSON CAN ONLY COME
INTO CONTACT WITH ELECTRIFIED
SECURITY FENCE IF AND ONLY IF HE
OR SHE COMMITS TRESPASS AND
BREACHES THE FENCE OR WALL. SOME
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE EMBRACED
EXISTING LAW THAT GOVERNS THE
INSTALLATION AND OPERATIONAL
STANDARDS FOR THESE SECURITY
ALARM SYSTEMS, AND WORK QUICKLY
WITH BUSINESSES AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. UNFORTUNATELY, SOME
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE DELAYED
PERMIT APPLICATIONS FOR YEARS
WHEN ISSUING PERMITS TO INSTALL
SUCH SECURITY SYSTEMS.
CURRENTLY, THERE ARE ALMOST 400
BUSINESSES WAITING FOR THEIR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ISSUE
APPROVAL, AND MOST CONCERNING
THESE BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
WAITING ON AVERAGE FOR MORE THAN
ONE YEAR AND STILL DON'T HAVE
APPROVAL YET. HB 2371 ADDRESSES
THIS BY REQUIRING THAT THE LOCAL
PERMITTING PROCESS IS CONSISTENT
WITH THAT OF OTHER SECURITY
ALARM SYSTEMS, AND REINFORCES
EXISTING LAW THAT REQUIRES THESE
SECURITY FENCES ARE INSTALLED
AND LABELED IN SUCH A WAY THAT
IT WILL BE VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR ANYONE TO ACCIDENTALLY COME
IN CONTACT WITH ONE. FOR THE
PAST EIGHT YEARS, AND AT MORE
THAN 1000 PROPERTIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE, INCLUDING PUBLIC
AGENCIES SUCH AS CAL FIRE AND
CITY PUBLIC WORKS DEPARTMENTS,
ELECTRIFIED SECURITY FENCING
BASICALLY A FENCE INSIDE A FENCE
HAVE BEEN SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY
SECURING PROPERTIES AND
EMPLOYEES WITHOUT INCIDENT.
UNDER MY BILL, LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ALSO RETAIN THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT
TO MAKE LOCAL ZONING DECISIONS
THAT DICTATE WHERE THESE TYPES
OF SYSTEMS CAN BE USED. FOR
EXAMPLE, YOU CANNOT PUT AN
ELECTRIFIED SECURITY FENCE ON A
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY. JOINING ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ARE ONLY
AGUSTIN WITH THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
YOLANDA BENSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. THANK YOU FOR
TESTIFYING. TODAY. WE'RE GOING
TO GIVE YOU EACH TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MEMBERS, ANNALEE
AUGUSTINE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, A NONPROFIT
DEDICATED TO HELPING THE 1.4
MILLION FAMILY BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE PROUD TO
CO-SPONSOR THIS BILL. MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS USE THIS TECHNOLOGY
AND CREDIT IT FOR THE ABILITY TO
REMAIN IN BUSINESS,
MANUFACTURING AND INDUSTRIAL.
INDUSTRIAL BUSINESSES NEED TO
PROTECT THEIR LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS SUCH AS VEHICLES,
CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT, TRACTORS
AND OTHER FORMS OF LARGE
INVENTORY. THIS IS OFTEN WHAT
BUSINESSES RELY ON FOR THEIR DAY
TO DAY OPERATIONS, AND THEY
ACTUALLY CAN'T AFFORD TO REPLACE
IT. OFTENTIMES, SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNTS OF THEFT, CRIMINAL
TRESPASS AND PROPERTY DAMAGE
THREATEN THE SAFETY OF EMPLOYEES
AND CUSTOMERS, AND ULTIMATELY,
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE SAFE
JOBS. ELECTRIFIED SECURITY
FENCES HAVE BEEN PROVEN THROUGH
TIME AND APPLICATION TO BE
NEARLY 100% EFFECTIVE AT
DETERRING CRIME, AND THEREFORE
ARE CRITICAL TO COMBAT THE
RISING INCIDENCES OF CRIME THAT
COMMUNITIES FACE. ELECTRIFIED
SECURITY FENCES ARE PROVEN, TO
BE SAFE AND ALSO USED BY VARIOUS
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES, INCLUDING
CAL FIRE PUBLIC WORKS
DEPARTMENTS AND SCHOOL BUS
STORAGE YARDS. AB 2371 SIMPLY
ADDS THE CONSISTENCY TO THE
PROCESS SO ALL ENTITIES CAN USE
THE TECHNOLOGY. THERE'S NO
REASON WHY BUSINESSES SHOULD
HAVE TO WAIT YEARS WHEN THEY'VE
ALREADY IDENTIFIED A THREAT TO
THE SAFETY AND THEIR ABILITY TO
PROTECT THEIR EQUIPMENT AND
EMPLOYEES. FOR THESE REASONS AND
MORE, WE THINK THE AUTHOR AND
OUR PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR THIS
BILL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. THAT
WAS RIGHT AT TWO MINUTES. GOOD
JOB. I'LL BE LESS YOLANDA BENSON,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
AND THE 127 LOCAL HISPANIC
CHAMBERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
SERVING 815 OVER 815,000
HISPANIC OWNED BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. WE BELIEVE THAT 2371
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR CARRYING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL, WE BELIEVE
IT OFFERS A CONSISTENT FRAMEWORK
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES, ESPECIALLY
SMALL BUSINESSES LIKE THE
HISPANIC OWNED BUSINESS WHO HAS
AN IMPORT EXPORT BUSINESS. ONE
OF OUR MEMBERS, THEY
SPECIFICALLY HAVE CARGO
CONTAINERS ON THEIR PROPERTY
BECAUSE THEY'RE AN IMPORT EXPORT
BUSINESS. THEY HAVE HAD BURGLARY
AND THEFT ON INSIDE THEIR CARGO
CONTAINERS. EVEN THOUGH THE
CARGO CONTAINERS WERE LOCKED.
THERE HAS BEEN THEFT. THEY'VE
LOST THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS, WHICH
IS A LOSS TO A BUSINESS. AS A
SMALL BUSINESS THAT CAN'T EASILY
BE MADE UP, THE LOSS OF THESE
THE ELECTRIC FENCE ELECTRIFIED
FENCE, SECURITY FENCE WOULD BE
AN EASY ADDED SECURITY FOR THIS
KIND OF BUSINESS. IT IS THEIR
LIVELIHOOD. THEY NEED TO HAVE
THESE KINDS OF CHOICES IN
PROVIDING SECURITY FOR THEIR
BUSINESSES. WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE,
VOTE ON THIS, VERY COMMON SENSE
BILL. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME, WE'LL
TAKE THE METOOS IN SUPPORT. JUST
YOUR NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION,
YOU REPRESENT, AND YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. MR. CHAIRMAN,
MEMBERS, RANDY PERRY, ON BEHALF
OF PORAC AND CAL FIRE
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. DEAN TALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION. STRONG
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING. SHERRY
MCCUE REPRESENTING THE SELF
STORAGE ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. CATHERINE CHARLES, ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. RYAN,
ELAINE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION, SUPPORT. MATTHEW
HARGROVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. NICK CHAPPIE, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION, IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MICHAEL CAPRIO WITH
REPUBLIC SERVICES AND STRONG
SUPPORT. JACKIE ANIS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FUELS AND
CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
CHRISTOPHER RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANNALEE AUGUSTINE. ALSO HERE ON
BEHALF OF COPART IN SUPPORT.
THANKS ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE AUDIENCE WHO WANT TO BE THE
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESS AND
WHICH YOU'LL GET? TWO MINUTES.
COME ON UP. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY
THAT AFTER THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND SENATE JUDICIARY,
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES,
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES HAS GONE
TO NEUTRAL ON THE BILL WANTED
ONCE THEY'RE PRINTED AND WANTED
TO APPRECIATE AGAIN THE SPONSORS
AND AUTHORS OFFICE FOR THEIR
CONVERSATIONS ON THOSE, AND WE
APPRECIATE THEM BEING OPEN TO
OUR, CONCERNS WITH THE BILL. SO
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY METOOS IN
OPPOSITION? IF NOT, WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DAIS. DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR EMOTION? WE
HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL
BY SENATOR SKINNER. YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU, MR. VICE
CHAIR. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW, WE
UNEXPECTEDLY LOST ALDO GARCIA.
OUR AIDE. THIS HAPPENED LAST
WEEK, HE WAS A RISING STAR IN MY
OFFICE AND A BELOVED MEMBER OF
THE CAPITAL COMMUNITY. WE WENT
TO HIS FUNERAL SERVICES LAST
NIGHT AND I STILL CANNOT BELIEVE
THAT HE'S GONE. IT'S BEEN REALLY
HARD FOR OUR OFFICE TO DEAL WITH
THIS EVENT FROM LAST WEEK. I SAY
THAT BECAUSE THIS BILL IS ONE
THAT HE WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR IN
MY OFFICE, AND I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO REMEMBER HIM
AND ACKNOWLEDGE ALL OF HIS HARD
WORK, AND NOT ONLY IN THIS BILL,
BUT IN OTHER BILLS, AS WELL. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. WELL, FROM OUR
COMMITTEE, WE EXTEND OUR SINCERE
CONDOLENCES ON THAT. THAT IS A
TOUGH LOSS, AND WE ALL FEEL THAT.
SO WITH THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE ROLL MOTION IS TO PASS THIS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
SENATORS DURAZZO SATO. AYE. SATO
AYE. DALI GLAZER. SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE. WAHAB. WIENER.
WIENER. AYE THREE ZERO. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL KEEP THAT BILL OPEN
ON CALL, NEXT UP, WE HAVE AB
2443 BY MR. CARILLO. AGAIN. GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU, MR. VICE
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS
BILL TODAY. THIS IS A VERY
SIMPLE BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW
THREE CITIES IN MY DISTRICT, THE
CITIES OF VICTORVILLE, PALMDALE
AND LANCASTER. THE REST
CRITICALLY NEEDED RESOURCES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL, SENATORS, MY
DISTRICT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT 39 IS
A BRAND NEW DISTRICT THAT
STRADDLES THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY LINES.
ONE OF THE PRIMARY THINGS THAT
COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT HAVE
IN COMMON IS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
LEFT BEHIND. WHEN PEOPLE THINK
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY, THEY ARE
NOT THINKING ABOUT PALMDALE AND
LANCASTER. AND WHEN PEOPLE THINK
OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY, THEY
ARE NOT THINKING ABOUT THE
CITIES OF ADELANTO AND
VICTORVILLE. AND I'LL GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE. MEASURE H IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY, WHICH FUNDS
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTY, ONLY RETURNS ABOUT
$0.15 TO THE DOLLAR THAT IS
COLLECTED IN THE CITY OF
PALMDALE. FOR THIS MEASURE, MY
COMMUNITIES IN THE HIGH DESERT
ARE CONSISTENTLY FORGOTTEN ABOUT
AND LEFT LEFT OUT OF CRITICAL
RESOURCES AT BOTH THE STATE AND
THE COUNTY LEVEL. THIS MEASURE
SIMPLY ALLOWS THEM TO DO IT
THEMSELVES, TO RAISE FUNDS
LOCALLY, TO MEET THE LOCAL NEEDS
OF THESE CITIES, HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS JASON GONSALVES,
ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
PALMDALE AND VICTORVILLE. THANK
YOU, MR. GONSALVES. YOU GOT TWO
MINUTES, PLEASE. THANK YOU,
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS, AND THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO JASON GONSALVES,
ON BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
VICTORVILLE AND PALMDALE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AS NOTED BY THE
AUTHOR, THIS BILL SIMPLY ALLOWS
THE MAYOR AND COUNCIL TO CHOOSE
TO PUT SOMETHING BEFORE THEIR
VOTERS, THEIR CONSTITUENTS. WE
USED TO CALL IT SELF-HELP. AND
AS THESE COMMUNITIES GROW, THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AND THE
DEMANDS GROW, AND WITH THAT, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THIS
FLEXIBILITY THROUGH JANUARY
2029. AS NOTED IN THE BILL, AND
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
OKAY, THIS IS SUPPORT. OKAY. ANY
MORE SUPPORT? THIS IS 2371. NO,
2443 OKAY OKAY. SEEING NO MORE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, WE MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB 2443 OKAY.
SEEING NONE COME TO THE DAIS,
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? NØ
SEEING NONE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO I
SEND A REQUEST AND I VOTE FOR
MÁS. OKAY OKAY. SENATOR WIENER
MOVES THE BILL. WE'LL DO A ROLL
CALL. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. SENATORS DURAZZO I
DURAZZO I CIERTO CIERTO. NO.
DOLLY GLAZIER. SKINNER WAHAB
WIENER. WIENER. AYE. 2 TO 1
OKAY. THANK YOU. LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR MORE VOTES. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU. OKAY, WE MOVE
ON TO I THINK I NEED, I NEED THE
OTHER LIST.
THANK YOU FOR HANGING IN THERE.
ROLL. YEAH OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO.
IF WE CAN HAVE A MOTION Þ MOTION
ON FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR. YES
LET HIM KNOW WE'RE DONE. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE MOTION IS
MOVED BY SENATOR WIENER. WE'LL
NOW DO A ROLL CALL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MOTION TO
ADOPT THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I, DURAZZO I.
SATO GALI BLAKESPEAR. SKINNER.
WAHAB WIENER. WIENER. AYE 2 TO
0. AND WE'RE GOING TO HOLD IT
OPEN. YES. OKAY. AND WE DID. LET
ME SEE THEIR CONSENT THERE. WE
JUST DID 2443. THEY ALREADY DID
THAT ONE. OKAY OKAY. AND MOTION
ON THE FIRST TWO OKAY. WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK. WE'RE GOING
BACK TO VOTE ON TWO BILLS. IF WE
CAN HAVE A MOTION SB 739. MOVED
BY SENATOR WIENER, WE HAVE.
ASHBY SB 739. SENATOR ASHBY,
WE'LL HAVE THE ROLL CALL MOTION
IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
BE CONCURRED IN SENATORS DURAZZO
I DURAZZO I SATO DOLLY GLACIER.
SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER WIENER I 2
TO 0 OKAY. AND WE NEED A MOTION.
I'M SORRY. I LEAVE IT OPEN.
OKAY. WE NEED A MOTION ON SCR
163. I'M NOT SUPPORTING IT, BUT
I'LL MAKE A LIMON. OKAY. THANK
YOU. WE'LL HAVE A ROLL CALL.
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND ORDERED
TO THIRD READING. SENATORS
DURAZZO I DURAZZO I SATO. DOLLY.
GLAZIER SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER 1
TO 0. OKAY NOW WE MOVE ON TO
LOWENTHAL AB 2235 OH, HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. OH, HERE WE GO.
YAY! LUCKY YOU. OKAY, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE AHEAD, THEN TO, AB
2735. WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB 2735.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
FOR GETTING THIS BILL INTO A
BETTER PLACE. THIS BILL ARISES
OUT OF A CLEAR NEED TO PROTECT
BOTH CONSUMERS AND INSURANCE OF
THE INSURANCE MARKET FROM
UNCERTAINTY POSED BY THE CURRENT
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE
MARKET. SOURCES ESTIMATE THAT IS
20, THAT THERE IS 20% LESS
AVAILABILITY FOR INSURANCE
OPTIONS THAT THERE WERE JUST A
YEAR AGO. AB 2735 LOOKS TO
PROVIDE STABILITY FOR THE
EXISTING MARKET BY ESTABLISHING
AN ALTERNATIVE INSURANCE OPTION
FOR OUR STATE'S WATER PROVIDERS
IN 2015, THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
AB 656, AUTHORED BY THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA,
TO ALLOW FOR INSURANCE RISK
POOLING FOR MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES. IN ADDITION TO
PROVISIONS OF, TO THE PROVISIONS
OF AB 656. THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
A WATER CORPORATION AND A PUBLIC
AGENCY TO ENTER INTO A JOINT
POWERS AGREEMENT FOR THE
PROVISION OF INSURANCE AND RISK
POOLING. THE CALIFORNIA FAIR
PLAN HAS PROVIDED A BACKSTOP FOR
ENTITIES SEEKING COVERAGE WHEN
THEY OTHERWISE HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO. HOWEVER, IT HAS BECOME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT THIS THAT
THIS EXISTING SYSTEM IS IN
JEOPARDY. THIS IS BEING FELT BY
WATER PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE. INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM HAVE BOTH NOTED THEIR
PREFERENCE TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF ENTITIES WHO UTILIZE THE FAIR
PLAN AS A SIGNIFICANT LOSS WOULD
CAUSE REVERBERATIONS FOR THE
MARKET AS A WHOLE. AB 2735
PROVIDES A UNIQUE, EXPLICITLY
PERMISSIVE SOLUTION TO THIS
COMPLEX PROBLEM FOR OUR WATER
PROVIDERS. JPAS CAN SET LOWER
PREMIUMS AND OFFER BROADER
COVERAGE THAN OTHERWISE
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE PRIVATE
MARKETPLACE. DUE TO THE FACT
THAT THEY FALL UNDER UNIQUE
REGULATORY AND TAXATION
PARAMETERS BY ALLOWING WATER
PROVIDERS THAT FALL OUTSIDE OF
THE SCOPE OF AB 656 TO
PARTICIPATE IN POOLED INSURANCE.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP STABILIZE
WATER RATES WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
STABILIZING THE UTILIZATION OF
THE FAIR PLAN, AS THIS IS A
PROVEN MODEL FOR OTHER
UTILITIES, AB 2735 IS A COMMON
SENSE NOVEL SOLUTION FOR WATER
PROVIDERS ACROSS THE STATE. HERE
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY AS
JENNIFER CAPITULO, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION, THE SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE, AND PAUL FULLER,
INSURANCE ADMINISTRATOR FOR CAL
MUTUALS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD MORNING,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
PAUL FULLER. I AM A LICENSED
INSURANCE BROKER AND WATER
OPERATOR IN CALIFORNIA. I
REPRESENT APPROXIMATELY 4000
PUBLIC WATER DISTRICTS, MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES, AND INVESTOR
OWNED WATER UTILITIES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY, INCLUDING 900 IN
CALIFORNIA. LIKE MANY
POLICYHOLDERS IN CALIFORNIA,
WERE EXPERIENCING OUR WATER
CLIENTS ARE EXPERIENCING RATE
SHOCK IN THE COMMERCIAL
MARKETPLACE. IT'S NOT UNUSUAL
FOR A WATER CLIENTS TO SEE RATES
EXCEEDING 100% FROM EXPIRING
LEVELS, AND THAT IS ON TOP OF
RATE INCREASES FROM PRIOR YEARS
AND ON TOP OF HIGHER
DEDUCTIBLES, LESS COVERAGE AND
LOWER LIMITS. NOW, FORTUNATELY,
OUR PUBLIC WATER DISTRICT AND
MUTUAL WATER COMPANY CLIENTS
HAVE AN OPTION, AND THAT IS AN
INSURANCE POOL OR JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY. I'M NOT HERE TO
SUGGEST THAT INSURANCE POOLS ARE
A PANACEA TO THE INSURANCE
CRISIS, BUT I CAN CONFIRM THAT
INSURANCE POOLS PROVIDE MORE
AFFORDABILITY, MORE STABILITY,
AND MORE VALUE COMPARED TO
TODAY'S COMMERCIAL MARKETPLACE.
THERE'S THREE REASONS FOR THAT.
NUMBER ONE IS STRUCTURE
INSURANCE POOLS UTILIZE
REINSURANCE, WHICH IS A MORE
EFFICIENT WAY OF BUYING
INSURANCE. SECOND WOULD BE THE
ABILITY FOR, FOR EASE OF
BUSINESS FOR, INSURANCE POOLS TO
ULTIMATELY PROVIDE MORE RISK
MANAGEMENT SERVICES WITHOUT
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT AND
CONTROL. AND THEN FINALLY, IT
WOULD BE THE VALUE AND THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT THEY HAVE ON
THEIR MEMBERS. THEY CAN MANDATE
A HEIGHTENED LEVEL OF SAFETY
PERFORMANCE. AND FOR THESE
REASONS, INSURANCE POOLS, AT
LEAST COMPARED TO TODAY'S
INSURANCE MARKETPLACE, CREATES A
BETTER VALUE, MORE AFFORDABILITY
AND MORE STABILITY FOR PUBLIC
WATER DISTRICTS. FOR MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES. AND WE'RE
ASKING FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION TO
ALLOW INVESTOR OWNED WATER
UTILITIES THAT SAME PRIVILEGE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE WANTS. OH, I'M SORRY, I
JUMPED RIGHT OVER YOU. GO AHEAD.
NO PROBLEM. JENNIFER CAPETILLO,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION,
WHERE THE STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
CO-SPONSORING THE BILL WITH
COUNCILS, WE HAVE ABOUT 90
MEMBER COMPANIES HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND OUR
WATER UTILITIES ARE REGULATED BY
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. THIS BILL FOR US IS
100% ABOUT WATER AFFORDABILITY.
WE'RE SEEING WATER RATES
STEADILY INCREASE AND WE ARE
LOOKING EVERYWHERE POSSIBLE TO
TRY TO STABILIZE WATER RATES FOR
OUR CUSTOMERS. WE'RE LOOKING AT
EVERY LINE ITEM IN OUR WATER
UTILITIES BUDGET AND SEEING IF
THERE'S ANYWHERE THAT WE CAN
LOOK FOR ADJUSTMENTS, AND WE
FEEL LIKE THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO REDUCE THOSE COSTS
RELATED TO INSURANCE AND
DIRECTLY THEN PASS THOSE SAVINGS
ON TO OUR CUSTOMERS. THIS BILL
IDEA CAME FROM A SMALL COMPANY
THAT'S ACTUALLY IN SENATOR
DALY'S DISTRICT. EVEN THOUGH HE
POPPED OUT, AND IT'S CALLED
LUKENS BROTHERS WATER COMPANY,
3000 SERVICE CONNECTIONS IN THE
TAHOE AREA. I THINK HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE MILLIONAIRES
AND THE MILLIONAIRES. WELL, THIS
IS THIS LITTLE TINY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY THAT IS
THE FOLKS THAT WORK IN THE
HOTELS AND THE CASINOS AND IN
TAHOE. AND IN 2020, THEIR
PROPERTY INSURANCE RATES WERE
$43,000 A YEAR. HERE WE ARE NOW
IN 2024, THEIR INSURANCE COSTS
ARE $279,000 A YEAR. SO 43,000
TO $279,000 IN THREE YEARS.
THAT'S HOW MUCH IT'S INCREASED.
AND THAT'S, OF COURSE, BECAUSE
OF THE CALDOR FIRE, THE RISK
THERE. THEY WEREN'T IMPACTED BY
THE CALDOR FIRE. THEY'VE NEVER
HAD A CLAIM ON THEIR INSURANCE
EVER, IN THEIR HISTORY OF A
WATER UTILITY. BUT JUST THAT
EVER CHANGING PRESSURE ON THE
PRIVATE INSURANCE MARKET, THAT
HUGE INCREASE EXPERIENCED THERE
FOR THOSE CUSTOMERS. SO 21% RATE
INCREASE FOR THEM RESULTED IN
ABOUT A $23 A MONTH ADDITION
ONTO THEIR UTILITY WATER BILL.
AND THAT'S JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE,
RIGHT? I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
LIKE THAT IS RATE SHOCK WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT IT. SO WE MET WITH
CAL MUTUALS, WE CAME UP WITH
THIS IDEA. WE'RE HERE, YOU KNOW,
HOPING THAT THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD TODAY AND WE CAN HELP,
SAVINGS FOR OUR WATER UTILITY
CUSTOMERS. THANK YOU. PERFECT.
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU. OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2735. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS. STEVE
BAKER WITH AARON READING
ASSOCIATES FOR THE UPPER SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SARAH BRENNAN WITH THE WIDMANN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
WATER SERVICE AND SUPPORT ALISON
RAIMI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
WORKERS, STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS, AND STATE
PIPE TRADES IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
KENDRA DE JOGO WITH THE WALKER
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE SAN JOSE
WATER COMPANY. THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR EFFORTS. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? OKAY. SEEING
NONE, ANYONE IN OPPOSITION,
PLEASE COME FORWARD. FAITH
BORGESS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES, WE'D LOVE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR WORK ON THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS WITH, LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW
THEM ONCE THEY'RE IN PRINT. BUT
WE DO EXPECT TO GO NEUTRAL WITH
THAT. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MATT BROD HERE ON BEHALF OF AQUA
JPA. AND THEN ALSO BEEN
DEPUTIZED BY AFSCME, TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION, WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, WHICH WE THINK
STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN, YOU
KNOW, ADDRESSING RATE
AFFORDABILITY, BUT ALSO
PROTECTING THE JPA MODEL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? OKAY. SEEING NONE, I
COME TO THE DAIS. ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM OUR. I HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AGAIN? WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE, FOR THEIR
HARD WORK TO GET US TO THIS
POINT. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MOTION IS MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS DURAZZO
I DURAZZO I. SATO. DOLLY.
GLAZIER. SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER.
WIENER. AYE. 2 TO 0. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. OKAY. WHO
DO WE HAVE HERE? ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. I GUESS WE'RE STUCK WITH
YOU. WE HAVE A BUNCH OF OTHERS,
BUT I'LL LET YOU GO UP. WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL, ARE
YOU HERE TO PRESENT AB 2235?
RIGHT? THAT'S CORRECT, MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS, I WILL BE
BRIEF, I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE CHAIR AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
UNDERSTANDING. TRULY. THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL AND
WHERE IT'S AT, THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH IS EMBARKING ON AN
AMBITIOUS PLAN TO BUILD THE
LARGEST OFF WIND TURBINE
FACILITY AT ANY US PORT. THE
FACILITY WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
MEET ITS GOAL OF PRODUCING 25GW
OF OFFSHORE WIND POWER BY 2045,
AND HELP LOWER THE NATIONAL COST
OF OFFSHORE WIND POWER BY 70% BY
2035. OFFSHORE WIND WILL PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S
RENEWABLE ENERGY PORTFOLIO,
HELPING CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE ITS
SB 100 GOALS WHILE DELIVERING
THE RENEWABLE ENERGY TO SUPPORT
DECARBONIZATION ACROSS MULTIPLE
SECTORS, INCLUDING THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH'S TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSIONS. AB 2235 PROVIDES FOR
AN EXPRESS ABILITY FOR THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH TO PROCURE
CONTRACTS SPECIFICALLY RELATING
TO THE PIER, WIND PROJECT, AND
DESCRIBES THE PROJECT DELIVERY
METHODS BY WHICH THOSE CONTRACTS
CAN BE PROCURED. AB 2235 ALSO
PROVIDES SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS
FOR BUSINESS ENTITIES ENTERING
INTO CONTRACTS FOR PIER WIND
PROJECT RELATING TO BONDING A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE,
AND INSURANCE, MADAM CHAIR, I
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE WORKING
ON LANGUAGE AT THIS TIME BETWEEN
THE ILWU AND THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES, REGARDING JURISDICTIONAL
ELEMENTS, AND WILL NOT MOVE THE
BILL. YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO
NOT MOVE THE BILL OFF THE SENATE
FLOOR WITHOUT SUCH AN AGREEMENT.
GOOD NEWS, GOOD NEWS. OKAY. YES.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR? YES. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
DAN CHA, REPRESENTING THE PORT
OF LONG BEACH. THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL, RELATIVELY
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL TO GIVE THE
PORT THE CONTRACTING FLEXIBILITY
TO BUILD THE LARGEST FACILITY TO
SUPPORT THE WIND OFFSHORE WIND
INDUSTRY. AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DESCRIBED, ONCE ASSEMBLED, THESE
THESE TURBINES WILL BE TOWED OUT
TO SEA FROM THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH TO WIN LEASE AREAS IN THE
CENTRAL AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THAT WILL GENERATE CLEAN,
RELIABLE POWER FOR THE GRID. IN
ADDITION TO PUTTING THE STATE
AND THE US AT THE FOREFRONT OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY, PIER WIND WILL
HELP THE STATE MEET ITS CLIMATE
GOALS WHILE CREATING GOOD PAYING
UNION JOBS AND CREATING ECONOMIC
AND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES, AND JUST TO
BE CLEAR, THESE THESE TURBINES
ARE SO LARGE THAT THERE'S NO
OTHER WAY TO ACTUALLY ASSEMBLE
THEM. BUT BUT AT A PIER, RIGHT.
RIGHT NEAR THE COASTAL AREAS.
SO, BUT BUT ALSO, TO BE CLEAR,
THIS BILL ONLY PERTAINS TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE PIER ITSELF.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT,
BUILDING THE ACTUAL TURBINES
WITH WITH RESPECT TO THIS LARGER
DEVELOPMENT. CURRENTLY, THE PORT
IS REQUIRED TO UTILIZE A DESIGN
BUILD PROJECT DELIVERY METHOD
FOR ITS PUBLIC WORKS
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. BUT
BECAUSE OF THE PROJECT'S
COMPLEXITY AND AGGRESSIVE
DELIVERY SCHEDULE, WE NEED THIS
FLEXIBILITY AS PROVIDED FOR IN
THIS BILL, TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE AS WELL TO DEVELOP THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO ENABLE
OFFSHORE WIND AND TACKLE THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. WITHOUT THIS
LEGISLATION, OUR PROJECT WOULD
BE DELAYED AT LEAST A YEAR WITH
COSTS FOR A PROJECT THAT THAT IS
ALREADY APPROACHING $5 BILLION.
BUT THE DELAY WOULD INCREASE THE
PROJECT BY ANOTHER $250 MILLION.
SO THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION,
AND WE URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, NO MORE WITNESSES. OKAY. DO
WE HAVE ANYONE, IN SUPPORT OF AB
2235 CHAIR CHAIR DURAZZO AND
MEMBERS MARVIN PINEDA ON BEHALF
OF THE INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE
AND WAREHOUSE UNION, WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE, WANT TO
THANK SENATE MEMBER LOWENTHAL
AND HIS STAFF FOR ALL HIS HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL, WE KNOW WE
COULD GET TO AN AGREEMENT, AND
WE WILL. WE'LL WORK HARD WITH
THAT. SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO. SYLVIA SOLIS SHORE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, JEREMY SMITH
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL, I GUESS TECHNICALLY
WE'RE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN
PRINT. AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAS, ALLUDED TO. WE HAVE BEEN IN
LENGTHY CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ILWU TO TRY AND FIGURE OUT SOME
LANGUAGE, IN THIS BILL SO THAT
IT CAN CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD,
I GUESS SO. TECHNICALLY WE ARE
OPPOSED. WE ARE OPPOSED IN THE
ASSEMBLY, BUT, WE ARE HEARTENED
BY THOSE CONVERSATIONS LED BY
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND HIS HARD
WORKING STAFF, AND WE THINK
WE'RE GOING TO GET SOMEWHERE IN
THE NEXT FOUR WEEKS. BUT WE ARE
TECHNICALLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
IN PRINT. AND JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WAS CLEAR TO THE
COMMITTEE. SO WE SUPPORT THE
BILL MOVING FORWARD TODAY WITH
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S, PROMISE
THAT IT WILL GO NO FURTHER UNTIL
WE CAN COME TO AN AGREEMENT. SO
THANK YOU. OKAY. I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT. IT'S NOT EXACTLY THE
SAME THING CAME OUT HERE, BUT I.
I KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING, AND,
JUST, YOU KNOW, URGE THAT,
MOVING FORWARD, THAT ALL THE
PARTIES, REALLY, THERE'S TOO
MUCH AT STAKE HERE. IT'S GOING
TO BE AN EXTRAORDINARY PROJECT
FROM WHAT I COULD TELL, JUST ONE
QUESTION. YOU MENTIONED THAT IF
I PLEASE, THE TURBINES YOU
MENTIONED, THIS IS ABOUT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE PIER. THAT'S
RIGHT. HAVE YOU GOTTEN ANYWHERE
NEAR THE CONVERSATION OF OR DOES
IT NOT MATTER TO YOU NOW ABOUT
THESE TURBINES AND WHERE THEY
WOULD BE MANUFACTURED? I ASKED
BECAUSE I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
GOING WITH A GROUP TO DENMARK,
AND WE ACTUALLY TOOK A BOAT OUT
INTO THE OCEAN AND SAW THESE
MASSIVE, MASSIVE TURBINES. IT
WAS PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY. SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT. BUT IS
THAT A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION, NOT SLIGHTLY, BUT
THE STATE THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THE
MANUFACTURING IN STATE, THE
ENERGY COMMISSION HAS PUBLISHED
A REPORT ABOUT MEETING THE
STATE'S OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY
GOALS AND IT INCLUDES
CONSIDERATION OF A MULTI PORT
STRATEGY, NOT ONLY FOR THE
STAGING AND INTEGRATION, PUTTING
THESE MASSIVE TURBINES TOGETHER,
BUT ALSO MANUFACTURING THESE.
AND THERE ARE OTHER PORTS THAT
CAN PROVIDE THAT HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO PROVIDE THAT
MANUFACTURING. CAPABILITY. SO WE
ABSOLUTELY WANT TO SEE THOSE
TURBINES MANUFACTURED HERE AS
WELL. I'M SURE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD SUPPORT THAT, BUT
IT IS PART OF A LARGER MULTI
PORT STRATEGY THAT, YOU KNOW, IS
SEVERAL STEPS AHEAD OF US, BUT
WE HOPE TO GET THERE,
EVENTUALLY. MADAM CHAIR, IF I
COULD ON ON THAT NOTE, IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT THE
MANUFACTURING TAKES PLACE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
ENCOURAGE, MY VERY GOOD FRIENDS
AT THE ILWU AND THE TRADES TO BE
COGNIZANT OF THE TIMELINE THAT
WE'RE OPERATING UNDER AS IT
RELATES TO, MEETING THE STATE'S
GOALS, WHICH IS ON A DISTINCT
TIMELINE. AND THE ABILITY TO
HAVE MANUFACTURING TAKE PLACE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS ALSO
INDIRECTLY TIED TO AN AGREEMENT.
SO, IF IT IF I MAY JUST FINISH
UP HERE, DON'T FINISH UP YET. WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS? NO, NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY.
NOW, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. YOU
KNOW, OBVIOUSLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS IN A IN A
TREMENDOUS STATE OF TRANSITION,
RIGHT NOW. AND WE SEE THAT WITH
OUR WORKFORCE. BUT NOWHERE IS IT
MORE EVIDENCED THAN THE 69TH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. AND I HAVE
INTENSE ADMIRATION FOR MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN THE
TRADES AND THE ILWU, WHO IN THE
69TH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ARE GOING
THROUGH TREMENDOUS
TRANSFORMATION ON THE ILWU SIDE,
WE SEE THE THREAT OF AUTOMATION
HAVING NOT JUST AN IMPACT ON
THEIR JOBS, BUT ON THE TOTAL
ECONOMY OF THE 69TH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT AND ALSO AT 69TH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT HAS BEEN AN
OIL DISTRICT. THERE ARE TWO
REFINERIES IN THE DISTRICT.
THERE IS DRILLING EVERYWHERE IN
THE DISTRICT, WHICH EMPLOYS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MEN AND
WOMEN IN THE TRADES. THOSE ARE
GOOD JOBS, GOOD UNION PAYING
JOBS AND AS WE ALL MOVE TOWARDS
THIS TRANSITION, THERE IS AN AIR
OF UNCERTAINTY ON BOTH PARTS. SO
I APPLAUD THEM BOTH FOR, YOU
KNOW, BEING SO VIGOROUS IN THIS
BILL AND BEYOND IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE CARVING OUT AND
SECURING UNION JOBS IN THESE
AREAS. AND SO I'M VERY
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE ARE GOING TO
GET SOMETHING DONE AS IT RELATES
TO THIS. THIS IS SOLELY A
CONSTRUCTION BILL, BUT
OBVIOUSLY, AS IT RELATES TO
FEDERAL MONEY, AS IT RELATES TO
MANUFACTURING, THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE INDIRECTLY
IMPLICATED IN THIS AND SO VERY
OPTIMISTIC THAT ALL PARTIES WILL
GET TOGETHER AND FIND A FIND THE
KUMBAYA. OKAY. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, WE NEED A MOTION.
MOTION'S BEEN MADE BY SENATOR
WIENER. ROLL CALL. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS DURAZZO
I DURAZZO I SATO. DOLLY.
GLAZIER. SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER.
WIENER. AYE. 2 TO 0. KEEP THE
RULES OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. OKAY I KNOW Ó NØ
GARCIA. LET'S FIRST GO SEE HIS
FIRST. YES ALL RIGHT, WHICH ONE
OF THE TWO? BOTH OF THEM. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA, I THINK YOU'RE UP AND
YOU'LL BE TAKING UP AB 2922.
YES, MADAM CHAIR, THANK YOU. SO
MUCH. AND I'LL BEGIN BY THANKING
YOU. THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS,
THE ANALYSIS THAT WAS WRITTEN.
AND WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. AND I WILL SHARE
WITH YOU THAT, I APPRECIATE THE
TIME THAT YOU GAVE, OUR TEAM,
OUR SPONSORS, STAKEHOLDERS WHO,
ARE EMBEDDED, DEEPLY IN THE
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY VALUABLE IN OUR PART
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WE
DEVELOP WHAT IS BEEN KNOWN AS
CALIFORNIA'S LITHIUM ECONOMY IN
IMPERIAL COUNTY, AS THE
SUPERVISOR OUT THERE WOULD SAY,
LITHIUM VALLEY IS IMPERIAL
VALLEY, SO THANK YOU AGAIN. THIS
BILL EXTENDS THE AUTHORIZATION
FOR CAPITAL INVESTMENT INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS, IT'S KNOWN AS THE,
CHIP PROGRAM. CIP PROGRAM UNTIL
JANUARY 1ST, 2035. THIS PROGRAM
AUTHORIZES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ATTRACT LARGE MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES BY OFFERING CAPITAL
INVESTMENT INCENTIVES FOR
QUALIFIED MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES, SUCH AS CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION, ALTERNATIVE FUEL
VEHICLES, AND MANUFACTURING OF
EVS. ALL OF WHICH ARE CRUCIAL
FOR ACHIEVING A CLEANER ENERGY
FUTURE IN CALIFORNIA, THIS
PROGRAM, AS I ALREADY MENTIONED,
HAS HAD TREMENDOUS BENEFITS IN
OUR REGION. AND, BY EXTENDING
THIS PROGRAM AND SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEFORE US.
AND ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SOME
QUESTIONS THAT REMAIN TO BE
DISCUSSED, WITH STAKEHOLDERS,
WITH, OFFICES WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION, WE THINK THAT
MOVING FORWARD, WE'LL BE ABLE
TO, PUT TOGETHER A PROGRAM THAT
WILL BE APPLICABLE ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT WILL
MEET ALL OF THE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES OF HIGH STANDARDS
WHEN IT COMES TO LABOR, HIGH
STANDARDS WHEN IT COMES TO
BENEFITS AND HIGH STANDARDS,
WHEN IT COMES TO THE TYPES OF
JOBS THAT WE WANT TO ATTRACT TO
CALIFORNIA AS IT PERTAINS TO
MEETING OUR CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
AND OUR CLIMATE GOALS. BIG
CONVERSATIONS THIS WEEK AND
LATER TODAY IN BOTH HOUSES AS IT
PERTAINS TO, CLIMATE AND, THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS INTERSECT
QUITE COMPLIMENTARY. SO WITH
THAT, WE HAVE, OUR, PRINCIPAL
SUPPORTERS THAT HAVE BEEN
DRIVING, THE CONVERSATION ON OUR
BEHALF. IT'S REBECCA TERRAZAS,
ASSISTANT COUNTY EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE COUNTY OF
IMPERIAL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, ONCE AGAIN, MY NAME
IS REBECCA BAXTER. I AM THE
ASSISTANT CEO FOR THE COUNTY OF
IMPERIAL. AND ON BEHALF OF THE
IMPERIAL COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, WE ARE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AB 2922. IT'S A BILL
THAT WOULD REINSTATE THE CIP
PROGRAM SO THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LIKE OURS, HAVE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ATTRACT LARGE
MANUFACTURING FACILITIES TO
INVEST IN OUR COMMUNITIES. NOW,
ALTHOUGH THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
EXTENDED AND EXPANDED SINCE ITS
ENACTMENT, THIS PROGRAM WAS
UNFORTUNATELY ALLOWED TO EXPIRE
IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR. AB 2922
WILL BRING THIS VITAL ECONOMIC
TOOL BACK ONLINE, AND
REAUTHORIZATION OF THE PROGRAM
WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
TOOL AS THE COUNTY OF IMPERIAL
CONTINUES TO IMPLEMENT THE
LITHIUM VALLEY ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY INVESTMENT PLAN, AS
A MATTER OF FACT, WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH CTR
WHO ACTUALLY HAS A PLA WITH
LABOR, WITH THE BUILDING AND
TRADES CONSTRUCTION COUNCIL, TO
ENTER INTO THE CIP PROGRAM.
HOWEVER, THIS PROGRAM LAPSED
DURING THOSE NEGOTIATIONS. AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
TRY TO REAUTHORIZE THE PROGRAM.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION, AS MUCH AS
ONE THIRD OF THE WORLD'S CURRENT
LITHIUM DEPOSITS ARE IN
CALIFORNIA, IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
IMPERIAL COUNTY MAY HOLD AS MUCH
AS 18 MILLION METRIC TONS,
ENOUGH TO SUPPORT OVER 375
LITHIUM EV BATTERIES, BUT
LITHIUM IS FOUND IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE UNITED STATES AND AROUND
THE WORLD, AND SUCCESS AS THE
INDUSTRY OF THE INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA IS NOT YET ASSURED.
SO DUE TO THE NATURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S LITHIUM DEPOSITS,
EXTRACTION HERE WILL BE THE
CLEANEST, THE MOST HEALTH
FRIENDLY AND LEAST CARBON
INTENSIVE IN THE WORLD. BUT IT
WILL ALSO REQUIRE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE UPFRONT CAPITAL THAN OPEN
PIT MINES OR EVAPORATION PONDS
FOUND IN UTAH, NORTH CAROLINA,
AUSTRALIA AND CHILE. FOR A
RURAL, UNDERSERVED COUNTY THAT
HAS PERPETUALLY SUFFERED FROM
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT AND HIGH
POVERTY RATES, AMONG THE HIGHEST
IN THE STATE, THIS IS A
TRANSFORMATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
THAT'S BEFORE US AS AN EMERGING
AND GROWING INDUSTRY. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT CALIFORNIA DOES
EVERYTHING IT CAN TO MAKE OUR
STATE COMPETITIVE. TO THE
COMPANIES LOOKING TO ENTER THE
LITHIUM EXTRACTION AND
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY.
THEREFORE, FOR THESE REASONS, WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AB 2922.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB
2922 LAWRENCE GORDON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTING AS A MANUFACTURING
MAKER. BILL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA, ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND THE COUNTY OF
RIVERSIDE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
ALEJANDRO SOLIS, ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN POWER CAMPAIGN, COMITÉ
CIVICO EL VALLE AND LOS AMIGOS
DE LA COMUNIDAD IN ON SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MARVIN
PINEDA, ON BEHALF OF LA
COOPERATIVA CAMPESINA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
MEMBERS BRADY GARDNER, ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT. LOOK FORWARD
TO LOOKING AT THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. I'M ERIC LAUER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT, AND ALSO LOOKING
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
NOPE. SEEING NONE. GREAT. WE'VE
COME TO THE DÍAS. ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS? SENATORS MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER, ANY COMMENTS?
QUESTIONS? NONE. I WANT TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BOTH THE COUNTY
AS WELL AS THE AUTHOR, IT'S A
REALLY WONDERFUL EXAMPLE OF
PROMISES THAT ARE ALWAYS MADE TO
POOR COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR THAT, YES, WE'LL GET TO
YOU. YES, YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES TO THRIVE
IN THIS ECONOMY. AND ALL THAT'S
DONE IS THE ASSETS ARE SUCKED
OUT AND PEOPLE ARE LEFT POOR. IN
FACT, SOMETIMES EVEN MORE POOR
THAN WHEN THEY WERE PROMISED,
MADE THE PROMISES. SO THIS IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF WHAT CAN BE
DONE FOR A COMMUNITY THAT HAS
THE HISTORY OF IMPERIAL COUNTY,
AND I THINK YOUR LEADERSHIP
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS A TESTAMENT
TO WE CAN HAVE BOTH ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY AND A GREAT ECONOMY,
AND THE PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THOSE
INDUSTRIES CAN BE TREATED FAIRLY
WITH GOOD JOBS. SO I ADMIRE ALL
THAT YOU'VE DONE STANDING UP FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES. AT THE
SAME TIME THAT WORKING PEOPLE
HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD THE BASICS, AND MORE THAN
JUST THE BASICS IN THEIR LIVES.
SO I'M GLAD TO BE SUPPORTING YOU
IN THIS. SO IF YOU WANT TO WRAP
UP, THANK YOU. AND, AS I
MENTIONED IN OUR OPENING, WE'LL
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATIONS. WE
KNOW THAT THESE PROGRAMS DON'T
ALWAYS, THERE ISN'T A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL. AND I THINK THAT'S A
CONVERSATION THAT WE CONSTANTLY
HEAR HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO GET THIS
RIGHT, NOT JUST FOR IMPERIAL
COUNTY, BUT FOR THE REST OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S
PART OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WILL CONTINUE MOVING FORWARD
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION, WITH
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEES TO FOLLOW. SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
WORKING WITH US ALL THE WAY UP
UNTIL THE LAST DAY OF THE LAST
HOUR. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER. MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS DURAZZO, I, DURAZZO I.
SATO, DOLLY. GLACIER SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB. WIENER. WIENER
I30. WE'LL HOLD IT OPEN FOR MORE
VOTES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA AB 3198.
YES. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES, THIS BILL, IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL FOR OUR REGION IN
SHORT, IT WOULD REMOVE LEGAL
BARRIERS IN THE CURRENT STATUTES
THAT AUTHORIZE THE COUNTY OF
RIVERSIDE IMPERIAL IRRIGATION
DISTRICT, THE COACHELLA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT, LOCAL CITIES AND
TRIBES TO BECOME MEMBERS OF A
FUTURE JOINT POWER AUTHORITY
RELATED TO ELECTRIC SERVICES IN
THE REGION. THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL WAS CLOSELY VETTED AND
SUPPORTED BY THE COACHELLA
VALLEY ENERGY COMMISSION, OR
KNOWN AS KVEC, WHICH IS
COMPRISED OF THE SAME
STAKEHOLDERS. I PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED, ALL WHICH ARE
COMMUNITY ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES OF ALL OF THESE
PARTICULAR AGENCIES. AGAIN, THAT
WERE JUST HIGHLIGHTED. TODAY,
CIVIC IS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
ROBUST STRATEGIC PLANNING
PROCESS TO DETERMINE AN
ALTERNATIVE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
FOR ELECTRIC SERVICES IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY AND THE NEW
JPA, AND IS ONE OF THE PREFERRED
OPTIONS BECAUSE OF THIS
IMPORTANCE TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE REGION, SUMMER WALLACE, WHO
REPRESENTS A PORTION OF
COACHELLA VALLEY IN THE
NEIGHBORING DISTRICT, HAS ALSO
ADDED ON AS A CO-SPONSOR, TO
DEMONSTRATE HOW EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT IT IS TO THE ENTIRE
REGION, JOINING ME HERE TODAY,
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON BEHALF
OF CIVIC IS ANTONIO ORTEGA, A
REPRESENTATIVE OF ONE OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS ORGANIZATION
SLASH BODY. SO GOOD MORNING.
MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAID, MY NAME IS ANTONIO
ORTEGA. I'M HERE REPRESENTING
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE COACHELLA
VALLEY ENERGY COMMISSION. AS YOU
HEARD ALREADY FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA, AB 3198 IS NEEDED
TO REMOVE BARRIERS AND CURRENT
LAW THAT PREVENT SOME LOCAL
AGENCIES FROM PARTICIPATING IN A
FUTURE JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
RELATED TO POWER SERVICES IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY. WORKING
THROUGH THE COACHELLA VALLEY
ENERGY COMMISSION, WHICH
REPRESENTS SIX CITIES, FOUR
TRIBES, TWO COUNTIES, ONE WATER
DISTRICT AND ONE IRRIGATION
DISTRICT, WE IDENTIFIED THE
ISSUE THAT NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESSED, ROLLED UP OUR
SLEEVES, AND WORKED DILIGENTLY
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO IDENTIFY A
SOLUTION. ONCE WE DETERMINE THAT
LEGISLATION WAS NEEDED TO REMEDY
THIS ISSUE, WE APPROACHED THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO UNDERSTOOD
ITS IMPORTANCE TO ONGOING
EFFORTS AND AGREED TO AUTHOR AB
3188. THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF A BROADER LOCAL
DISCUSSION, AND WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS AND CONSIDERATION. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION,
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
COME FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AGAIN.
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA, ON BEHALF OF
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT, ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION, SEEING NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION COME TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SEEING NONE. Þ MOVE
THE BILL, BY SENATOR WIENER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO WRAP UP? I JUST THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THE MATTER. THANK
YOU. WE'LL CALL CALL THE VOTE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. SENATORS DURAZZO I.
DURAZZO. I'M SORRY. DOLLY.
GLACIER. SKINNER SKINNER I WAHAB
WIENER. WIENER. I'M 3 TO 0.
THANK YOU. WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLL
ROLLS OPEN. ALL RIGHT, NOW WE
HAVE.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WILSON. I'M
SORRY. CARILLO HAS A WITNESS WHO
HAS. OKAY OKAY. I'M SORRY. YES.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON. YEAH RIGHT NOW.
YEAH. YEAH, YEAH. SO IT'S. GOOD
MORNING. ARE YOU GOING TO FACE
US HERE? YOU DON'T WANT TO GO.
YOU KNOW WHAT? I HAVE A HARD
TIME READING FROM THE PODIUM.
OKAY, SO IF IT'S OKAY, I'LL
PRESENT FROM HERE. OKAY GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. AND THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT BEFORE
HER. OUR WITNESS HAS TO LEAVE
AND CATCH A FLIGHT BACK HOME. I
WANT TO BEGIN AND THANK. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS POLICY.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH
STRIKE THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL AND INSTEAD REQUIRE THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES TO REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON OR BEFORE
MARCH 1ST OF 2025. THE FISCAL
VIABILITY OF EAST LOS ANGELES AS
A SPECIAL DISTRICT OR
INCORPORATION, AS WELL AS THE
FEASIBILITY OF FORMING A
MUNICIPAL ADVISORY COUNCIL, A
LOCAL TOWN COUNCIL, OR A
COORDINATING COUNCIL THAT COULD
REPRESENT THE COMPREHENSIVE
INTEREST OF THE ENTIRE EAST LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY OR PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH AN EXISTING
REPORT OR REPORTS CONTAINING
SUSTAINABILITY WITH SIMILAR
INFORMATION. THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
ADOPTED TWO MOTIONS IN RESPONSE
TO AB 2986, WHICH REQUIRE THE
L.A. COUNTY CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER TO REPORT BACK TO THE
BOARD. THE INFORMATION OUTLINED
ON PAGE FIVE OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS RELATED TO
UNINCORPORATED EAST LOS ANGELES
AND OTHER UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. AS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS, THESE
REPORTS MAY PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO EVALUATE NEXT STEPS FOR THE
EAST LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY AND
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENT
DATA TO THE RESIDENTS OF
UNINCORPORATED EAST LA AND OTHER
UNINCORPORATED LOS ANGELES
COUNTY COMMUNITIES. EAST LOS
ANGELES IS THE MOST POPULATED
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITY IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY, AND WOULD BE THE
10TH LARGEST CITY IN THE COUNTY
IF IT WERE A CITY. IT IS
CALIFORNIA'S MOST POPULATED
UNINCORPORATED CENSUS DESIGNATED
AREA. THIS COMMUNITY IS 7.5MI²
AND HAS APPROXIMATELY 120,000
RESIDENTS, 95.5% OF WHOM ARE
LATINO. THIS VIBRANT COMMUNITY
HAS NO LOCAL REPRESENTATION AND
YET IS SURROUNDED BY CITIES,
SOME OF WHICH HAVE LESS
POPULATION, AND ALL OF WHOM
BENEFIT FROM LOCAL GOVERNANCE.
SENATORS, I AM PROUD TO
REPRESENT EAST LOS ANGELES AND
BE A PRODUCT OF EAST L.A. EAST
LOS ANGELES IS THE HEART OF
CALIFORNIA'S LATINO COMMUNITY,
WHOSE CULTURE HAS INFLUENCED THE
WORLD AND CULTIVATED GENERATIONS
OF POLITICAL LEADERS,
ENTERTAINERS, ACTIVISTS AND
SCHOLARS IN 2012, LAFCO DENIED
EFFORTS FOR EAST LOS ANGELES TO
INCORPORATE BASED ON A 2008
FINANCIAL STUDY DONE DURING THE
RECESSION. THE RATIONALE WAS
THAT THE COMMUNITY'S TAX BASE
COULD NOT SUPPORT CITYHOOD.
DENYING THAT EFFORT MEANT THAT
SELF-DETERMINATION TOWARDS THE
CREATION OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
NEVER WENT TO THE VOTERS.
RESIDENTS IN EAST L.A. WERE
DENIED THE OPPORTUNITY OF CHOICE
THROUGH THEIR VOTE. ACCORDING TO
COMMUNITY LEADERS WHO WORKED ON
THAT EFFORT. THEN COUNTY
SUPERVISOR GLORIA MOLINA
PROMISED TO DELIVER AN ANNUAL
FINANCIAL REPORT DETAILING TAX
COLLECTION AND EXPENDITURES FOR
THE COMMUNITY AS WELL AS THE
CREATION OF THE EAST LOS ANGELES
ADVISORY COMMITTEE, COMPOSED OF
LOCAL LEADERS, WHICH WAS IN FACT
ESTABLISHED. UNFORTUNATELY, THE
FINANCIAL REPORTS NEVER
MATERIALIZED, AND THAT THAT
COUNCIL OR COMMITTEE WAS
DISMANTLED. THIS COMMUNITY'S
NEARLY 120,000 RESIDENTS HAVE
SOUGHT A STRONGER CIVIC VOICE
FOR DECADES. DESPITE DESPITE
BEING THE LARGEST UNINCORPORATED
AREA IN L.A. COUNTY, EAST L.A.
RESIDENTS HAVE ONLY ONE LOCAL
ELECTED LEADER, A LOCAL
REPRESENTATIVE. THE COUNTY
SUPERVISOR, WHOSE DISTRICT
INCLUDES 2 MILLION PEOPLE. AB
2986 DOES NOT MANDATE CITYHOOD
OR INCORPORATION AS A SPECIAL
DISTRICT. THE BILL SIMPLY
ENSURES THAT L.A. COUNTY
PRODUCES WIDELY AND THIS
DECIMATES INFORMATION PERTINENT
TO EAST LA'S PAST AND FUTURE,
EMPOWERING EAST LOS ANGELES
RESIDENTS SO THEY HAVE A VOICE
IN THEIR COMMUNITY. I'VE
DEVELOPED THIS BILL WORKING WITH
HUNDREDS OF EAST LOS ANGELES
TENANTS AND HOMEOWNERS, BUSINESS
OWNERS, NONPROFIT DIRECTORS, AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS. I'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO THE COMMITTEE
CONVERSATIONS RELATED TO
HOUSING, AND THAT HISTORICALLY
POOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO
OVER DECADES HAVE IGNORED HAVE
BEEN IGNORED WHEN IT COMES TO
DECIDING WHERE TO BUILD HOUSING.
I AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS MADE
THAT MORE DELIBERATE PLANNING
NEEDS TO BE CONSIDERED. THIS IS
CURRENTLY NOT HAPPENING IN EAST
LA IN EAST L.A, AND THERE IS NO
EAST L.A. COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
PLAN AND VERY LITTLE INPUT. IF
ANY, FROM RESIDENTS WHO RESIDE
IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS WITHIN EAST
LA. AB 2986 IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT EAST LOS ANGELES
RESIDENTS CAN ACCESS PERTINENT
LOCAL INFORMATION THROUGH
TRANSPARENT COMMUNICATIONS. WE
CAN HELP THIS COMMUNITY WITHOUT
PLACING ANY UNDUE BURDEN ON L.A.
COUNTY, LA LAFCO, OR THE STATE.
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE OUR FRIENDS
AND LABOR AND THEIR CONCERNS AS
SOMEONE AND AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
RECEIVED ON MULTIPLE YEARS A
100% REPORT CARD WITH LABOR. MY
RECORD SPEAKS FOR ITSELF, AND I
WANT TO TAKE THE TIME DURING
RECESS TO WORK AND MEET WITH
LABOR AND ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
THAT IS MY COMMITMENT AND WHAT I
AM MORE THAN HAPPY TO DO AND
WHAT I HAVE BEEN DOING
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS. I LOOK
FORWARD AS WELL TO MEETING WITH
L.A. COUNTY SUPERVISOR SOLIS TO
BETTER SUPPORT OUR BEAUTIFUL
EAST LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY THAT
WE BOTH REPRESENT, AND ENSURE
THAT THE COMMUNITY IN EAST LOS
ANGELES FEELS SEEN, FEELS HEARD,
AND WE DEVELOPED AN ACTUAL,
REAL, TRANSPARENT EAST LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
PLAN AS ELECTED LEADERS, WE COME
AND GO, BUT THE FAMILIES THAT
MAKE EAST L.A. STAY AND THEY
MAKE IT WHAT IT IS. THEY ARE
DESERVING OF LEADERS WHO PUT
THEIR DIFFERENCES ASIDE AND TAKE
THE WORK NECESSARY IN FRONT OF
THEM TO IMPROVE THE CONDITIONS
AND THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF THE
FAMILIES THAT WE REPRESENT. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS AND
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT, AND TO
TESTIFY HERE IS FOR AB 920 2986
IS CHRISTY HERNANDEZ, CHAIR OF
THE MARAVILLA COMMUNITY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE, WHO WILL SPEAK AS A
RESIDENT AND STAKEHOLDER IN EAST
LOS ANGELES. THANK YOU. AND JUST
ONE SECOND, I HAD ANNOUNCED AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE HEARING
THAT WE HAD TO BE OUT BY 12:00.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BE VERY STRICT
WITH THE WITH THE TIME, WITH
EVERYONE I ASK EVERYONE ELSE,
KEEP KEEP THEIR PRESENTATION
SHORT. OKAY. SO I THINK YOU WERE
GOING TO GET THE FULL FOR TWO,
FOR, SINCE WE ONLY HAVE ONE
WITNESS. THAT'S WHAT I SAID.
OKAY, YOU GET THE FULL FOR TWO
PEOPLE, SO. OKAY, FOUR MINUTES,
AND THEN WE'LL ASK EVERYBODY TO
BE. OTHERWISE WE'RE GOING TO GET
HAULED OUT OF HERE. OKAY THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, GOOD AFTERNOON.
OR, MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME AGAIN IS
CHRISTY HERNANDEZ. I WAS BORN,
RAISED, AND I LIVE IN
UNINCORPORATED EAST LOS ANGELES.
AS MENTIONED, I'M ALSO THE
CHAIRPERSON OF THE MARAVILLA
COMMUNITY ADVISORY COMMITTEE,
WHERE WE CONVENE MEETINGS
BETWEEN EAST LA RESIDENTS AND
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS. I DO
THIS ON A VOLUNTEER BASIS AS
DOES OUR WHOLE BOARD, BECAUSE WE
CARE ABOUT THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR LOCAL RESIDENTS, WITH THE
GOAL OF INCREASING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT, OUR COMMUNITY HAS
REQUESTED A THIRD PARTY
FINANCIAL STUDY FOR
UNINCORPORATED EAST LA, WHICH
HAS LED TO REQUESTS FOR A STUDY
FROM SACRAMENTO. AS THE LARGEST
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA, WITH CLOSE TO
120,000 RESIDENTS, WE LACK THE
REPRESENTATION OF CITY COUNCIL
OR MAYOR. OUR MOST LOCAL ELECTED
IS AN LA COUNTY SUPERVISOR WHO
REPRESENTS 2 MILLION PEOPLE.
RESIDENTS CURRENTLY DO NOT
RECEIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL REPORTS
OR BUDGETS, LEAVING US IN THE
DARK ABOUT HOW MUCH TAX REVENUE
OUR COMMUNITY GENERATES AND HOW
OUR TAX DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT.
THE LAST FINANCIAL REPORT
SPECIFIC TO EAST LA IS 13 YEARS
OLD AND DOES NOT ACCURATELY,
ACCURATELY REFLECT THE
COMMUNITY'S CURRENT FINANCIAL
STATUS. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
HAVE ACCESS TO UP TO DATE
FINANCIAL REPORTS TO UNDERSTAND
HOW OUR TAX DOLLARS ARE BEING
ALLOCATED, AND ENSURE THAT WE
ARE RECEIVING OUR FAIR SHARE OF
FUNDING FOR SERVICES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE. THIS
BILL IS NOT ABOUT CITYHOOD AND
IT IS NOT MANDATE CITYHOOD. IT'S
A REQUEST FOR TRANSPARENCY TO
UNDERSTAND THE DISTRIBUTION OF
FUNDS TO UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES, SPECIFICALLY EAST
L.A. SADLY, MISINFORMATION, FEAR
MONGERING AND FALSE CLAIMS HAVE
BEEN SPREAD, LEADING TO
CONFLICTS RESEMBLING DAVID
VERSUS GOLIATH PITTING PITTING
OUR COMMUNITY AGAINST EACH
OTHER, MAKING IT SEEM LIKE WE
ARE ANTI-LABOR. WE ARE NOT. WE
WANT TO WORK WITH LABOR, AS MANY
OF OUR SUPPORTERS ARE ALSO UNION
MEMBERS. WE WANT TO WORK WITH
SUPERVISOR SOLIS AND WHOMEVER IS
NEXT, IS OUR NEXT COUNTY
SUPERVISOR. AND HOW WE IMPROVE
EAST LA. WE ARE TIRED OF BEING
TOLD WE ARE TOO POOR. WE WANT TO
SEE A PLAN THAT IMPROVES
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS AND THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR OUR
FAMILIES. WE DON'T WANT TO BE
SILENCED AS WE SIMPLY WANT
TRANSPARENCY. EAST LA IS MORE
THAN A CAMPAIGN STOP. WE ARE
GLOBALLY RECOGNIZED COMMUNITY
WITH A RICH HISTORY OF CULTURE
AND ACTIVISM. IF NOW IS NOT THE
RIGHT TIME FOR TRANSPARENCY AND
SELF-DETERMINATION, THEN WHEN
THE FINANCIAL STUDY FOR EAST LA
IS CRUCIAL FOR ENSURING FAIR
DISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES AND
SERVICES. AS THE LARGEST
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITY, WE
CONTRIBUTE MORE TO TAX REVENUE
INTO THE GENERAL FUND. THE STUDY
CAN HELP TO PROMOTE EQUITY AND
SERVICE DISTRIBUTION AND INFORM
OUR COMMUNITY ABOUT SPENDING
PATTERNS. THE COUNTY HAS NOT
MADE THAT INFORMATION AVAILABLE
SINCE 2011. SINCE THE
INTRODUCTION OF AB 2980 SIX
INCHES MARCH, WE HAVE OBSERVED
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN THE
BEHAVIOR AND INTERACTION OF THE
COUNTY WITH THE COMMUNITY,
INCLUDING LA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS MOTION TO OPPOSE OUR
STUDY, BUT THEN TOOK STEPS TO
CONDUCT THEIR OWN FINANCIAL
STUDY WITH A PRICE TAG OF $5.1
MILLION. WHY WOULD THE COUNTY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND THEN TURN
AROUND AND PASS A MOTION TO
CONDUCT THEIR OWN STUDY FOR EAST
LA? THE COUNTY HAS SUDDENLY
SHOWN INTEREST IN EAST L.A, WITH
AN UPTICK IN COUNTY RECOGNITION
OF INDIVIDUALS WITH TIES TO THE
EAST SIDE, INCREASED SOCIAL
MEDIA COVERAGE AND PHOTO OPS
WITH SMALL BUSINESSES IN
SCHOOLS. HOWEVER, IN SHEER
CONTRAST, THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
SHOWN SUPPORT FOR OUR FINANCIAL
REPORT AND TRANSPARENCY HAVE
BEEN SHUNNED AND BULLIED BECAUSE
OF MY SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. THE
COMMUNITY GROUP THAT I CHAIR WAS
DISPLACED FROM OUR MEETING
LOCATION OF 30 PLUS YEARS. A
COMMUNITY AUDITORIUM AND A
COUNTY BUILDING. WE HAVE ASKED
FOR THE SUPERVISOR'S SUPPORT TO
REINSTATE OUR APPLICATION, AND
IT'S GOING ON TWO MONTHS OF NO
ACTION. NONPROFITS IN FAVOR OF
OUR STUDY HAVE SEEN REALLOCATION
OF THEIR FUNDING, IMPACTING
THEIR COMMUNITY PROGRAMING.
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND
SUPPORT OF OUR STUDY HAVE
REPORTED VISITS FROM CODE
ENFORCEMENT AND HEALTH
INSPECTORS. OPPOSITION IS
FURTHER MARGINALIZING AND
DISENFRANCHIZING EAST LA
RESIDENTS, NONPROFITS AND
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. RESIDENTS SHOULD NOT BE
BULLIED OR SABOTAGED FOR
REQUESTING TRANSPARENCY, FOR
WANTING TO EMPOWER OUR COMMUNITY
WITH INFORMATION, FOR WANTING
MORE, FOR OUR COMMUNITY, AS A
DEMOCRACY, AS A DEMOCRACY, IT'S
CRUCIAL TO WORK TOGETHER TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE. WE
WELCOME THE CONVERSATION, BUT
INSTEAD THERE'S AN INTENSE
EFFORT TO SILENCE AND SUPPRESS
THE VOICES, SUPPORTING
TRANSPARENCY AND EMPOWERMENT. SO
THIS BILL IS ONE PIECE OF A MUCH
LARGER CONVERSATION, MORE EAST,
MORE EAST LOS ANGELES RESIDENTS
LIKE MYSELF HAVE CHOSEN TO COME
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY THAT
RAISED US AND WORK TOWARDS A
THRIVING ECONOMY, CONTRARY TO
THE NARRATIVE OF BY THE
OPPOSITION, COUNTY MEMBERS MAKE
EAST L.A. THEIR LIFELONG HOME,
AND AS A BELOVED COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER DIANA TARANGO ONCE
SAID, DON'T MOVE. IMPROVE. THIS
FINANCIAL STUDY WILL PROVIDE US
WITH THE INFORMATION TO HELP
FIND WAYS TO IMPROVE OUR BELOVED
COMMUNITY THAT WE CALL HOME. SO
IN THE NAME OF DEMOCRACY AND
TRANSPARENCY, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB
2986? THANK YOU. MICHAEL SIMON,
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
UNINCORPORATED, WE DO SUPPORT
THE BILL, OUR STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION SPEAKS ON BEHALF OF
5 MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
DISENFRANCHIZED BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT HAVE MAYORS AND CITY
COUNCILS TO TAKE CARE OF LOCAL
ISSUES. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE SUPPORT LOCAL CONTROL,
DEMOCRACY AND FAIRNESS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OKAY. HEARING SEEING
NONE. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
2986. ARE WE GOING TO HAVE
SPECIFIC WITNESSES? OKAY OKAY.
GOOD MORNING. TWO MINUTES EACH.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
HONORABLE GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. AND HONORABLE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS TAMMY OMOTO
FRIAS AND I AM THE SENIOR BUDGET
DEPUTY FOR SUPERVISOR HILDA
SOLIS OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. ON BEHALF
OF SUPERVISOR SOLIS, I AM HERE
TO OPPOSE AB 2986, WHICH SEEKS
TO ESTABLISH A TASK FORCE TO
DETERMINE THE FEASIBILITY OF
INCORPORATING EAST LOS ANGELES
OR CREATING A SPECIAL DISTRICT
SUPERVISOR. SOLIS AUTHORED TWO
MOTIONS WHICH ALREADY ADDRESSED
THE BILL'S CONCERNS, AND BOTH
WERE UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED BY THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. IN APRIL,
THE COUNTY DIRECTED WAS DIRECTED
TO NOT ONLY OPPOSE THE BILL, BUT
TO ENGAGE LAFCO OR LABOR
PARTNERS AND ALL PARTS OF THE
EAST L.A. COMMUNITY TO CONDUCT
AN ANALYSIS ON THE FISCAL
VIABILITY OF EAST L.A. AS A CITY
OR SPECIAL DISTRICT. THE COUNTY
IS ALSO LOOKING TO FORM A
MUNICIPAL ADVISORY COUNCIL, A
TOWN COUNCIL, OR A COORDINATING
COUNCIL TO REPRESENT THE
COMPREHENSIVE INTERESTS OF THE
ENTIRE EAST LA COMMUNITY. THIS
WOULD BE IN ADDITION TO THE LONG
STANDING COMMUNITY ADVISORY
COUNCILS THAT ALREADY EXIST IN
EAST L.A. IN MAY, THE COUNTY WAS
DIRECTED TO PROVIDE AN ANNUAL
REPORT ON SERVICES AND
INVESTMENTS IN THE
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES WITH
A POPULATION OF OVER 10,000, AND
TO RUN A FORMAL INFORMATION
CAMPAIGN TO ENSURE THESE
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES WERE
AWARE OF THE ANNUAL REPORT AND
THE SERVICES, PROJECTS AND
PROGRAMS THE COUNTY PROVIDES.
AND THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS, OUR
COMMUNITY, STAKEHOLDERS SHOULD
BE ENGAGED, HEARD AND KEPT
UPDATED. THE COUNTY HAS ALREADY
INITIATED THIS WORK REGARDLESS
OF THE BILL, BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THE WORK WILL BE
COMPLETED AND ISSUED TO THE
PUBLIC LONG BEFORE THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. OF THE
BILL, LONG BEFORE THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL THAT TAKES EFFECT,
MY COLLEAGUE WILL DISCUSS
FURTHER THE LAFCO PROCESS, BUT
I'D LIKE TO UNDERSCORE THAT THE
PROCESS BEGINS WITH SIGNATURE
GATHERING TO ENSURE THAT THE
RESIDENTS OF THE AREA IN
QUESTION REALLY DO WANT TO
INCORPORATE. AND WE HAVE
GATHERED OVER 2200 SIGNATURES OF
EAST LA RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES
WHO OPPOSE INCORPORATION. IT IS
WITH THEM AS WELL AS A DOZEN OF
OUR UNION PARTNERS, THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, LAFCO AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WE OPPOSE. AB
2096. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING,
AND THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ADRIANA ROMO, AND I'M THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR LOS
ANGELES, LAFCO AS YOU ARE AWARE,
OUR COMMISSION TOOK A POSITION
TO OPPOSE AB 2986. I DO WANT TO
COMMEND THE COMMITTEE FOR A
GREAT BILL ANALYSIS. IT WAS VERY
INFORMATIVE AND IT CLEARLY
UNDERSTANDS THE LAFCO PROCESS.
SO I DO APPRECIATE THAT, I WANT
TO JUST HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE
AREAS AS TO WHY WE ASKED THAT.
AB 2986 AS PRESENTED FOR LAFCO
TO FORM A COMMITTEE TO REVIEW
INCORPORATION OR SPECIAL
DISTRICTS IS BECAUSE IT BYPASSES
THE LAFCO PROCESS AND CURRENT
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS FROM. SINCE
ITS CREATION HAS WORKED WHERE AN
APPLICANT SUBMITS A PETITION TO
LAFCO, LAFCO REVIEWS AND IT'S
BEEN SUCCESSFUL FOR FORMATION OF
NEW CITIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS
IN LA COUNTY. AS LATE AS 1991.
THERE IS NOTHING TO SUGGEST THAT
CURRENT LAW IS INSUFFICIENT, AND
AB 2986, AS PRESENTED TO US, IS
JUST A DIFFERENT APPROACH
ALTOGETHER. IT SETS BAD
PRECEDENT. ALSO, SINCE THE
INTRODUCTION, WE HAD NOT HEARD
ANYTHING FROM ANY OF THE
RESIDENTS. WE ARE HERE TO
SUPPORT THE RESIDENTS, PROVIDE
THE PROCESS SO THAT THE
RESIDENTS COULD FULFILL, THEIR
REQUIREMENTS TO FILE AN
APPLICATION TO LAFCO, WE ARE
VERY FORTUNATE THAT WE HAVE
COMMISSIONER WENDY ZELAYA HERE,
WHO IS ONE OF TWO COMMISSIONERS
THAT REPRESENTS THE GENERAL
PUBLIC IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND SHE IS VERY, ENGAGED IN THE
COMMUNITY, PROFESSIONALLY AND
PERSONALLY. AND SHE DOES HAVE A
VOICE IN THE, EAST LOS ANGELES.
SHE'S VERY, YOU KNOW, DOOR TO
DOOR PERSON. AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT. AND HER BEING HERE ALSO,
LAFCO IS REQUIRED TO REVIEW A
PROPOSAL THAT'S SUBMITTED TO US
AND THE BILL BY LAFCO FORMING A
COMMITTEE GOES AGAINST THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE IN THE FORMATION
OF THE ANALYSIS PROCESS AND
FORMULATING COMMITTEE SO THAT WE
CAN THEN ANALYZE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO OUR
COMMISSION. AND THAT IS
GENERALLY A CONFLICT, I'M SORRY,
YOU HAVE TO WRAP IT UP. OKAY SO
TO WRAP IT UP, I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT THERE ARE THERE IS AN
OPTION WITH THE GOVERNOR'S,
OFFICE AND PLANNING RESEARCH FOR
INCORPORATION GUIDELINES. AND
THERE IS, A PROCESS FOR THE
PROPONENTS TO GO AHEAD AND START
AN INITIAL FISCAL ANALYSIS
BEFORE THEY GO INTO THE DEEP
DIVE OF A, OF COLLECTING
PETITIONS OF 25. SO WE'RE HERE
TO SUPPORT THE RESIDENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND SUPPORT THE
PROCESS. THANK YOU, ANY MORE,
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION, PLEASE. WELL,
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES DEPUTY PROBATION
OFFICERS ASKED ME 685. WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. TIFFANY
WHITEN WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HONORABLE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, AMY HINES-IKE WITH
UNITE HERE LOCAL 11, WE
RESPECTFULLY HAVE A OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED, AND WE THANK YOU
SO MUCH, HONORABLE CHAIR AND
YOUR GREAT STAFF FOR INTERVENING
ON THIS MATTER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
MATTHEW SEIBERLING, ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION FOR LOS ANGELES
DEPUTY SHERIFFS AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL EMPLOYEES, BOTH IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MEGAN SUBERS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND THE LA COUNTY
FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL 1014, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS SARA FLOCKS,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION. WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN
PRINT. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
UNIONS IN THE LA AREA, INCLUDING
THE LA COUNTY FED, THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AS WELL.
BUT YET WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
VET THE AMENDMENTS. WE WILL DO
THAT IN RETURN WITH A POSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MARVIN
DIONNE, COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES,
IN LIGHT OF OUR REVIEW OF THE
ANALYSIS AND THE DESCRIBED
AMENDMENTS, WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? OKAY. SEEING NONE.
COLLEAGUES AT THE DAIS.
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS? SENATOR
SKINNER, AS I READ THE
AMENDMENTS, IT INDICATES THAT IT
HAS A SHELL IN TERMS OF THE
STUDY. SO WOULD THAT DOES THAT
TRIGGER THE LOCAL MANDATE?
THAT'S ALREADY MANDATED, IN
OTHER WORDS, REQUIRING THE STATE
TO PAY FOR IT. IF WE'RE
DIRECTING A COUNTY TO DO
SOMETHING THAT HAS A MANDATE ON
THAT FOR THE,
OKAY. DOESN'T CHANGE THAT. OKAY.
THAT'S DON'T CHANGE. OKAY.
AMENDMENTS DON'T CHANGE, THOUGH.
THE THE ISSUES AROUND WHETHER A
BILL MEETS THE TEST OF LOCAL
MANDATE, AS WE KNOW THAT,
HOWEVER, THE WORD SHALL IS
RATHER DIRECTIVE. I'M NOT. I
DON'T HAVE OPPOSITION TO THAT.
BUT IT IS DIRECTIVE. IT IS
SAYING SHALL VERSUS ANYWAY. BUT
JUST WANTED TO RAISE THAT. OKAY.
BUT IT SHALL PRODUCER REPORT.
ALSO. OKAY OKAY. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
NO. OKAY SORRY. I, I APPRECIATE
THAT THESE THINGS YOU KNOW, THAT
THERE'S, WHEN INTER
JURISDICTIONAL EVEN THOUGH
THERE'S NOT A JURISDICTION HERE
YET, HOWEVER, THE COUNTY, ALL OF
THE COUNTY, ALL THE ENTITIES
RELATED TO THE COUNTY, I MEAN,
THEY'RE I GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY
IS, ASSEMBLY MEMBER THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A LOT OF
SUPPORT FOR YOUR BILL. AND AND I
REALIZED THAT THE CHAIR'S
AMENDMENTS PRIMARILY REQUIRE A
STUDY VERSUS ENACTING IT AS
INITIALLY. BUT I JUST NOTE THAT,
ANYWAY, THAT WE'RE BEING ASKED
TO, IN EFFECT, IMPOSE SOMETHING,
THAT THE PEOPLE FOR WHOM IT
WOULD BE IMPOSED ON ARE NOT
SUPPORTIVE OF. YEAH I JUST WANT
TO MAKE A COMMENT. THE I BELIEVE
HOPEFULLY I'M HOPEFUL THAT AFTER
THE MANY OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WERE IN OPPOSITION, AFTER
THEY SEE THE AMENDMENTS,
HOPEFULLY THAT THEY WILL BE
SUPPORTIVE AS A WAY TO MOVE
FORWARD, PROVIDE INFORMATION,
CREATE THE INFORMATION, CREATE
THE REPORT AND HOPEFULLY THAT,
YOU KNOW, BECOMES A REASON TO
SUPPORT THE PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD. WE'RE NOT CHANGING WHAT
IT TAKES. IF THERE WERE IF THERE
WAS INTEREST IN GOING TOWARDS
CITYHOOD, WE'RE NOT CHANGING
ANYTHING OF THAT. THAT'S LAFCO.
SO WE'RE NOT MOVING ANYTHING.
THIS IS A MATTER OF HOW TO GET
THE INFORMATION. INSTEAD OF THE
STATE DOING, A STUDY. IT MAKES
MORE SENSE JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
WHAT THE COUNTY HAS ALREADY
DECIDED THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
DO, AND IT'S PRETTY MUCH, YOU
KNOW, A LOT OF THE INFORMATION
THAT GENERALLY HAS BEEN
REQUESTED. OKAY. DO YOU WANT TO
WRAP UP AGAIN? WE'RE THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO GET KICKED OUT OF
HERE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND AGAIN, I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE IN THE ASSEMBLY FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT BEFORE HER. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON. SENATOR
SKINNER, THERE ARE OVER 500
LETTERS OF SUPPORT, ALREADY IN
THE SYSTEM FOR YOU TO REVIEW.
THIS HAS ALL BEEN A GRASSROOTS
MOVEMENT FROM THE BOTTOM UP. MY
STAFF, WE ARE A STAFF OF THREE
IN THE DISTRICT. I DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES THAT THE LA COUNTY
SUPERVISORIAL DISTRICT ONE HAS
TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT ALL OF
THEIR STAFF TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT THE SIGNATURES THAT
THEY'VE COLLECTED. SO IT IS A
DAVID AND GOLIATH VERSUS
SITUATION, AND SO I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENT, BUT I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT IF YOU WERE TO ATTEND
A MEETING IN EAST LOS ANGELES,
YOU WOULD SEE HUNDREDS OF
RESIDENTS IN SUPPORT OF WANTING
TO HAVE TRANSPARENCY IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, WANTING TO HAVE THE
DATA AS TO HOW THEIR TAXES ARE
BEING ALLOCATED. WANTED TO FORM
SOME KIND OF LOCAL
REPRESENTATION THAT ALLOWS FOR
THEM TO HAVE SOME KIND OF SAY IN
THE VARIOUS DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES IN EAST L.A, THE SIX
DIFFERENT BUSINESS CORRIDORS
THAT NEED SUPPORT AND SERVICES,
WANTING TO SEE AN ACTUAL,
TRANSPARENT PUBLIC AND REAL EAST
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT PLAN THAT INCLUDES
THE VOICES OF THE VERY PEOPLE
THAT LIVE THERE THAT CURRENTLY
DOES NOT EXIST. AND SO THIS IS A
STEP FORWARD, AND I'M GRATEFUL
TO THE SUPERVISOR FOR HAVING
MADE THE MOTION. THE TWO MOTIONS
THAT NOW WILL INCLUDE THE STUDY
FOR EAST LOS ANGELES AS WELL.
AND THIS DIDN'T EXIST BEFORE
THIS BILL. TRANSPARENCY FOR ALL
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES
WITHIN LA COUNTY WITH MORE THAN
10,000 RESIDENTS THAT PRIOR TO
THIS BILL DID NOT HAVE ANY
INFORMATION AS TO HOW THEIR
TAXES WERE BEING USED. SO WE
HOPE TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AGAIN. I, I PLEDGE
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH OUR
LABOR PARTNERS TO GET TO A GOOD
SPACE AND TO FOR THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS WELL AS WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH SUPERVISOR
SOLIS HERSELF. BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY, THIS IS NOT
ABOUT WHOEVER IS IN OFFICE. THIS
IS ABOUT OUR COMMUNITY. THIS IS
ABOUT ENSURING THAT THE
RESIDENTS OF EAST LOS ANGELES
FEEL SEEN AND HEARD. AND WITH
THAT, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
TO HAVE THE CONVERSATION MOVE
FORWARD. DO I HAVE A MOTION?
SENATOR WIENER MOVES THE BILL
AND WE HAVE A ROLL CALL. PLEASE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
DURAZZO, I, DURAZZO I. SATO.
DOLLY. GLASER SKINNER. SKINNER I
WAHAB. WIENER. WIENER I 3 TO 0.
THANK YOU, YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD IT OPEN AND WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO RETURN AT 1:00, TO
FINISH THE REST OF THE AGENDA.
THANK YOU ALL.
OKAY. THANK YOU. THE FIRST, THE
NEXT, BILL THAT WE WILL BE
PRESENTING IS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON AB 2257. THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
APPRECIATE YOU, TÍNH. OKAY. YOU
CAN GET STARTED WHENEVER YOU
WANT. ALL RIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2257, A
BILL DESIGNED TO ENHANCE THE
TRANSPARENCY, EFFICIENCY AND
FAIRNESS OF THE RATE SETTING
PROCESS FOR WATER AND SEWER
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR DILIGENT
WORK ON THE AMENDMENTS, ALL OF
WHICH WE ARE ACCEPTING AND ARE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE. AT ITS
CORE, AB 2257 IS ABOUT FOSTERING
A CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOG BETWEEN
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND THE PEOPLE
THEY SERVE UNDER EXISTING LAW,
PROP 218 REQUIRES PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE ADVANCE
NOTICE TO PROPERTY OWNERS, A
PUBLIC HEARING FOR PROTESTS, AND
RESTRICTS THE IMPOSITION OF FEES
UNLESS THEY REPRESENT THE ACTUAL
COST OF SERVICES. HOWEVER, THE
INCREASE IN PROPOSITION 218
LITIGATION CHALLENGES LOCAL
AGENCIES ABILITY TO SET FAIR
RATES TO COVER OPERATIONAL AND
INVESTMENT COSTS. AS A REMINDER,
THESE ARE COSTS TO THE
RATEPAYER. OFTEN THESE LEGAL
CHALLENGES COME WITHOUT PRIOR
OBJECTIONS BEING RAISED DURING
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD,
LEADING TO COSTLY AND UNFORESEEN
LAWSUITS THAT STRAIN THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES OF THESE
AGENCIES. ONCE AGAIN, THE
AGENCIES ARE THE RATEPAYERS.
THE. THIS BILL AIMS TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES EARLY AND REDUCE THE
FREQUENCY OF LITIGATION, WHICH
CAN BE COSTLY AND TIME CONSUMING
FOR BOTH PARTIES. ONCE AGAIN,
THE RATEPAYERS AB 2257
REPRESENTS A BALANCED APPROACH
TO RATE SETTING. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT MORE THAN JUST PROCEDURAL
ADJUSTMENTS. IT'S ABOUT ENSURING
OUR PUBLIC AGENCIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES WORK TOGETHER MORE
EFFECTIVELY TO TACKLE THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE. IMPORTANTLY
THIS BILL STILL PROTECTS THE
RIGHT TO LITIGATE AGAINST
ONGOING FAILURES BY AN AGENCY TO
IMPLEMENT RATES IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THE SUBSTANTIVE
REQUIREMENTS OF PROPOSITION 218.
THIS ENSURES THAT AGENCIES
CANNOT MISUSE FEES FOR PURPOSES
OTHER THAN THOSE EXPLICITLY
STATED WITH ME TODAY IS
CHRISTOPHER ANDERSON, SENIOR
STATE RELATIONS ADVOCATE AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES. AQUA. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM. YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. CHRIS
ANDERSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES, THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. PUBLIC WATER AND
SEWER AGENCIES PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES FOR THE
BENEFIT OF COMMUNITIES,
AGRICULTURE, INDUSTRIES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. THESE AGENCIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING A
CONSISTENT AND RELIABLE WATER
SUPPLY, SAFEGUARDING THE QUALITY
OF DRINKING WATER, PLANNING,
CONSTRUCTING, MAINTAINING
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND MUCH
MORE. WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
PRESENTING UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGES, THESE AGENCIES MUST
ALSO ADAPT AND ENHANCE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS OF INCREASINGLY FREQUENT
AND SEVERE CLIMATE RELATED
EVENTS. BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS ARE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. PROP 218 PLACES
STRICT LIMITATIONS ON HOW
AGENCIES CAN RAISE REVENUE, AND
AS A RESULT, PUBLIC AGENCIES
PREDOMINANTLY RELY ON REVENUE
FROM SERVICE RATES AND
ASSESSMENTS TO FINANCE THEIR
ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT SERVICES.
WHILE THESE AGENCIES REQUIRE
FINANCIAL STABILITY TO MEET
INCREASING DEMANDS, A RISE IN
PROP 218 LITIGATION IS MAKING IT
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO ENSURE
AGENCIES CAN PASS FAIR AND
REASONABLE RATES TO COVER COST
OF OPERATIONS AND INVESTMENTS.
AND, AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NOTED, OFTENTIMES THESE LAWSUITS
ARE FILED WITHOUT PRIOR NOTICE
TO THE PUBLIC AGENCY. AB TWO 257
WOULD BOLSTER THE EXISTING RATE
MAKING PROCESS IN ORDER TO
ENHANCE DIALOG AND TRANSPARENCY
BETWEEN PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
THEIR CUSTOMERS. THE GOAL OF
THIS LEGISLATION IS TO SHINE
SUNLIGHT ON POTENTIAL
OBJECTIONS. WHEN AGENCIES HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND AND
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS, AGAIN, I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR CARRYING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. AND IF YOU'LL INDULGE
ME, I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
REGISTER THE SUPPORT OF EAST
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT, CAYUGAS
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT, AND
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB 2257?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. HELLO,
KRISTIE FOY WITH ARNOLD AND
ASSOCIATES HERE ON BEHALF OF
THREE VALLEYS MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HI THERE. MCKINLEY
THOMPSON MORLEY, ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS, ERIN
NIEMELA WITH NIEMELA PAPPAS AND
ON BEHALF OF EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT, SANTA MARGARITA
AND THE CALIFORNIA STORMWATER
QUALITY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. OBED FRANKEL HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CONTRA COSTA WATER
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. BALTASAR
CORNEJO, WITH BROWNSTEIN ON
BEHALF OF OTAY WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. HOLLY. FOR MANY DAYS,
THE LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF VALLEY WATER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, KEISHA HUNT
WITH NOSSAMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF
PADRE DAM MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT, AS WELL AS OLIVENHAIN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. JASON AITKEN, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION AND THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICTS. HAPPY TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M ERIC LARA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. PROUD
TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH
SAN JOAQUIN IRRIGATION DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AGAIN. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
AB 2257 SEEING NONE. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION AB 2257 OKAY. SEEING
NONE. BRING IT BACK. THERE'S NO
SENATOR. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE. WE'RE
LIKE I'D LIKE TO OFFER THE
AUTHOR ANY WRAP UP. YES, YES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR,
BY PROMOTING EARLY AND
MEANINGFUL DIALOG BETWEEN PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND RATEPAYERS, THIS
BILL LAYS THE GROUNDWORK FOR
MORE EQUITABLE AND EFFECTIVE
WATER AND SEWER SERVICE RATES IN
CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT, AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE A VOTE? I
MEAN, A MOTION. MOTION. MOVED BY
SENATOR WIENER, CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. SENATORS
DURAZZO I, DURAZZO I. SATO
DOLLY. GLACIER. SKINNER WAHAB.
WIENER. WIENER. AYE 2 TO 0.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLES OPEN.
THANK YOU. OKAY. MOVING ON TO
ALVAREZ. ALVAREZ. WHO DID? OKAY
OKAY. I THINK YOU'RE LUCKY TO
COME AHEAD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ADAMS, I
NEED TO DO SOMETHING FOR SOMEONE
ELSE. WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK THANK YOU.
CHAIR. WE HAVE A UNDERAGE
WITNESS THAT MIGHT JOIN US UP AT
THE TABLE, YES. THANK YOU,
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING AB 3233.
YES. SO THANK YOU. CHAIR. STAFF
AND ADVOCATES, TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 3233, THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL CHOICE AND SAFETY
ACT. AT FACE VALUE, THIS BILL IS
A DIRECT RESPONSE TO AN ISSUE
THAT I HAVE HEARD FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS, PARTICULARLY THOSE
IN MONTEREY COUNTY. BUT BEYOND
THAT, THIS IS A PERSISTENT
PROBLEM THAT APPLIES TO ALL OF
US HERE. AND TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IN RECENT YEARS,
WE HAVE HEARD FROM MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS, EDUCATORS, LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, PARENTS, AND
COUNTLESS OTHERS ABOUT THE
IMPACTS OF OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS ON COMMUNITIES. WE
HAVE ALL READ RESEARCH ON THE
IMPACTS TO PUBLIC HEALTH,
INCLUDING INCREASED RISK OF
ASTHMA AND CARDIAC DISEASE, AND
MOST ESPECIALLY, ESPECIALLY IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WITNESS
THE INCREASED RISK OF
EARTHQUAKES FROM DRILLING AND
OIL SPILLS AND AIR POLLUTION,
AND HEARD CONCERNS ABOUT
DEPRECIATING PROPERTY VALUES, AS
WELL AS DECREASED INVESTMENT IN
RESIDENTIAL AREAS NEAR OIL AND
GAS SITES. AS A RESULT, MANY
CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE TAKEN
STEPS TO REEVALUATE WHETHER TO
MAINTAIN THESE OPERATIONS,
ESPECIALLY AS CALIFORNIA REDUCES
ITS DEPENDANCE ON FOSSIL FUELS
AND A CARBON NEUTRAL FUTURE.
MONTEREY COUNTY SAN BENITO
COUNTY, LA COUNTY, ALAMEDA
COUNTY, AND CULVER CITY HAVE
INTRODUCED ORDINANCES AND PASSED
LOCAL MEASURES TO REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE OIL AND GAS. IN DOING
SO, THEY HAVE MADE IT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THEIR OWN
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS OF WHETHER
TO KEEP SUCH ACTIVITIES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES, AND TO DETERMINE IF
ANY ECONOMIC BENEFIT IS WORTH
THE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES TO
HEALTH, SAFETY, TOURISM, THE
ENVIRONMENT, AND SO MUCH MORE.
DESPITE THE OVERWHELMING AND
POPULAR SUPPORT FOR THESE LOCAL
MEASURES, THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT RULED LAST FALL THAT THE
LOCAL MEASURE IN MONTEREY COUNTY
WOULD NOT HOLD DUE TO HOW WE
HAVE WRITTEN STATE LAW. THIS
INVALIDATES THE ACTIONS OF
COMMUNITIES DISENFRANCHIZES
VOTERS WHO HAVE VOICED THEIR
CONCERNS AND ULTIMATELY LIMITS
THE ABILITY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO PROTECT THEIR COMMUNITIES.
IT'S A DANGEROUS LEGAL PRECEDENT
THAT WE CANNOT IGNORE. AB 3233
ENABLES LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR WELFARE, HEALTH AND
ECONOMY. SPECIFICALLY, THIS BILL
CLARIFIES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AUTHORITY TO LIMIT OR PROHIBIT
OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS. METHODS
AND LOCATIONS WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION, AND IT DOES NOT
BAN NEW OIL OR GAS OPERATIONS OR
MANDATE LOCAL ENTITIES TO STOP
ACTIVITY. IT SIMPLY CLARIFIES
THAT THEY DO. SO. JOINING ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY. HOLLAND KRENTZMAN AND
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. KATHRYN FREEMAN, IF
YOU WOULD JUST TAKE ONE MOMENT,
OKAY. GO AHEAD. WHOEVER WANTS TO
START. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, HOLLAND
KRETZMANN FOR CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH MORE THAN A DECADE
OF EXPERIENCE WITH CALIFORNIA'S
OIL AND GAS LAWS. AND THE
CENTER, PROUDLY SPONSORS AB
3233, THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL
CHOICE AND SAFETY ACT, A BILL
THAT WOULD PRESERVE THE ABILITY
OF CITIES AND COUNTIES TO USE
THEIR LOCAL AUTHORITY TO PROTECT
THEIR RESIDENTS FROM OIL AND GAS
POLLUTION. IT'S COMMON SENSE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OUGHT TO
BE ABLE TO DECIDE WHETHER AND
UNDER WHAT CONDITIONS, TO ALLOW
POLLUTING ACTIVITIES TO TAKE
PLACE IN THEIR JURISDICTIONS.
AFTER CAREFULLY WEIGHING INPUT
FROM THEIR CONSTITUENTS AND THE
POTENTIAL HARMS TO HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. THAT'S THE WAY
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN IN CALIFORNIA,
CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE HAD
LOCAL RULES APPLYING TO ALL
KINDS OF INDUSTRIES ON THE
BOOKS, INCLUDING OIL AND GAS,
FOR DECADES. THEY CAN RANGE FROM
STRAIGHT BANS TO SETBACK
MINIMUMS TO ORDINANCES DESIGNED
TO FACILITATE MORE PRODUCTION.
THIS BILL ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE GOING TO
HAVE DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO OIL
AND GAS. THE POINT IS THAT IT'S
UP TO THOSE CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES. LAST
YEAR, THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT INVALIDATED PARTS OF
MONTEREY COUNTY'S OIL AND GAS
ORDINANCE ON NARROW GROUNDS
BASED ON AN OUTDATED 1961
PROVISION OF THE STATE OIL AND
GAS CODE. BUT THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY HAS DISTORTED THIS
DECISION TO SOW CONFUSION ABOUT
WHAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN AND
CAN'T DO. THE INDUSTRY'S THREATS
AND INTIMIDATION HAVE HAD A
CHILLING EFFECT ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, WHO WANT MORE
CLARITY IN THE STATE LAW ABOUT
THE SCOPE OF LOCAL CONTROL, AB
3233 WOULD PUT AN END TO THIS
CONFUSION BY UPDATING THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE TO MAKE IT
CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN ENACT
PROTECTIONS FROM OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT, INCLUDING
RESTRICTIONS ON SPECIFIC
TECHNIQUES. THE BILL DOES NOT
TELL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT THEY
MUST BAN OR RESTRICT OIL AND
GAS, SO THE BILL DOES NOT RAISE
OR LOWER PRODUCTION. THAT
DECISION IS LEFT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. THE OIL INDUSTRY IS
IN STEEP DECLINE DUE TO DECADES
OF NATURALLY DECREASING
PRODUCTION AND LOWER DEMAND.
THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD NOT ALLOW
THE INDUSTRY TO PUT BLAME ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS, WHO JUST WANT
COMMON SENSE CONTROL OVER WHAT
HAPPENS IN THEIR OWN CITIES AND
COUNTIES. WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
AB 3233. THANK YOU. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. I'M
CATHERINE FREEMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, WHICH REPRESENTS ALL
58 COUNTIES. WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB 3233, WHICH WOULD
ENHANCE LOCAL CONTROL OVER LAND
USE AND ZONING ISSUES WITH
REGARDS TO OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS IN CALIFORNIA, MOST
LAND USE DECISIONS, AS YOU'VE
HEARD, ARE DELEGATED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ENSURE THE BEST
POSSIBLE OUTCOMES ARE MADE FOR
EACH INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY.
COUNTY COUNTIES ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR WEIGHING THE ESTHETIC,
ENVIRONMENTAL, ECONOMIC, AND
SAFETY CONCERNS WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AS SUCH, WE HAVE
VESTED INTEREST IN MAINTAINING
CLEAR AUTHORITY TO GOVERN ALL
OIL AND GAS RELATED USES
THROUGHOUT OUR JURISDICTIONS.
THIS IS WHY CSAC FILED AN AMICUS
BRIEF IN CHEVRON VERSUS COUNTY
OF MONTEREY, WHICH CHALLENGED
MEASURE Z, A LOCAL ORDINANCE
WHICH AIMED TO RESTRICT OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT WITHIN WITHIN
THE COUNTY. AB 3233 WOULD
CLARIFY IN STATUTE THAT THESE
LOCAL POWERS APPLY TO THE
REGULATION OF OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION FACILITIES. TO BE
VERY CLEAR, WE ARE NOT OPPOSED
TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF OIL AND
GAS PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
BILL SIMPLY WOULD ENSURE THAT
COUNTIES HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
BALANCE THEIR UNIQUE LOCAL NEEDS
THAT ARISE IN THE CONTEXT OF OIL
AND GAS DEVELOPMENT. IT'S FOR
THIS REASON THAT WE SUPPORT AB
3233. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. OKAY, ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB 1332 33?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. HI.
MICHELLE RUBALCAVA WITH NIELSEN
MERKSAMER ON BEHALF OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AND SUPPORT AND
ALSO BEING ASKED TO DO A ME TOO
FOR SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. THANK
YOU. HEY, FATIMA ZUBIATE WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS,
THIS IS ONE OF OUR TOP PRIORITY
BILLS. SO WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ALSO DOING A ME TOO FOR
THE CLIMATE CENTER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AARON NIEMELA WITH NEMA
PAPPAS ON BEHALF OF A CAMPAIGN
FOR THE SAFE AND HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA. ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON. REBECCA MARCUS,
REPRESENTING THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, TIFFANY NG, WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE REGISTERING OUR
STRONG SUPPORT AND PROVIDING
STRONG SUPPORT FROM THE CENTER
CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE, UNITED
FOR SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY, OR
CORE'S STRATEGIC CONCEPTS AND
ORGANIZING AND POLICY EDUCATION.
LÀ OR SCOPE LÀ AND THE VISION
COALITION ALL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. KATIE MCCAMMON WITH
SUPPORT FROM 350 SACRAMENTO AND
ALSO SUPPORT FROM 350 BAY AREA
ACTION. 350 SANTA BARBARA, SAN
DIEGO. 350 BAN SINGLE USE
PLASTICS, 1000 GRANDMOTHERS FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS AND 350
HUMBOLDT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, JACOB EVANS WITH
SIERRA CLUB, CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, JENNIFER DINARDO OF
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT AND STRONG SUPPORT.
AND ALSO REGISTERING STRONG
SUPPORT FOR CENTER FOR RACE,
POVERTY AND ENVIRONMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
FOLKS. MY NAME IS MORGAN
GONZALEZ WITH COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT AND SIERRA, A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES CITY
DISTRICT 15, ALSO REGISTERING
STRONG SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
STAND L.A. AND PSR LÀ. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, MEMBERS AND STAFF MITCH
STEIGER WITH CFT, A UNION OF
EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT, AND
THE OTHER YOUNG MAN, NØ. OKAY
NEXT TIME. HI. THANK YOU FOR
COMING. HI. MY NAME IS JESSICA
HERE ON BEHALF OF ÁP AND ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK
AND NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
RENATO. REGISTERING STRONG
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF CCI. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO NOTE SUPPORT FOR CLIMATE
HEALTH. NOW CONSUMER WATCHDOG I
THINK CCE CHEN JUST NOTED BUT
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK CLIMATE FIRST
REPLACING OIL AND GAS FOSSIL
FREE CALIFORNIA SUNFLOWER
ALLIANCE PROTECT MONTEREY COUNTY
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO PROTECT
AMERICA. CODE BLUE SANTA CRUZ
CLIMATE ACTION NETWORK,
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA AND NRDC.
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, NO MORE IN
SUPPORT. HOW ABOUT IN OPPOSITION?
WELCOME THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR,
PAUL DIRO, REPRESENTING THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION. IT'S HAVING BEEN
HERE ALL DAY AND LISTENED TO THE
STATEWIDE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, VERSUS LOCAL CONTROL. I
FULLY UNDERSTAND THE PRINCIPLES
OF LOCAL CONTROL, BUT IF THERE'S
A STATEWIDE NEED AND VALUE, THAT
THAT OVERCOMES LOCAL CONTROL, I
BELIEVE THAT, IN THIS CASE, THE
LOCAL CONTROL IS NOT MERITED.
OIL RESERVOIRS THAT SIT A MILE
FROM THE SURFACE IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AND CONTINUE TO
BE A STATEWIDE RESOURCE WITH
VALUE. THE DECLINE IN THE
PRODUCTION RATES IN CALIFORNIA,
ARE BECAUSE OF PERMITTING
ISSUES, NOT A DECLINE IN IN, IN
ACTUAL OIL, WE HAVE WE HAVE,
THOUSANDS OF MINERAL RIGHT
HOLDERS THAT MAY END UP LOSING
THE VALUE, THAT THAT ARE UNDER
THEIR PROPERTY, WHETHER THERE IS
LOCAL, LOCALLY, YOU CAN LEGALLY,
TAKE THE PROPERTY RIGHTS AWAY
FROM, FROM THE MINERAL RIGHT
HOLDERS. I THINK, IS IN
QUESTION, SHUTTING DOWN, OIL
PRODUCTION WILL FURTHER
EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM OF
RELYING ON FOREIGN SOURCES OF
CRUDE COMING ON OIL TANKERS TO
CALIFORNIA SHORES. WE CURRENTLY
IMPORT 75% OF THE CRUDE THAT OUR
REFINERIES NEED TO MEET. THE
DEMAND OF CALIFORNIA DRIVERS.
MOST OF THESE IMPORTS COME FROM
SAUDI ARABIA, IRAQ AND ECUADOR
COUNTRIES THAT DON'T SHARE OUR
WORKING STANDARDS WITH OUR
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE.
NOR ARE STRICT ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS. IMPORTING FOREIGN OIL
ALSO COMES WITH A COST TO OUR
REFINERIES AND ULTIMATELY
CONSUMERS AT THE PUMP. IN STATE
OIL PRODUCTION IS TRANSPORTED
VIA PIPELINE TO ALL REFINERIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IMPORTED OIL AND THE COST OF THE
TRANSPORT VIA PIPELINE IS A
DOLLAR A BARREL. THE IMPORTATION
OF OIL COMING FROM PRIMARILY THE
MIDDLE EAST AND SOUTH AMERICA.
THERE IS A COST OF $6 A BARREL
FOR THAT TRANSPORT COST. HAVING
A TANKER TRAVEL THREE WEEKS FROM
SAUDI ARABIA TO THE SHORES OF
CALIFORNIA, NOT ONLY IS THIS A
BAD IDEA? THE TRADE OFF OF
POTENTIAL LOCAL BANS OR
LIMITATIONS OF OIL PRODUCTION
RESULTS IN MORE DIRTY FOREIGN
OIL COMING TO CALIFORNIA AND
MORE COST TO CONSUMERS AT THE
PUMP. FOR THOSE REASONS, WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK
YOU, CHAIR. SENATOR SEAN
WALLENTINE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION, IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. I HEARD IT SAID
EARLIER, THIS BILL IS NOT
OPPOSED TO OIL PRODUCTION. I
DISAGREE THE BILL IS OPPOSED TO
OIL PRODUCTION. THAT'S THE WHOLE
POINT OF THE BILL IS TO RESTRICT
OR ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
RESTRICT, OIL PRODUCTION. BUT
IT'S NOT ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL
BECAUSE, FOR EXAMPLE, KERN
COUNTY WOULD PROBABLY WANT TO
EXPAND OIL PRODUCTION. BUT THIS
BILL DOES NOT ALLOW KERN COUNTY
TO DO THAT. THIS BILL ONLY GOES
ONE DIRECTION. SHUT DOWN OIL
PRODUCTION, I'D LIKE TO SAY,
TOO, THAT THE STATE OIL AND GAS
SUPERVISOR, MR. DOUG ITO, AND
HIS TEAM, THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY RIGHT NOW TO SHUT DOWN
ANY OIL WELL, ANYWHERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT IS
POLLUTING OR HARMING THE
ENVIRONMENT OR ANY INDIVIDUAL.
THEY HARDLY EVER DO THAT. WHY?
BECAUSE OUR OIL WELLS ARE NOT
POLLUTING. THEY'RE NOT
POLLUTING. WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
POLLUTE. IN CALIFORNIA, UNLIKE
OIL WELLS THAT ARE DRILLED IN
IRAQ, SAUDI ARABIA AND ECUADOR,
WHERE THEY'RE BULLDOZING THE
AMAZON RAINFOREST, THAT'S WHERE
CBD SHOULD BE. THEY SHOULD BE
PROTECTING THE RAINFOREST. NOT
HERE TRYING TO SHUT DOWN THE
MOST RESPONSIBLE OIL PRODUCTION
INDUSTRY ON THE PLANET WITH A
WORKFORCE BY THE WAY, THAT IS
MAJORITY BLACK AND BROWN
RESIDENTS THAT I HEAR EVERY ONE
OF THESE HEARINGS THAT SAID THAT
WE ARE HARMING BLACK AND BROWN
CALIFORNIANS, THAT IS NOT TRUE.
WE EMPLOY THEM. WE GIVE THEM
GREAT JOBS, OKAY? WE GIVE
EVERYONE GREAT JOBS. AND SO THIS
IDEA THAT THAT OIL, WELL, OIL
COMPANIES LURKED INTO
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THEN DRILLED
WELLS WHERE THERE ARE HOUSES IS
FALSE. THE OIL WELLS WERE THERE.
THEY'VE BEEN THERE FOR 100
YEARS. AND THE VERY CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT THE AUTHOR IS
WANTING TO GIVE AUTHORITY TO
GAVE AUTHORITY TO BUILD HOUSES
RIGHT UP AGAINST OUR OIL WELLS
AND NOW IT'S OUR FAULT. IT'S
WE'RE BAD BECAUSE PEOPLE LIVE
NEAR OUR OIL WELLS, WHO, BY THE
WAY, WE GET ALONG WITH VERY
WELL, MOSTLY. AND SO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL, ON
BEHALF OF OUR 350 OIL PRODUCER
SERVICE AND SUPPLY COMPANIES AND
ROYALTY OWNERS AND OUR 55,000
STRONG WORKFORCE, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO AB 3233,
MADAM CHAIR MIKE MONAHAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE, COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS,
SENATOR, I CAN MAKE COMMENTS
NOW. IS IT? NOW'S THE TIME.
THAT'S WHY I'M STARING AT YOU.
ALL RIGHT, WELL, I THINK, AFTER
ALL THE HEARINGS WE'VE HAD ON
SIMILAR BILLS TO THIS, I THINK
EVERYBODY KIND OF KNOWS WHERE I
STAND ON THIS, IF WE WERE NOT
DEPENDENT ON OIL AT ALL, AND WE
WERE PRODUCING OIL AND SHIPPING
IT SOMEWHERE ELSE, I WOULD
PROBABLY SAY, YEAH, THIS MIGHT
BE A GOOD BILL. HOWEVER, OUT IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY, WE DON'T
PRODUCE ANY OIL, WE DON'T HAVE
ONE DARN OIL BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE AN OIL FIELDS UNDERNEATH
OUR OUR COUNTY. IF LÀ COUNTY, ON
THE OTHER HAND, DECIDED THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO PRODUCE A BAN
ON GAS, OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY, WE'D ALL
BE IN DIRE, DIRE STRAITS.
BECAUSE ALL OF OUR PEOPLE
COMMUTE, THEY GO THERE. 62% OF
THEM COMMUTE TO GO TO THEIR
THEIR JOBS. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
OIL USAGE RIGHT THERE, THE OTHER
THING THAT THIS FAILS TO MENTION
IS THAT A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE TODAY, INCLUDING THE
BUILDING, YOU'RE STANDING ON THE
PODIUM, YOU'RE STANDING IN FRONT
OF THIS TABLE AND ALL OF THE
THINGS AROUND IT ARE BYPRODUCTS
OF OIL. AND IF THE COUNTIES THAT
HAD THE OIL ALL DECIDE TO SHUT
DOWN, WHAT HOW HOW WOULD WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPLY MANUFACTURERS
WITH THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY NEED
TO BUILD US THE LIFESTYLE THAT
WE ARE ALL ACCUSTOMED TO, SO,
YOU KNOW, I THINK THIS THIS BILL
IS ABOUT 40 YEARS PREMATURE.
BECAUSE UNTIL WE STOP NEEDING
OIL, IT IS FOOLISH FOR US TO
THINK THAT SOMEHOW IF WE JUST
SHUT IT ALL DOWN, EVERYBODY'S
GOING TO BE HEALTHY AGAIN AND
MOVE ON THEIR WAY, THEY'LL BE
BROKE, WE WON'T HAVE ENERGY TO
KEEP US COOL WHEN IT'S WARM LIKE
IT IS TODAY, BECAUSE, AGAIN, A
LOT OF OUR ELECTRICAL NEEDS ARE
BASED ON, PETROLEUM PRODUCTS
THAT, YOU KNOW, GENERATE
ELECTRICITY AT NIGHT WHEN WE'RE
NOT GENERATING ENOUGH. AND RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE TO GENERATE A LOT.
SO IF WE WERE TO IF WE WERE TO
ENABLE JUST LOCATIONS THAT HAVE
THE OIL TO SHUT THEMSELVES DOWN,
THE ENTIRE STATE WOULD BE IN
TROUBLE. AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK
ONE OF THE GENTLEMEN WAS TALKING
ABOUT OVER THERE WAS, THIS ISN'T
JUST ABOUT ONE AREA, IT'S ABOUT
THE ENTIRE STATE. AND THAT'S WHY
WHEN WE HAVE STATE RESOURCES, WE
CAN'T ALLOW JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO SAY, HEY,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO WE'RE NOT
USING THAT. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
SHARE THAT. IF SACRAMENTO DIDN'T
SHARE WATER WITH US DOWN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, WE'D BE IN
BIG TROUBLE. SO, IF THE IF THE
ARIZONANS OVER AT BOULDER DAM
DECIDED THEY WERE GOING TO NOT
ALLOW HYDROELECTRIC, PRODUCTION
ANYMORE AND SHUT DOWN THEIR DAM,
WE'D ALL BE IN BIG TROUBLE. SO.
SO THIS ISN'T A LOCAL, A LOCAL
AGENCY ISSUE. THIS IS A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ISSUE. AND IT GOES
BEYOND THAT. IT'S A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ISSUE. AND THEN IF WE
HAVE TO GET OIL FROM OTHER
PLACES THAT, HAVE LESS
RESTRICTIONS THAN WE HAVE, THAT
ARE PRODUCING OIL IN A NON
ENVIRONMENTAL FRIENDLY WAY, THAT
DON'T HAVE ALL OF THE
REGULATIONS THAT, MONITOR
WHETHER THEY ARE ACTUALLY
POLLUTING OR NOT, IF, IF WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW THEM TO BE THE
PRODUCERS AND THEN PUT THEM ON
THEIR SHIPS AND SHIP THEM OVER
HERE FOR ALL OF THE OIL THAT WE
NEED, AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO BE
IN TROUBLE BECAUSE THE OIL THAT
WE DO HAVE THAT WE WOULD
DESPERATELY NEED BECAUSE THEN
WE'D BE SHORT OIL, THAT WOULD
COST US IF YOU THINK SIX BUCKS A
GALLON RIGHT NOW IS BAD, WE'RE
TALKING 15 TO $20 A GALLON. HOW
IS ANYBODY SUPPOSED TO AFFORD
THAT? ARE YOU GOING TO TELL
EVERYBODY TO GO OUT AND GET AN
ELECTRICAL CAR FOR $75,000?
WE'RE NOT THERE YET. WE DON'T
HAVE THE GRID TO SUPPORT THAT
PART. WE DON'T HAVE THE WE DON'T
HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO REPLACE
THE OIL THAT WE ARE DEMANDING
NOW. AND WE CAN'T JUST KEEP
TAKING OIL OFF THE GRID UNTIL WE
HAVE SOMETHING TO REPLACE IT
WITH. NOT A DREAM OF SOMETHING
TO REPLACE IT WITH, BUT THE
ACTUAL STUFF ON THE GROUND TO
REPLACE IT WITH. AND USUALLY
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, THE MARKET
MOVES ITSELF OVER AND THEN
THINGS DIMINISH AS YOU GO ALONG.
IT WILL NEVER, EVER GO AWAY
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE AS AS
CONSUMERS DEMAND IN THE
MARKETPLACE, NOT JUST FOR GAS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT ALL OF OUR
PRODUCTS, ANYTHING MADE WITH
PLASTIC, ALL OF IT. SO I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND BECAUSE I
THINK IT WOULD BE A, A LONG TERM
DISASTER FOR, FOR CALIFORNIA IN
OUR ECONOMY AND, AND SO, SO
THEREFORE, YOU KNOW, I
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE
HEALTHY, YOU KNOW, I, I SERVED
THE AREAS, THE AREAS THAT ARE
OIL PRONE CULVER CITY,
INGLEWOOD, ALL THOSE AREAS FOR A
LONG TIME. AND NEVER THE SIDE
EFFECTS OF OIL NEVER EVEN
CROSSED OUR MINDS OVER THERE. IT
DIDN'T, YOU KNOW, THE AIR WAS
VERY CLEAN. BECAUSE OF THE OCEAN
BREEZES AND STUFF. IF NOTHING
ELSE. SO THAT'S SOME OF THE
CLEANEST AREAS. AS FAR AS AIR IS
CONCERNED AROUND, SO, YOU KNOW,
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT CAUSE PEOPLE TO BE
UNHEALTHY AND, AND I THINK IT'S
THEY'RE PUTTING A LOT MORE
WEIGHT ON THE, THE OIL
PRODUCTION INDUSTRY FOR THAT
CAUSE THEN THEY PROBABLY
DESERVE. DO THEY HAVE A LITTLE
BIT. YEAH. BUT THAT'S OUR TRADE
OFF FOR HAVING WHAT WE HAVE. AND
SO WITH THAT, I'M NOT GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY,
BUT I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS. THANK YOU. YES, SIR. IS
A MOTION APPROPRIATE? I THINK WE
ALREADY HAVE ONE. OR YOU HAVE
ONE. OKAY. SENATOR WIENER. OKAY.
I, YOU KNOW, WE'RE ALL HAVING TO
RUN IN AND OUT OF COMMITTEE, SO
I DIDN'T KNOW WHO WAS, I WILL,
NOT ATTEMPT TO REBUT THE
TREATISE THAT WE JUST HEARD,
THOUGH IT IS QUITE REBUTTABLE,
OTHER THAN NOTING THAT WE ARE IN
SOME OF THE EARLIEST HIGH HEAT
DAYS, MAKING UP A HEAT WAVE IN
CALIFORNIA EVER RECORDED, WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW IN THE US, THE
HIGHEST CATEGORY, HURRICANE THAT
WILL IN THAT IT'S NOT HIT THE US
YET, BUT THE HIGHEST CATEGORY
HURRICANE IN THE EARLIEST DATE
DUE TO THE HIGH TEMPERATURES OF
THE OCEAN AND THERE IS NO
SCIENTIST. I SHOULDN'T SAY NO.
THERE'S ALWAYS A FEW SCIENTISTS,
BUT THE VAST, VAST MAJORITY OF
SCIENTISTS WILL SQUARELY AND
CERTAINLY POINT THAT TO THE FACT
THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY IN. AND
EXPERIENCING THE EXTREMES OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. AND IT WAS AN
AVOIDABLE CRISIS. WE DID NOT
AVOID IT BECAUSE OF OUR
DEPENDANCE ON FOSSIL FUELS. THAT
IS NOT REALLY WHAT'S GERMANE IN
THIS BILL. THIS BILL IS GIVING
SOME LOCALITIES THE RIGHT TO ACT
AS THEY FEEL IS APPROPRIATE. BUT
AGAIN, I WILL NOT GO THROUGH THE
ENTIRE TREATISE THAT MY
COLLEAGUE MADE OTHER THAN I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL, AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING IT.
OKAY. APPRECIATE THE, CHAIR'S
RECOMMENDATION, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GIVE CLOSING REMARKS? UNLESS
THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE? OKAY WELL,
I THINK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
CHAIR, AND THANK YOU FOR THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION. I KNOW THAT,
EACH PERSON ON THIS COMMITTEE
CARES DEEPLY FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY, CARES DEEPLY FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
ABSOLUTELY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. AND
I WILL JUST REITERATE, THERE ARE
NO MANDATES IN THIS LEGISLATION.
THIS IS SIMPLY ABOUT COMMUNITY
CHOICE. IT'S ABOUT LOCAL
GOVERNANCE AND LOCAL CHOICE,
WHICH I'VE BEEN A PROPONENT OF
ACROSS VENUES. AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. CALL THE ROLL MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS DURAZZO
I DURAZZO I SATO. SATO. NO.
DOLLY DOLLY. NO. GLAZER. SKINNER
SKINNER I WAHAB. WIENER 2 TO 2.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR MORE VOTES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALBORNOZ. OH,
THERE YOU ARE. OKAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ, YOU'RE HERE TO
PRESENT AB 2783. OKAY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, AND
THANK YOU, COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2783, THE SAN
DIEGO PORT REFORM AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. I WANT TO
THANK THE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL AND THE SENATORS
WHO, TOOK A MOMENT TO MEET WITH
ME TO DISCUSS WHY THIS
LEGISLATION IS IMPORTANT TO, TO
THE DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT, I
ALSO WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED, WITH A COMMITMENT AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE CAN
DISCUSS RESTORING THE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT FOR SOME CASES OVER
THE NEXT MONTH AS WE WORK
THROUGH THE LEGISLATION. AB 2783
IS A PRODUCT OF OVER 60 MEETINGS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS SAN
DIEGO, INCLUDING LABOR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SAN DIEGO
DELEGATION. THE BILL IMPLEMENTS
Kò REFORMS AIMED AT IMPROVING
TRANSPARENCY, ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT WITHIN THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO. THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO IS
A UNIQUE PORT IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A PORT DISTRICT WITH
MULTIPLE MEMBER CITIES, FIVE
MEMBER CITIES THAT WAS CREATED
BY THE STATE LEGISLATURE IN 1962
BY ESTABLISHING CLEAR GUIDELINES
FOR ETHICAL OVERSIGHT, THIS BILL
WILL ENHANCE THE PORT'S
PARTICIPATION AS A COMMUNITY
PARTNER AND ENSURE THAT PORT
DECISIONS ARE MADE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF ALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC, ESPECIALLY THE MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES THAT I
REPRESENT. I RECOGNIZE AND VALUE
THAT THE PORT'S ROLE IN SAN
DIEGO'S ECONOMY AND WORKFORCE. I
HAVE THREE MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY
WHO HAVE VERY GOOD JOBS IN THE
MARITIME INDUSTRY, IN THE PORT
OF SAN DIEGO, AND I WANT TO SEE
THE PORT CONTINUE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL, AS IT IS A BACKBONE
OF OUR ECONOMY IN SAN DIEGO'S
REGION. MANY OF THE REFORMS IN
THIS BILL ARE IN RESPONSE TO
RECOMMENDATIONS OUTLINED IN
GRAND JURY REPORTS ISSUED BY SAN
DIEGO COUNTY JUST LAST YEAR, THE
GRAND JURY FOUND THAT THERE'S A,
QUOTE, LACK OF OVERSIGHT,
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR AN ORGANIZATION WITH SUCH A
FAR REACHING POWER AND
JURISDICTION. IT ALSO REVEALED
CONCERNS AMONG PORT DISTRICT
STAKEHOLDERS, WHERE SMALLER
CITIES REPORTED, QUOTE, A LACK
OF FOLLOW THROUGH AND INVESTMENT
IN THEIR CITIES PROPORTIONAL TO
THE REVENUE GENERATED BY THE
PORT OF SAN DIEGO WITHIN THE
MUNICIPAL BOUNDARIES. AB 2783
RESPONDS TO THESE CONCERNS BY
ESTABLISHING AN INDEPENDENT
ETHICS REVIEW BOARD, SIMILAR TO
WHAT IS FOUND IN OTHER PORTS ON
THE WEST COAST. THE BILL ALSO
HAS BEEN AMENDED TO CODIFY THE
PORT'S EXISTING MARITIME
INDUSTRIAL IMPACT FUND, KNOWN AS
A MYTH, WHICH REQUIRES A PORT TO
SET ASIDE MARITIME REVENUE FOR
OFF TIDELAND PROJECTS THAT
MITIGATE IMPACTS THAT ARE
GENERATED BY THE MARITIME
ACTIVITY. ACCORDING TO CAL EPA'S
CALENVIROSCREEN TOOL, THE CENSUS
TRACKS ADJACENT TO THE PORT OF
SAN DIEGO SCORE IN THE 100TH AND
THE 99TH PERCENTILE IN EXPOSURE
TO DIESEL PARTICULATE AT THE
VERY TOP EXTREME END, THE
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT I, WHERE I'M
RAISING MY FAMILY IS IN ONE OF
THOSE RED SHADED. IF YOU'VE SEEN
THOSE CAL ENVIRO MAPS, THEY'RE
SHADED BY COLOR. COLOR CODED RED
SHADED IS, MEANS IT'S MOST
SEVERE ON THE CAL EPA'S SEVERITY
SCALE. SO THE MYTH THIS FUND CAN
HELP MITIGATE SOME OF THE HEALTH
DISPARITIES THAT WE HAVE SEEN,
JUST AS AN EXAMPLE, THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH HAS AN ANNUAL
ALLOCATION OF THE SAME TYPE OF
FUND FROM 3 TO $4 MILLION PER
YEAR TO HELP, AGAIN, SUPPORT
COMMUNITY INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
RELATED TO PORT ACTIVITIES. THE
PORT OF LA ALSO DOES THAT,
AVERAGING ALMOST $2 MILLION PER
YEAR. I HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE ELIGIBLE SPENDING CATEGORIES
AT THE MIFF AS WRITTEN, AND HOPE
THAT WE CAN ALSO CONTINUE TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION ON THIS
PROVISION TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDS GET USED TO HELP MITIGATE
THE REAL IMPACTS IN THE
COMMUNITY, I WILL SAY MY OFFICE
HAS WORKED IN REALLY GOOD FAITH
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO IDENTIFY
CHANGES MET WITH THE PORT
STARTING PRIOR TO THE BEGINNING
OF THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION,
BEFORE INTRODUCING THE BILL. AND
I RECOGNIZE THERE ARE ITEMS THAT
WE STILL DO NOT AGREE ON, BUT
CERTAINLY CONTINUE TO THE DIALOG
AS WE HAVE THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
PROCESS WITH ALL PARTIES. AB
2783 HAS BEEN AMENDED WITH A
REASONABLE BILL THAT IMPLEMENTS
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
STANDARDS FOUND AT PORTS AND
OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES. IT'S
SUPPORTED BY LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS. THE ASSEMBLY'S SAN
DIEGO BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS
DELEGATION, THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS AND THE ILWU LONGSHOREMEN
WORKERS WHO WORK ON THE PORT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR AGAIN. THE
CONSIDERATION AND NOW I'D LIKE
TO ASK OUR WITNESS. WE ONLY HAVE
ONE WITNESS, SO SHE MIGHT GO A
LITTLE OVER TWO MINUTES, BUT NOT
MUCH OVER TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON. AND DO I TURN IT ON
HERE? THERE WE GO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, CHAIR DURAZZO,
SENATORS AND STAFF, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY. I FLEW UP
THIS MORNING FROM SAN DIEGO. I'M
JUST A REGULAR CITIZEN,
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE, AND I LIVE
IN CORONADO, CALIFORNIA. SHOUT
OUT TO SENATOR DALL-E TWO
BECAUSE I USED TO LIVE IN RED
BLUFF IN CHICO FOR A DECADE, AND
I MISS MY NORTH COUNTY, I DO. I
REALLY DO. IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
PLACE. AB 2783 IS CRITICAL FOR
US IN SAN DIEGO. THE PORT
REMAINS A POWERFUL YET
UNACCOUNTABLE PUBLIC AGENCY, AND
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS,
IT'S BEEN ROILED IN SCANDALS IN
LAWSUITS AND UNEXPLAINED
DEPARTURES OF THEIR CFO AND
THEIR CEO, WITH PAYOUTS,
CENSURES OF THEIR COMMISSIONERS,
ABRUPT DEPARTURES OF
COMMISSIONERS, AND NOT A LOT OF
TRANSPARENCY HERE. THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE THE CONTINUOUS BROWN ACT
VIOLATIONS THAT HAPPEN, PUBLIC
RECORD ACTS, LAWSUITS THAT ARE
IN IN IN THE COURT SYSTEMS NOW.
AND THE THIRD OF THE THREE GRAND
JURY REPORTS IN A ROW THAT
SHARPLY CRITICIZED THE PORT'S
GOVERNANCE, WHICH THE PORT
REJECTED OUT OF HAND. FIRST, THE
INDEPENDENT ETHICS BOARD FOR THE
PORT IS AN ABSOLUTE IMPERATIVE.
THE PORT CONTENDS THEY ALREADY
HAVE A CODE OF ETHICS, BUT I'LL
REMIND YOU, SO DID ENRON
CORPORATION AND THE WEINSTEIN
FILM COMPANY. IT DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING UNLESS IT'S INDEPENDENT
OVERSIGHT, INDEPENDENCE AWAY
FROM GENERAL COUNSEL TO TRULY
SEPARATE THAT ETHICS. OVERSIGHT
IS A BEST PRACTICE IN EVERY
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY, AND IT
SHOULD BE IN THIS ONE, TOO. THE
GRAND JURY STATED, AND I QUOTE,
THE FIVE CITIES SPECIAL DISTRICT
IS LED BY A SEVEN MEMBER
UNELECTED BOARD OF COMMISSIONERS,
LARGELY AUTONOMOUS,
SELF-GOVERNING, SELF-FUNDED, AND
INDEPENDENT OF OVERSIGHT BY
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS.
CHANGING STATE LAW IS OUR ONLY
HOPE TO INSTITUTE THIS
INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT. AND
THAT'S WHY THE CITIZENS DOWN IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND THESE PORT
COMMUNITIES LOOK TO YOU TO BE
OUR VOICES. WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
HIRE LOBBYISTS TO LINE UP AT THE
MICROPHONE BEHIND US. WE'RE
HERE, AND I'M THEIR VOICE RIGHT
NOW. SECONDLY, THE MARITIME
IMPACT INVESTMENT FUND MUST BE
CODIFIED TO ENSURE THE SET ASIDE
IS ALLOCATED ANNUALLY AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ, WHO'S
NOT MY REPRESENTATIVE, BY THE
WAY, IT'S ASSEMBLYWOMAN BERNER
WHO'S MY REPRESENTATIVE AND
SENATOR ATKINS. THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO HAS CONSISTENTLY
UNDERFUNDED THIS SET ASIDE
COMPARED TO OTHER CALIFORNIA
PORTS. AS HE MENTIONED, IN TEN
YEARS, THEY'VE CONTRIBUTED JUST
OVER $2 MILLION. PORT OF LONG
BEACH SINCE 2009 HAS 50 MILLION
THAT THEY'VE SPENT IN THEIR
FUND. THE MODEL THAT OTHER
CALIFORNIA PORTS OPERATE UNDER
DEDICATES THESE FUNDS TO
MITIGATE THESE HEALTH IMPACTS IN
THE ADJACENT COMMUNITIES. AND MY
COMMUNITY. CORONADO, BY THE WAY,
IS IN THE 100TH PERCENTILE OF
DIESEL PARTICULATE POLLUTION,
AND CORONADO IS A WEALTHY
COMMUNITY. AND WE SHARE WITH
BARRIO LOGAN THE SAME POLLUTION
THAT IS AFFECTING AND IMPACTING
OUR HEALTH. SO I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO DETERMINE IF THE
PORT SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO DETOUR
FROM THE BEST PRACTICE THAT
OTHER PORTS FOLLOW, THAT THESE
FUNDS ARE FOR MITIGATION. THESE
FUNDS NEED TO GO TO HEALING
PUBLIC HEALTH. WE'RE IN THE 100
PERCENTILE, THE SAME CAL EPA
ENVIRO SCREEN SHOWS CORONADO IN
THAT. BUT THESE FUNDS NEED TO GO
TO HEALING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
CLEANING UP PORT NOT TO FUND
ELECTRIFICATION MANDATES. THESE
GRANTS ARE PLENTIFUL FOR
ELECTRIFICATION MANDATES FOR
PORTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AND
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THAT THE PORT
OF SAN DIEGO SHOULD SEEK THOSE
FOR THE ELECTRIFICATION, AS
WELL. FOR THOSE THAT SAY THAT
CORONADO HOST NAVY CARRIERS AT
OUR SITE, I'LL REMIND YOU THAT
ALL OF THOSE ARE NUCLEAR POWERED
AIRCRAFT CARRIERS, SO THEY BRING
CLEAN ENERGY. WE KNOW THIS COMES
DIRECTLY FROM THE PORT. THE PORT
IS A TERRIFIC ECONOMIC ENGINE.
IT DOES HAVE A LOT OF GREAT
JOBS. THOSE OF YOU WHO COME TO
VISIT US IN SAN DIEGO FLY INTO
IT. BUT THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO
CANNOT SHIRK THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO US OR TO
YOU. THERE ARE SHARED STATE
LANDS, AND WE IMPLORE YOU TO
CODIFY THESE REALLY ESSENTIAL
GUARDRAILS FOR THE PORT POWERS
THAT BE TO ENSURE THEIR
ACCOUNTABILITY, PROPER
GOVERNANCE, AND TRUE ETHICAL
OVERSIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2783? MARVIN
PINEDA, ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE
WAREHOUSE UNION LOCAL 9429,
REPRESENTING ALL THE ILWU
WORKERS AND THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MR. RUBALCAVA, WITH
NIELSEN MERKSAMER, ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF CHULA VISTA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY. ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB 2783, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. GOOD AFTERNOON.
THERE WE GO. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR. COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
JONATHAN CLAY HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO,
REGRETFULLY STILL REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED, WE APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM OVER THE
LAST 6 TO 8 MONTHS TALKING ABOUT
MANY OF THE ISSUES HE'S BROUGHT
FORWARD. UNFORTUNATELY, THOUGH,
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL IS
STILL AT A POINT WHERE WE FEEL
THAT WE NEED TO TRY AND SEEK
CHANGES. WE'RE COMPLETELY ALL
FOR ETHICS. AS HAS BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED, WE'VE HAD AN ETHICS
ORDINANCE IN PLACE SINCE 2001.
WE'VE HAD LOBBYIST DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS, AND FOR A LONG
TIME, OUR MAIN CONCERN WITH THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S BEING PUT INTO
THE BILL IS THE PRESCRIPTIVENESS
OF IT. THE PROBLEMS THAT IT'S
GOING TO CREATE. AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN TO REMOVE REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEES FROM THIS ETHICS
COMMISSION. THAT WOULD BE,
CREATED BUT LEAVE UNREPRESENTED
THERE. THE PROBLEM THAT CREATES
IS FIRST ONE WITH OUR HARBOR
POLICE HARBOR POLICE ABOVE THE
RANK OF LIEUTENANT ARE ALL
UNREPRESENTED. SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A CONFLICT WITH
THE GOVERNMENT CODE OVER WHO'S
GOING TO BE GOING TO WHAT PLACE
UNDER WHAT PROCESSES. SAME. THE
PORT HAS ALWAYS HAD A PORT
EMPLOYEES AND, EMPLOYEE REVIEW
BOARD THAT ALSO IS INDEPENDENT,
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE APPOINTED
TO THAT REVIEW. EMPLOYEE ISSUES.
AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
CONFLICT HERE. THE PROBLEM THAT
WE HAVE WITH THE WAY THIS
LANGUAGE IS STRUCTURED IS SINCE
WE'RE CODIFYING EVERYTHING VERY
PRESCRIPTIVELY ANY CHANGES THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO MAKE IN
ORDER TO MAKE THIS ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTABLE AND WORK IS GOING
TO REQUIRE US TO COME BACK
MULTIPLE TIMES, PROBABLY FOR
LEGISLATION, YOU KNOW. SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE ADVOCATING
FOR IS IF YOU'RE GOING TO PUT
ETHICS PROVISIONS IN THERE,
THAT'S GREAT. PUT OUT SOME OF
THE BASIC FRAMEWORK OF THAT. BUT
LEAVE IT TO AN ORDINANCE. SAME
WITH THE LOBBYIST DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT
UP IN THE PAST. OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES IN SAN
DIEGO HAVE ETHICS OR LOBBYIST
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS. THOSE
ARE ALL DONE VIA ORDINANCE. SAME
THING. WE ARGUE THAT. SURE, TELL
US IN STATUTE THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE THIS, BUT LET US DO THIS
VIA ORDINANCE. AGAIN, WE'RE A
PUBLIC ENTITY. WE HAVE TO COMPLY
WITH THE BROWN ACT, NOTICING
REQUIREMENTS, ETC, ETC. AS IT
RELATES TO THE CENSURE
PROVISIONS, IF THE ETHICS
PROCESS IS CREATED, THOSE SHOULD
BE TAKEN OUT. THAT ALL GETS
HANDLED UNDER WHATEVER'S GOING
TO BE THIS ETHICS PROCESS IN
TERMS OF AND AGAIN, THERE'S
PROVISIONS IN THERE ON
DISCLOSURE NOTICE. THAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE PLACE TO HAVE THESE
KIND OF CONVERSATIONS. THE
CENSURE STUFF UNFORTUNATELY IS
JUST RELATES TO A DISAGREEMENT
THAT MY BOARD HAD WITH A FELLOW
COMMISSIONER. AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S NECESSARY TO BRING UP TO
SACRAMENTO AND LEGISLATION AS IT
RELATES TO THE GRAND JURY
REPORT, I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
REPRESENTING THE PORT FOR 26
YEARS NOW. THIS IS, I THINK, MY
SECOND OR THIRD TIME OF SEEING
THIS VERY SIMILAR GRAND JURY
REPORT. AND THE PORT IS NOT
IGNORED. THIS WE'VE RESPONDED
EACH AND EVERY TIME TALKING
ABOUT THE PUBLIC TRUST. WHAT'S
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS IS THE
PORT IS MADE UP OF FIVE MEMBER
CITIES. IT WAS CREATED IN 1963
BY THIS LEGISLATURE. SENATOR JIM
MILLS, AND IT WAS MADE UP OF THE
FIVE CITY HARBOR DEPARTMENTS. SO
THESE ARE THESE WERE THE FIVE
CITIES THAT BROUGHT CAME
TOGETHER TO UNIFY THE OPERATION.
AND WHAT WAS DONE ON THE PORT.
THOSE CITIES STILL REMAIN IN
CONTROL OF THEIR COMMISSIONERS.
COMMISSIONERS SERVE AT WILL. IF
A CITY HAS A PROBLEM WITH
SOMETHING THEIR COMMISSIONERS
DOING, THEY CAN ASK THOSE
COMMISSIONERS TO COME BACK TO
THEIR COUNCIL, REPORT OUT TO
THEM. AND AS WAS RECENTLY
HAPPENED, THEY CAN EVEN REMOVE A
COMMISSIONER IF THEY FEEL THAT
THEY'RE NOT REPRESENTING THEIR
INTERESTS. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
KIND OF, MISUNDERSTANDING FROM
THE GRAND JURY IN TERMS OF HOW
THIS WORKS. I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF DESIRE TO DO DIFFERENT
THINGS WITHIN THE TIDELANDS. AND
AS OF TIDELANDS TRUSTEE, THE
PORT HAS TO MANAGE THIS ON THE
GREATER BENEFIT FOR THE STATE.
IT ALSO GETS LOST THAT THE PORT
HAS MADE AND OPERATES 23 PUBLIC
PARKS, FISHING PIERS AND BOAT
LAUNCHES. ALL AROUND SAN DIEGO
BAY. THE PORT WAS THE FIRST PORT
TO ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT. I'LL WRAP
UP, COLD IRONING OR WHAT IS NOW
CALLED SHORE POWER, WHERE, YOU
KNOW, CRUISE SHIPS, CONTAINER
VESSELS, PLUG IN THE PORT IS THE
ACCELERATING ALL THE HEAVY DUTY
TRUCK RULES TO TRY AND MEET THE
STATE'S GOALS INSTEAD OF IN
2030. BY 2026. THAT'S THE OTHER
DYNAMIC WE HAVE HERE. WE HAVE
THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
ON THE TIDELANDS VERSUS OFF THE
TIDELANDS FOR IMPROVING CLEAN
AIR. WITH THAT, WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
2783? SEEING NONE, AND YOU. I
GUESS THAT'S UP TO YOU, SENATOR
WIENER. YEAH OKAY. WE MOVE THE
BILL. ANY COMMENTS? QUESTIONS
NONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN, MADAM CHAIR.
AND AGAIN, THANK YOU TO YOUR
STAFF. REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY. I HAVE HEARD
SOME THINGS TODAY THAT I HAD NOT
HEARD BEFORE FROM THE
OPPOSITION, AS YOU ALL HAVE
LIVED THROUGH THIS, THE
OPPOSITION SOMETIMES CHANGES AS
THE COURSE OF BILLS, MOVE
THROUGH, WE'VE WORKED THROUGH
ALL THE PRIOR, OPPOSITION. WE
WERE ABLE TO REMOVE EVERYONE WHO
WAS OPPOSED TO THIS. THAT'S WHY
THERE'S NOBODY TESTIFYING. THAT
IS I THINK YOU ALL HAVE SEEN ME
DO THAT WORK HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. WE'LL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT. AND IF THERE IS A WAY
TO GET THERE WITH SUPPORT TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS, WE WILL
DO THAT, AND WE'LL BE THE FIRST
TO BRING THAT UP. BUT, AT LEAST
FOR NOW, THE BILL AS IT IS
BEFORE YOU, WITH THE AMENDMENTS
AS YOU'VE INTRODUCED, SEEM TO BE
APPROPRIATE TO MOVE FORWARD. AND
I RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. OKAY. THANK YOU. CAN
WE HAVE THE ROLL CALL, PLEASE?
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
DURAZZO, I, DURAZZO I. SATO.
DARLENE GLACIER. SKINNER. WAHAB
WIENER WIENER I220. I THINK YOU
THINK SO. OKAY, OKAY. WE'RE
LAST. LAST BILL. YEP THIS IS ONE
MORE DOOR. WOULD YOU CALL ON ME?
OH, YEAH. OKAY. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHES, I, ITEM 15, AB
2293, YOU MAY PRESENT. THANK
YOU. IT'S NOT GOOD MORNING, BUT
I'M HERE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF FOR THE
DILIGENCE AND HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL. THE COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
WAS VERY MUCH APPRECIATED AND
SHOWS BOTH THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL AND THE NONPARTISAN NATURE
OF THE ISSUE THAT IT IS
ADDRESSING. WITH THAT, I ACCEPT
ON HIS BEHALF, THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS BRIEFLY, AB 2293
WOULD ALLOW A 500 1C3
ORGANIZATION TO JOIN A JOINT
POWERS AGREEMENT FOR THE PURPOSE
OF PROVIDING HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AB 2293 REPLICATES AN
EXISTING AND PROVEN MECHANISM
THAT ALLOWS A 500 AND 1C3
ORGANIZATION TO PARTNER WITH A
JPA WHEN PROVIDING SERVICES TO
ZERO EMISSION TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS AND APPLIES IT TO HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. IN DOING SO. THIS
BILL PROVIDES A FLEXIBLE
SOLUTION TO IMPROVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WITHIN THE STATE. THE
JOINT POWER, THE JOINT EXERCISE
OF POWERS ACT AUTHORIZES TWO OR
MORE PUBLIC AGENCIES TO FORM
ANOTHER LEGAL ENTITY OR
ESTABLISH A JOINT APPROACH TO
WORK ON A COMMON PROBLEM. FUND A
PROJECT JOINTLY IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS, BUILD FACILITIES,
DELIVER SERVICES, OR ACT AS A
REPRESENTATIVE BODY FOR A
SPECIFIC ACTIVITY. JPAS ARE
COMMONLY FORMED TO WORK ON
PROJECTS THAT CONSTRUCT OR
IMPROVE GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT,
HABITAT CONSERVATION, AIRPORT
EXPANSION, MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITIES, REDEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS, EMPLOYEE BENEFITS
SERVICES, AND REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS. DESPITE
THE BENEFITS THAT 1C3 HEALTH
CARE ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES, THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE LARGELY
EXCLUDED FROM FORMING OR JOINING
A JPA. THIS EXCLUSION IS
ESPECIALLY PROBLEMATIC GIVEN THE
CURRENT CHALLENGES FACING
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE SYSTEM,
WHICH IS STRUGGLING TO MAINTAIN
OPERATIONS IN MANY REGIONS
ACROSS THE STATE. TO HELP
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES FACING
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE SYSTEM,
AB 2293 WOULD AUTHORIZE ONE OR
MORE PRIVATE NONPROFIT 500 AND
1C3 ORGANIZATIONS FORMED FOR THE
PURPOSES OF PROVIDING HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO JOIN A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY OR ENTER INTO A
JOINT POWERS AGREEMENT.
IMPORTANTLY, THIS BILL EXPANDS
HEALTH CARE ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT INCURRING
ANY FURTHER DEBT. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, AND THE
BILL PASSED THE ASSEMBLY WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND RECEIVED
NO. NO VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. AYE. THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, PLEASE?
NO. OKAY. ANY SUPPORT, TESTIMONY
AT ALL? ME TOO. OKAY. IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL?
OKAY. SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, DO WE
HAVE A. OH. YOU'RE HERE. GREAT,
SENATOR WAHAB MOVES THE BILL.
AND, MADAM CHAIR, YOU MAY CLOSE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY, WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS DURAZZO. DURAZZO I
DURAZZO. I SATO. DOLLY. GLASER.
GLASER I. SKINNER. WAHAB WAHAB I
WIENER. WIENER AYE 40 ZERO.
OKAY. THE. WE'LL PUT IT ON. HOLD
ON. CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT. YOU GUYS GOT
EVERYTHING DONE? EVERYTHING THE
VOTES, THE FUNDING, NOTHING.
WELL, THAT'S REALLY OKAY. THANK
YOU. THAT'S REALLY GREAT. THIS
IS THE NUMBER ONE QUÊ CAUCUS.
THIS IS THE CHAIR. OKAY OKAY.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THREE
COMMITTEES AT THE SAME TIME.
ALMOST, THE, WHAT'S THE OIL AND
GAS ONE, THAT'S ADDIS. TWO THOSE
TWO THINGS WERE ABOUT TO REACH.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. I'M READY TO GO.
OH, BOY. NO ALL RIGHT, WE'RE
GOING TO GET WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK AND FINISH, HOPEFULLY. OH,
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
LIFT CALLS. LIFT EIGHT CALLS.
LIFT ALL THE CALLS. WE'RE GOING
TO LIFT ALL THE CALLS. HERE WE
GO. ARE WE GOING TO DO ALL OF
THEM INCLUDING CONSENT? OKAY. WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO
0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SATO, DOLLY GLASER, THIS
IS CONSENT. AYE GLASER. I
SKINNER. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 40
ZERO SKINNER. LEFT I VOTED
ALREADY. YES. OKAY OKAY. ITEM
ONE SB 739. MOTION IS AT THE
ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN CURRENT VOTE IS 2
TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SEYARTO DOLLY GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. SKINNER. WAHAB
WAHAB. AYE. 40 ZERO. MOVE ON TO
ITEM TWO SCR 163. OKAY. MOTION
IS BE ADOPTED AND ORDERED TO
THIRD READING WITH CURRENT VOTE
IS 1 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR SEYARTO DOLLY
GLASER. SKINNER. WAHAB WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. TIÂU TWO ZERO OKAY.
NEXT ONE IS CONSENT. ITEM FOR AB
1893. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 421, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS.
GLASER AYE. GLASER. AYE. WAHAB.
1893. FIVE. TWO. ONE. OKAY. THE
CLOSE, CLOSE, CLOSE THE ROLL. ON
1893. ITEM FIVE, AB 2243. MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 1, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GLASER. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE 5 TO 1.
CLOSE THE ROLL. ITEM SIX AB
1413. OH. THAT'S CONSENT. SORRY
SORRY. 2371. YES. OKAY NEXT ITEM
IS ITEM NINE AB 2371. MOTION IS
TO PASS, AS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 3
TO 0. NO VOTE RECORDED FOR THE
CHAIR. SENATOR DURAZZO I DURAZZO
I DOLLY. GLASER. GLASER I WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE 6 TO 0. CLOSE THE
ROLL. NO. NO. YEAH. OKAY OKAY.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL ON THAT,
NEXT IS 2440 AB 2443. MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 1 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
DOLLY. GLASER. GLASER. AYE
SKINNER. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 41.
HOLD IT OPEN. NEXT IS AB 2235.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
SUGIARTO. HANG ON. LET ME GET
THERE. 2235 OH 1212. OKAY I KNOW
THAT'S THE DEBATE. I'M NOT
VOTING ON THAT. OKAY DOLLY.
GLASER. GLASER AYE. SKINNER.
WAHAB WAHAB I'M 40 ZERO. OKAY,
MOVE ON TO ITEM 13. AB 2257.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. CURRENT
VOTE IS 2 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR. CIERTO.
CIERTO. NO DOLLY GLASER.
SKINNER. WAHAB WAHAB. GLASER.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. 4 TO 1. NEXT IS.
WE JUST DID THAT. MATHES. SHOULD
WE DO THAT AGAIN? YEAH OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. ITEM 15 AB 2293. MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT BO IS 420 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR CIERTO
CIERTO I DOLLY SKINNER 5 TO 0.
OKAY. LEAVE IT OPEN. YEAH AB
2735. ITEM 16. MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR CIERTO CIERTO. AYE.
DOLLY GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
SKINNER WAHAB. WAHAB NO 41.
LEAVE THAT OPEN. ITEM 17 AB
2783. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR. CIERTO. CIERTO. NO
DOLLY. GLASER. GLASER. AYE
SKINNER. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 4 TO
1. NEXT ITEM 18. AB 2922. MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
SECRETO. AYE. COR. TÔI DOLLY.
GLASER. GLASER AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. 6 TO 0. ITEM 19. AB
3198. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 3
TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR CIERTO. CIERTO. AYE
DOLLY. GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
WAHAB. AB 3198. WAHAB AYE. 6 TO
0. LEAVE IT OPEN. ITEM 20 AB
2986. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
3 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR CIERTO. DOLLY
GLASER. GLASER. AYE WAHAB. 4 TO
0. LEAVE THAT OPEN, GO ON TO
ITEM 22, AB 3233. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
2 TO 2, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
NINE. SENATOR GLASER WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE WIENER. WIENER. AYE
42. LEAVE THAT OPEN. CLOSE THE
RULE ON THAT ONE. OKAY CLOSE THE
ROLL. WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING
TO RECESS, TO WAIT FOR A FEW
MORE MEMBERS. THANK YOU. WE DID
RIGHT BACK TO. OH, YOU DIDN'T DO
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. RIGHT? WE'RE
GOING BACK TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. YEAH, THEY'RE THEY'RE
DONE. MOTION IS ADOPT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR SATO.
SATO AYE. DOLLY. SKINNER. 5 TO
0. LEAVE THE RULES OPEN. PARDON
ME. CAN YOU DO ONE AND TWO? I'LL
BE. OH, SURE. SURE SURE. OKAY,
WE GO ON TO ITEM ONE, SB 739.
MOTION IS AT THE ASSEMBLY.
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR SATO.
SATO. AYE. DOLLY SKINNER VIÆT
ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN,
ITEM TWO IS SCR 163. MOTION IS
BE ADOPTED AND BE ORDERED TO
THIRD READING. CURRENT VOTE IS 2
TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR SATO, DOLLY GLASER.
SKINNER. WIENER 2 TO 0. LEAVE
THAT OPEN. OKAY, OKAY. NOW WE
CAN RECESS. OKAY. 20.
OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
WE'RE GOING TO ITEM 20 IS AB
2086. MOTION IS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR SATO. DOLLY WAHAB.
WAHAB AYE. VIÆT ZERO. IT IS NOT
THAT. NO. YOU THINK THAT THE
JOINT COMMITTEE CHAIR OF THAT
AUTHORITY. IS USING IT FOR
INSURANCE, RIGHT? OKAY. I'M
DONE. WERE WE SUPPOSED TO TAKE
THESE WITH US? I DON'T KNOW,
SENATOR BRADFORD TECH IS. SO
IT'S UP TO YOU. YEAH. OH.
SO IT'S JUST. DARLING.
WE'RE GOING BACK. TO ALL THE
BILLS, FIRST ONE IS CONSENT
CALENDAR. CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS DOLLY. DOLLY. AYE.
SKINNER SKINNER. AYE. 7 TO 0.
CLOSE THE ROLL. ITEM NUMBER ONE,
SB 739. MOTION IS AT THE
ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN CURRENT VOTE IS 5
TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS DOLLY. DOLLY. AYE.
SKINNER SKINNER. AYE. 7 TO 0.
CLOSE THE RULES. ITEM TWO SCR
163. MOTION IS BE ADOPTED IN
ORDER TO THIRD READING. CURRENT
VOTE IS 2 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR SATO, DOLLY.
GLASER. SKINNER WIENER. 2 TO 0.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
RECONSIDERATION OKAY, OKAY.
YEAH. I'M SORRY. THAT'S RIGHT.
MOTION MOTION FAILS. AND,
WITHOUT OBJECTION,
RECONSIDERATION WILL BE GRANTED.
OKAY, THAT'S TWO. THREE FOR ITEM
FOUR, A B. OH. IT'S CLOSED. OKAY
FIVE. NO THREE, THREE WAS SO
NINE. OKAY. SORRY FIVE. OH, ALL
THE WAY TO NINE. OKAY. GO TO
ITEM NINE AB 2371. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 620, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS.
DOLLY. DOLLY. AYE SEVEN ZERO.
CLOSE THE ROLL. TEN. OKAY. ITEM
TEN AB 2443. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 1 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
DOLLY. DOLLY. NØ. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. 5 TO 2. CLOSE THE
ROLL. YES. 1209 TO ITEM 12 AB
2235. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 0, WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR SATO,
DOLLY. I'M SORRY, 12. AYE.
DOLLY. AYE SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE
SIX. TWO ZERO. CLOSE THE ROLLS.
YES. ITEM 13 AB 2257. MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED, TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 4
TO 1, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS DOLLY. DOLLY. NØ.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. 5 TO 2.
CLOSE THE ROLES. ITEM 15 AB
2293. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
5 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATORS. DOLLY DOLLY. AYE.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. 7 TO 0.
CLOSE THE ROLL 16. ITEM 16 AB
TWO 735. MOTION IS DUE. PASSES
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 1 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATORS. DOLLY DOLLY. AYE.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. SIX. TWO
ONE. CLOSE THE ROLL. YES. THANK
YOU. 17. ITEM 17 AB TWO 783.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 1 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS.
DOLLY. ITEM 17, NOT SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE. 521. CLOSE THE
ROLES 18. ITEM 18. AB 2922.
MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
DOLLY. DOLLY. AYE 70 ZERO. CLOSE
THE ROLES. NEXT ITEM 19 AB 3198.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS DOLLY. DOLLY. AYE 7 TO
0. CLOSE THE ROLES. ITEM 20 AB
2986. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
5 TO 0, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR SUGIARTO DOLLY. 5
TO 0. CLOSE THE WORLD. YEAH AND
THE LAST ONE IS ITEM 22 AB 3233.
OH, WE DID OKAY. THAT'S IT. SO
WE'RE DONE. DONE. YEAH. WE'RE
NOT DONE. WELL DONE. OKAY, I
JUST WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
REALLY QUICK. I WANT TO GIVE, IF
I COULD GET EVERYBODY'S
ATTENTION, I WANT TO THANK THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
STAFF, THE WORK AND THE HOURS
THEY PUT IN TO MAKE ALL OF THIS
HAPPEN. BECAUSE WITHOUT BEING IN
PUBLIC SIGHT IS TRULY
ASTONISHING. I COULDN'T HAVE
ASKED FOR A BETTER TEAM.
SINCERELY. THANK YOU. ANTON.
JONATHAN ITZEL EVAN RYAN.
EVERYONE ELSE, PLEASE, ACCEPT MY
GRATITUDE. AND I'M SURE ON
BEHALF OF ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO THE PUBLIC, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION. WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA. THE SENATE COMMITTEE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS ADJOURNED.
YAY.